FOR WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
WILL LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS. TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. AND
TODAY ALL OF OUR CURRENT
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THAT
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM AND I'LL I'LL TRY TO
PAY ATTENTION SO I CAN SEE THAT
EACH TIME YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW IT WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO UNMUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TWO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WITH WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT ONE EIGHT.
TWO EIGHT ONE SEVEN FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL OF COURSE
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR-
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE'VE NEVER
HAD TO DO THIS SO I DON'T
EXPECT THAT WILL HAPPEN TODAY.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE. TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT TO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. BEFORE WE
BEGIN LET'S ESTABLISH YOUR CALL%
AKORN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ZERO HERE NIELSEN CALLER HERE.
WE HAVE A CORN SO WE'RE READY
TO BEGIN. WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THE ITEMS PROPOSED FOR
DISCUSSION STARTING WITH
PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION SO I JUST SO YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS
THAT ARE UP FOR VOTE ONLY. AND
WE WILL BE TAKING A VOTE AT THE
END OF THIS PROCESS BUT WE'LL
START WITH THE DISCUSSION ITEMS
AND THE FIRST ISSUE IS ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTEEN WHICH IS THE
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL UNDER THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY I WANT TO
WELCOME YOU HERE TODAY. AND I
UNDERSTAND SECRETARY CROSS
RIVER METIS YOU'RE GOING TO
START US OFF. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR. CHECKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN HEAR
ME THERE YOU GO THERE YOU ARE I
CAN. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M NEW TO THIS CUSTOMER MADE A
SENSE OF CHEER MENTIONED I'M
THE SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR GOT IT ALL AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S CALIFORNIA COMEBACK
PLAN I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF SECOND HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF OUR PROPOSALS
INCLUDING ISSUES FIVE EIGHTEEN
OF YOUR AGENDA AT THAT ARE
BUILT ON THE PRINCIPLE THAT AN
EQUITABLE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
MUST INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. A CENTRAL FOCUS
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMEBACK PLAN
IS ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS. THE
PLAN PROPOSES HOUSING SOLUTIONS
FOR THE FULL DIVERSITY OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND WITH A FOCUS
ON RACIAL EQUITY. IT PRESENTS A
BOLD PROPOSAL TO SCALE HOME KEY
WHICH IS BEING ADOPTED BY OTHER
STATES AND ALSO COURSE BY OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS AFTER NATIONAL
MODEL. THE PLAN ALSO ADVANCES A
COMPREHENSIVE IN MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH THAT SEEKS TO END
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. THIS
INTEGRATED APPROACH INVOLVES
WORKING CLOSELY AND IN
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN OUR AGENCY
AND THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. AND IT HONORS
A FACT THAT WILL PERMANENT
HOUSING AND THE NECESSARY
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ARE THE
ONLY TRUE SOLUTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF UNSHELTERED
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE FACING
URGENT AND DANGEROUS SITUATIONS
EVERY SINGLE DAY WHO NEED OUR
SUPPORT WITH A FOCUS
INVESTMENTS IN ENCAMPMENT
RESOLUTION EFFORTS. THE
GOVERNOR'S HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS PLAN ALSO CALLS
ATTENTION TO ACCOUNTABILITY
WITH A PROPOSAL TO CONDUCT ANY
LANDSCAPE ASSESSMENT OF LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND STATE FUNDED HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS. ON HOUSING PRODUCTION
AND PRESERVATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK IS FOREMOST IN THE MAY
REVISION. THE PLAN ENVISIONS
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL EXPEDITE THE CONSTRUCTION
OF SHOVEL READY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THAT WILL ALSO
PRESERVE THOUSANDS OF EXISTING
UNITS REACHING THE END OF THEIR
AFFORDABILITY COVENANTS. AND
THAT ALSO MAKES HEALTH AND
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS TO ENHANCE
THE LIVEABILITYAT THE H. C.
D.'S MIGRANT FARMWORKER HOUSING.
INVESTING IN OUR EXISTING
HOUSING STOCK ESPECIALLY FOR
OUR ESSENTIAL MIGRANT FARM
WORKERS. WHO'VE LABORED NONSTOP
DURING THE CALL BUT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IS CRITICAL. AND I'D
LIKE TO JUST THANK YOU AGAIN
SHARE COMMENT YET ALL FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. I REALLY APPRECIATED THE
TIME THAT WE SPENT TOGETHER
VISITING THE KING CITY MIGRANT
CENTER EARLIER THIS MONTH. THE
CALIFORNIA COME IN COME BACK
PLAN. THE LICENSE HOUSEHOLDS
AND PREVENTS DISPLACEMENT BY
PROVIDING DIRECT RELIEF TO
RENTERS LANDLORDS AND
HOMEOWNERS THROUGH EXPANDED
RENTAL ASSISTANCE. THROUGH
FORECLOSURE PREVENTION MORTGAGE
ASSISTANCE AND HOME BUYER DON
DOWN PAYMENT SUPPORT. THE PLAN
SEEKS TO HELP INDIVIDUALS AND
HOUSEHOLDS EMERGE FROM THE
PANDEMIC STRONGER AND MORE
RESILIENT THROUGH INVESTMENTS
IN PROGRAMS TO EXPAND
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN EIGHTEEN YOU
FINANCING FOR LOW TO MODERATE
INCOME FAMILIES WHO HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN LOCKED OUT OF
DEBT FINANCING OPPORTUNITIES.
THE MAY REVISION ALSO
PRIORITISES OUR STATED GOAL OF
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES. WE
KNOW THAT PLANNING WITH
COMMUNITIES AROUND SUSTAINABLE
LIVING IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MEETING THIS GOAL AND THEREFORE
THE PLAN PROPOSES TO IMPLEMENT.
AND PROVIDE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS FOR
REGIONAL ENTITIES TO CARRY OUT
COMPREHENSIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
PLANNING PROJECTS. THESE
COMBINED HOUSING INVESTMENTS
COUPLED WITH THE STRATEGIES AND
THE PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS WILL HELP UNLOCK
AT LEAST FORTY SIX THOUSAND NEW
HOUSING UNITS AND HOUSING
PLACEMENTS. COLLECTIVELY THESE
APPROACHES ADVANCE THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO EXPAND HOUSING
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY
INCREASES IN HOUSING PRODUCTION
STRENGTHENING ACCOUNTABILITY
AND FACILITATING EXPEDIENCY.
ALL WITH A FOCUS ON EQUITY. IN
CONCLUSION THE CALIFORNIA
COMEBACK PLAN LEAST A
FOUNDATION OR AN EQUITABLE
RECOVERY AND BUILDS UPON THE
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR A TOTAL
HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE OF TWELVE
POINT FOUR BILLION IN A HOUSING
PACKAGE OF NINE POINT THREE
BILLION. AS THE STATE CONTINUES
TO RECOVER AND BOLSTER LONG
TERM EQUITY AND RESILIENCY. AND
WE'LL BUILD UPON OUR CURRENT
MOMENTUM AND IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND WITH THE
SUPPORT OF FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WE KNOW THAT WE CAN MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON HOUSING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP. I AM JOINED TODAY
BY THE COLLEAGUES BY MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- BY MY TEAM TO PROVIDE
SUMMARIES OF THE ELEMENTS OF
THE PROPOSAL THAT IS INCLUDED
IN TODAY'S COMMITTEE AGENDA. I
WILL HAVE TO LEAVE AND- SHORTLY
BUT MY TEAM WILL BE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SECRETARY-
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
JOIN YOU ON THAT TOUR AND WAS
VERY. VERY HELPFUL I THINK IN
IN HELPING TO. UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUE OF MIGRANT HOUSING- AND
SO- APPRECIATE YOU TESTIFYING
HERE TODAY MOVING ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS. HE TALKS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO ADD AT
THIS TIME. VERY GOOD- HOW ABOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AFTERNOON THAT'S WHAT I
THAT'S WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. I WILL BEGIN
TODAY PROVIDING A FEW OVER
ARCHING COMMENTS ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS BEFORE
MAKING SOME MORE SPECIFIC
COMMENTS. THE GOVERNORS MAY
REVISION CONTINUES TO RECOGNIZE
THE STATE HMELESSNESS
CHALLENGES ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES HAS BEEN A PRIORITY OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR AND ARE WORTHWHILE
GOALS. IN THE NAME OF THE GEN
THE GOVERNOR SAYS THE GOAL TO
FUNCTIONALLY AND FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS AND FIVE YEARS. TO
DO SO HE INTRODUCES VARIOUS
PROPOSALS THAT NEW AND EXISTING
PROGRAMS ACROSS MULTIPLE STATE
ENTITIES. AT THIS TIME IT'S
UNCLEAR TO US HOW THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS OF THE GOVERNORS MAY
REVISION HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE
WOULD WORK TOGETHER TO MEET THE
SCHOOL. THE ADMINISTRATION DOES
NOT IDENTIFY INTRUM GOALS TO
MEASURE THE STATE'S PROGRESS
TOWARDS FUNCTIONALLY ENDING
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS IN FIVE
YEARS. IN ADDITION FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS IS ONE DIMENSION
OF THE STATE'S HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. THE LEGISLATURE WILL
HAVE TO ASSESS IF IT HAS COOLED
AROUND OTHER DIMENSIONS OF
HOMELESSNESS THE DISTRICT BASED
HOMELESSNESS. AND HOW THE
STATE'S BUDGET CAN HELP ADDRESS
THESE GOALS. THE GOVERNOR SOME
MAJOR HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS
LARGELY EXPAND EXISTING STATE
PROGRAMS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND EXPAND SOME STATE
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS THAT OFFER
HOUSING ASSISTANCE. RECNT
BUDGETS HAVE PROVIDED FLEXIBLE
FUNDING DIRECTLY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO THEY CAN ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. THE MAY REVISION
DOES NOT INCLUDE THIS TYPE OF
PROPOSAL. THE LEGISLATURE WANT
TO ASSESS IF IT IS COMFORTABLE
WITH THIS CHANGE OR WHETHER IT
WOULD LIKE TO MAINTAIN FLEXIBLE
FUNDING DIRECTLY TO LOCALS. AS
THE FUTURE OF THE STATE
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE. TO WRAP
UP MY GENERAL COMMENTS IN THE
PASTORAL PROCESS RECOMMENDED
THE LEGISLATURE ESTABLISH A
PLAN FOR ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. THE GOVERNOR'S ME
REVISION LAYS OUT ONE POSSIBLE
APPROACH NOW THE LEGISLATURE
WILL HAVE TO ASSESS IF IT
CONCURS WITH THIS APPROACH
WHETHER WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE
MODIFICATIONS TO TAKE A
DIFFERENT APPROACH. TURNING TO
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S ANY REVISION. MANY
OF THESE PROPOSALS WILL REQUIRE
LEGISLATION TO IMPLEMENT WHICH
IS NOT YET AVAILABLE. THERE ARE
VARIOUS OUTSTANDING
IMPLEMENTATION CONSCIOUS
QUESTIONS THAT COULD BE
ADDRESSED THROUGH TRAILER ABOUT
LANGUAGE. FOR EXAMPLE HOW WOULD
LESSONS LEARNED OVER THE LAST
YEAR ABOUT HOME HE INFORMED HOW
THE PROPOSED THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
WOULD BE USED. AS AN EXAMPLE
HOW COULD YOU FACILITATE THE
USE OF A DIFFERENT MIX OF
FACILITIES. AS HOTELS AND
MOTELS MAY NOT BE AS READILY
AVAILABLE FOR USE TO HOME KEY
AT THE EFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC
SUBSIDE. IN ADDITION THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND THE
STATE'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK IN RECENT BUDGETS. THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES MAJOR
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATIONS. THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE TO
DETERMINE HOW WILL PRESERVE
THESE GAINS IN THE LONG TERM.
IN PARTICULAR IN THE CASE OF
HUNKY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE PLANS FOR
OPERATING SITES FOR FIVE YEARS.
HELLO HOPE YOU SAID TO BE
OPERATED AND MAINTAINED BEYOND
THOSE FIVE YEARS IS UNCLEAR.
THIS IS CERTAIN HE CAN MAKE
SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
BEEN HESITANT TO PARTICIPATE OR
COULD CREATE FISCAL PRESSURES
FOR THE SEAT IN THE LONG TERM
AS IT TRIES TO PROTECT HOME
CAMPUS MONTHS. THE STATEMENT
WANT TO CONSIDER HOW IT
BALANCES CAPITAL INVESTMENTS.
AND OPERATING COSTS WITHIN
HOKEY. THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
SPEND THE MAJOR APPLICATIONS
WITHIN THE PROPOSED TIMELINES
IN THE REVISION IS ALSO
UNCLEAR. IN MANY CASES THE
PROPOSE FUNDING IS MANY ORDERS
OF MAGNITUDE ABOVE WHAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED PREVIOUSLY FOR
PROGRAMS. IN PARTICULAR THE
THREE POINT FIVE BILLION IN
FUNDING ACROSS TWO YEARS FOR
HOCKEY. AND THE FUNDING WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IS SIGNIFICANT
COMPARED TO PRIOR YEARS. CAN
RESCUE COMPANY IS AVAILABLE
THREE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THE
LEGISLATURE CAN CHOOSE TO
ALLOCATE A PORTION OF PROPOSED
SPENDING. MORE CLOSELY ALIGNS
WITH EXPECTED CAPACITY AND
ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL FUNDS LATER
THIS WILL PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
MAKING POLICY DECISIONS ABOUT
ITS APPROACH TOWARDS ADDRESSING
THE STATE HOMELESSNESS
CHALLENGES. FOR SOME OF THE
GENERAL FUND PROPOSALS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ELECTRICITY
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
CONSIDER. TRADE LIBERAL TO MAKE
SOME MOVES. ON TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE KNOWN BARRIERS TO SET
THESE PROGRAMS COULD EXPAND
ACCESS AND ENHANCED ITS ABILITY
TO SPEND THE PROPOSED
AUGMENTATIONS. FINALLY THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS MANY STATE
DEPARTMENTS. IT WILL BE MORE
CRUCIAL THAN EVER FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO SET CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS THROUGH. STATUTE
AND BUDGET THE LANGUAGE
ESTABLISHING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WILL ALSO HELP THE
LEGISLATURE EXERCISE OVERSIGHT
OVER THE STATE'S PROGRESS FOR
DRESSING HOMELESSNESS. THESE
ARE JUST A FEW OF OUR INITIAL
COMMENTS ON THESE PROPOSALS AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO ANALYZE THEM.
I DO DIGITAL- THOUGHTS AND
GUIDANCE AT THE TRAILER BILL
BECOMES AVAILABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR-
YOUR COMMENTS AND- INSIGHTFUL.
SPECIFICITY PRECIADO VERY MUCH-
LET ME SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
DYESS. SENATOR NIELSEN. I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR THE AGENCY
SECRETARY. LET'S SEE IF SHE'S
STILL AVAILABLE. OR ANYBODY
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION. I
DOUBT THAT THE SECRETARY FOR
HOMELESSNESS I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
HOMELESS INSIDE AND WE HAVE OUR
COLLEAGUES H. D. IF IT RELATES
TO SOME OF THAT HOUSING
PROPOSALS LATER IN THE AGENDA
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN GET. HER UP
ON THE SCREEN. I THINK WE HAD
THE SECRETARY BRIEFLY. AND I'M
SURE YES I'M STILL HERE STILL
HERE OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I APPRECIATED YOUR OPENING
REMARKS. I'D LIKE TO. A LITTLE
BIT MORE SPECIFIC FROM BOTH THE
FRONT END AND BACKEND. IN
DEALING WITH THE HOMELESS
POPULATION. HAVE YOU
CONTEMPLATED PLANS FOR
ASSESSING THE NEEDS OF THE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL
BE COMING IN FOR THE SYSTEM TO
BE ASSISTANT HERE WHAT DO I
MEAN BY THAT. WHAT ARE THEIR
NEEDS THAT ARE PUTTING THEM IN
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE MANY OF THEM
HAVE SUBSTANCE ABUSE ALCOHOL
ABUSE. ILLNESSES THICKNESSES
THAT ARE PERSISTING AND IF MY
THOUGHT THAT. PROVIDING SHELTER
IF YOU WILL IS NOT THE ANSWER
IT'S PART OF THE HATCH BUT IT
IS NOT THE ANSWER IN KIND OF
THE CORE IS TO ASSESS THEIR
NEEDS AND WE'RE GOING TO HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS CAN WE DO THAT AND
ERRORS WERE IN THERE ARE
SERVICES AVAILABLE YOU
MENTIONED THE MADAM SECRETARY
SERVICES. SO I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT YOUR SCOPE OF SERVICES
THAT WE'RE GOING TO IDENTIFY AS
WE PROVIDE HOUSING NOW THAT
WOULD BE AT TE BACK END AT THE
FRONT END RATHER AT THE BACK
AND THEN HOW ARE WE GOING TO
ASSESS THE SUCCESS. OF THIS
PARTICULAR INVESTMENT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
FOR THAT FOR THAT QUESTION I
THINK IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION AND IT IS- DEFINITELY-
PART OF OUR OVERALL APPROACH
AND LET ME JUST START OFF BY.
ANSWERING A FEW COMPONENTS- AND
THEN I WILL TURN IT OVER TO A
DEPUTY SECRETARY ALLEY SEVEN-
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
HOMELESSNESS. AND ALSO ASKED
FINANCE IT BE LIKE TO CHIME IN
ON TRUMP SPENT. THAT PROPOSALS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT
SPEAK TO THE SERVICE SINCE-
INVESTMENTS IN THE SERVICE
COMPONENT. AT FIRST I WILL JUST
SHARE- AS- I MENTIONED BRIEFLY
IN MY REMARKS THAT. THE STATE
HAS IN BEEN INVESTING- IN
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE. GOOD
DATA PROPER DATA TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND. THE SCOPE OF
HOMELESSNESS STANDARD TYPES OF
HOMELESS. SERVICES THAT ARE
BEING PROVIDED- THROUGH THE
FORTY FOUR CONTINUE ON SOME
CROSS THE STATE ANSWERED TWO
MONTHS AGO- ARE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL. LAUNCH THE HOMELESS
DATA INTEGRATION SYSTEM THIS IS
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND IN THE
STATE- THAT IS THE FIRST. OF
ITS KIND IN TERMS OF A DATA
WAREHOUSE. WHERE WE HAVE- FOR
THE FIRST TIME A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE SYSTEM.
OF THE TYPES OF SERVICES OUT OF
THAT- INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
ACCIDENT SCENE. IT ALSO BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE OUTCOMES-
AND THE STRATEGIES THAT ARE
WORKING. AT SO WE FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT HAD SEEN. THE DATA
AND THE BASS LINE WILL ENABLE
US TO WORK MORE CLOSELYWITH
COMMUNITIES- TO. LEARN ABOUT
BEST PRACTICES AND WHAT'S
WORKING THE SCALE- THOSE
PROGRAMS OR INITIATIVES THAT
WORK. AND ALSO TO- TO WORK WITH
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS ALSO WHEN
ADVOCATING FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WHERE NECESSARY- BUT
BUT FRANKLY I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT- THE APPROACH
TO ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS
REQUIRES. A DEEP. INVESTMENTS
IN HOUSING BUT IT ALSO WE'RE
CHOIR SAID WE- INTO- THIS TO
RESOURCE- NOW. TO ENSURE THAT
IN. ARE FAMILY AND SAY MOVED IN.
APARTMENT HOUSING BUYER. THAT
THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO STAY HEALTHY
AND TO BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW TO
BE SUCCESSFUL. AND SO LET ME
JUST ASK A DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
HOMELESSNESS SALLY IF SHE'D
LIKE TO ADD ANY ADDITIONAL
DETAILS. YEAH I'D BE HAPPY TO-
A COUPLE OF THINGS ON THAT THE
SERVICES BY- BUT I WOULD LIKE A
CALL OUT OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES I
KNOW THIS IS BEING HEARD IN A
AND ANOTHER- SESSION LATER THIS
WEEK BUT WE JUST MENTIONED THAT
THERE ARE A HANDFUL. A PROPOSED
X. TO AN APARTMENT SERVICES
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD INCLUDE-
HOUSING RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND
SERVICES. I WILL SPEND- I KIND
OF TREND GOING STRONG AND
THERE'S QUITE A FEW BUT WE JUST
CAUGHT A COUPLE SPECIFIC ONE.
RELATED TO THE FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL THERE IS.
A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
AND EXPANSION- PROPOSE FOR ARMS
ARE HIGHLY DESIRED COLORS I
THINK SUPPORT PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDES THINGS LIKE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE- AS WELL AS A POINT
OF REFERENCE SERVICES FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE HOMELESS AND
ON CAL WORKS- THERE'S ALSO A-
PROGRAM. EXPANSION FOR OUR
MEDIUM IS HOME TO AROUND WHICH
IS SPECIFIC TO CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVED YOU MIGHT EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WHICH WOULD ALSO
HAVE. THE TIME TO WRAP AROUND
SUPPORT SERVICES I HAD ANOTHER
ONE I WOULD JUST CALL OUT. IN
THE HOUSING DISABILITY.
ADVOCACY PROGRAM THERE'S ALSO.
A PROPOSED EXPANSION PACK FOR.
WHICH IS VERY MUCH HARD AT-
THAT ARE OUT. FOR ACCESS BY OUR
ACTIONS. AND WHO AM I HOME AND
A TO FOR OPEN. GET BACK PACKAGE
YES WELL AS- AT HOUSING OR SO
THERE IS. QUITE A FEW OF THESE
ARE THAT WORKS TO NOW REALLY
RATE AND HOW THEY SUPPORT AND I.
SUPPORT SIR. AS THEY DON'T SEE-
OF THOSE. WELL IT IS MENTIONED
IN ONE OF THE KEY PIECES UP THE
ACTUAL PROPOSED TAX PLAN IS
ALSO AROUND ACCOUNTABILITY IF
YOU'RE GOING AROUND. HI HOW ARE
YOU MEASURING THE STAFF IS
EXCITED ABOUT YOUR TRADE TALKS
EXTENSIVELY ABOUT EACH YEAH I
ASK. THE MEDIA MIGHT ALSO
PROPOSES FIVE. POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE HOME OF
BIRMINGHAM FINANCING COUNSEL TO
CONDUCT A LANDSCAPE ASSESSMENT.
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
OUR EARNINGS IN OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY. EFFORTS TO JUST
CALL BACK.
AS THEY COME INTO
THE SYSTEM THEY'VE BEEN
ASSESSED WITH THE CERTAIN KIND
OF SUBSTITUTION EIGHT. THEY GET
PLACED IN THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT AS THEY WERE DEALING
WITH THEIR PROGRAM THAT'S THE
KIND OF THE NITTY GRITTY
INFORMATION I'M- CURIOUS THAT
WE COULD BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY.
MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT
WERE MANAGING ARE ACTUALLY
HELPING SERVICES I'M AGENCY AND
SOMEONE SO IN I'LL- GET IT TO
THEM TO SORT OF TALK ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE PLANNING ON ORDERING
AND TRACKING THEIR DATA
SPECIFICALLY I WILL SAY THAT
HE- HAD BEEN BACK AT THE STATE
LEVEL REQUIRED TO BE ABLE TO BE
TRACKED. YEAH YEAH- IS THERE
SOMEBODY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ON. BETTER IT
THAT IS ON THE LINE THEY CAN
ADDRESS SUCH QUESTIONS AND
THAT'S BEEN ASKED BY SENATOR
NELSON. HI I DON'T SEE IT ON MY
FINANCE THERE'S NO ONE ON THE
LINE FROM SOCIAL SERVICES BUT I
WILL HIGHLIGHT THE FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION DOES PROPOSE FOR
HDFC TO DO A LANDSCAPE
ASSESSMENT. OF THE LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND THE STATE FUND ANALYSIS OF
HOMES PROGRAMS AT THE STATE
LEVEL NOT BE I BELIEVE THAT
ANALYSIS WILL GET YOU SOME OF
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR. AND NOW YOU CAN
CHIME. IN ELABORATE ON THAT
PROPOSAL. HE I MENTIONED IT
BRIEFLY I THINK THAT THE
LANDSCAPE ASSESSMENT BUT WE'RE
PLAYING ON CONDUCTING BE
ORDINATION. AND- BUILDING OFF
OF WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED AND
HAVE AVAILABLE IF ANY SHE
ADDED. IT WOULD MOST CERTAINLY
BE TAKING A LOOK AT. THE YOU
KNOW THE VERY DIVERSE WAITING
OUT HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE
SYSTEMS ARE ARE PLAYING OUT
LOCALLY UNDERSTANDING WHERE
THEY'RE INVESTING. WHAT
STRATEGIES ARE INVESTING MOST
IN AND BEING ABLE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT OUR STATE FUNDED
PROGRAMS. AND TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IF THERE'S WAYS THAT
NEED TO BE LOOKING AT OUR STATE
FUNDED PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
RANGE OF INTERVENTIONS. IN A
DIFFERENT WAY OF UNDERSTANDING
HOW. OUR CURRENT INVESTMENTS
MATCHES WHAT REALLY IS IT
pLEVEL I USUALLY THAT WOULD
TRACK SOME OF THOSE STATE
FUNDED PROGRAMS UNDERSTANDING
WHAT KIND OF INTERVENTIONS.
THOSE PROGRAMS FIND THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE. ECOSYSTEM AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IS HAPPENING
I'M I'M THE LOCAL. LEVEL AND IF
THAT IF THAT. THE MAN FROM FIND
THEY JUST FOR- A LITTLE BIT OF
A- ALMOST. LITERALLY A PICTURE.
OF MY CAR OF WAR BEEN. AND
DEALER WITH THE HOMELESS. WE H.
LIKE IN PAINTER WE GET A BUCKET
OF PAINT. A BRUSH COME INTO A
ROOM A BIG LARGE WHITE WALL AND
THEN JUST. THROWING THE PAINT
ON THE WALL. THAT'S BEEN MY UP
FOR IMPRESSIONABLE OF WHAT
WE'VE DONE AND I HOPE THAT'S
WHAT I'M TRYING TO BE MORE
SPECIFIC I THANK YOU FOR TRYING
TO. HELP US OUT GET A LITTLE
BIT MORE SPECIFIC SO WE CAN
KEEP TRACK. OF THOSE
POPULATIONS AND HOW THEY ARE
PROSPERING HOPEFULLY. NOT NOT A
PRESIDENT THEN HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION BUT I'LL DEFER FOR NOW
PLEASE OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR I
APPRECIATE THAT. THE WHERE
YOU'RE GOING WITH THIS BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD SOME SIMILAR
DISCUSSIONS IN THE PAST ABOUT.
TRYING TO DOCUMENT SOME DATA
AND UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT
BETTER WHAT'S WORKING AND
WHAT'S NOT. RIGHT BY REGION
CENTER CAMO- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO BE PART
OF THE CHOIR- THAT IS SINGING-
AS IT RELATES TO THESE
QUESTIONS AND I THINK I ALSO
HAVE A QUESTION FOR- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. ON ANYONE ELSE WHO
WHO. CAN MAYBE ADD SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION YOU
KNOW- I SEE THEIR PROPOSAL FOR
OUR HOME HE- AND THE- THE-
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE
STABILITY- THAT- AROUND THE-
PROGRAMS FROM PROJECT ROOM KEY.
AND YOU KNOW I'M- BEING IN LA
SO MY QUESTION IS GENERALLY
AROUND SORT OF ACCOUNTABILITY
WITH THESE FUNDS. AND TRACKING
HOW WE ARE PULLING PEOPLE OUT
OF HOMELESSNESS AND THE REASON
WHY I AM ASKING THE QUESTION IS
BECAUSE A LOS ANGELES COUNTY-
52% OF OUR HOMELESS POPULATION
IS AFRICAN AMERICAN. 35% OF OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION IS LATINO
OUR ANGLO HOMELESS POPULATION
HAS DECREASED BY 7% AND YET
WHEN WE ADMINISTERED PROJECT
HOME KEY IN MY COUNTY- THE
ROOMS THAT WERE THE ONES THAT
WERE MADE AVAILABLE TO HOMELESS
FOLKS WERE DISPROPORTIONATELY.
PROVIDED TO WHITE ANGELENOS AND
SO AS WE CONTINUE TO INFUSE
GREATER DOLLARS INTO ATTACKING
AND COMBATING THE ISSUE AROUND
HOMELESSNESS I THINK IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WERE ALSO
PRETTY HONEST ABOUT WHAT HOW
AND WHERE THE MONEY IS BEING
DISTRIBUTED. AND WHAT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS ARE THAT
WE ARE LOOKING FOR AND
DEMANDING TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE. HAS EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
TO GET OFF THE STREETS AND IS
THERE ANYTHING IN ANY OF THESE
PROPOSALS THAT WILL ADDRESS
THAT IF THAT IS PART OF THAT
SURVEY LANDSCAPE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT OR SOMETHING ELSE I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW. YEAH I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION AND WE
DO EXPECT THAT THOSE ARE THE
SORTS OF QUESTIONS WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT. THE LANDSCAPE MEANT
I WOULD ALSO JUST MENTIONED
THAT EACH YEAH I ASKED THE
PUBLIC BURDEN IS THAT WHY HE
NOW HAS A WHOLE SECTION
SPECIFICALLY DEDICATED TO
RACIAL DISPARITIES WE ARE
WORKING VERY VERY CLOSELY BY
CONTINUING CARE RIGHTNOW I'M-
PROVIDING THAT. THAT DATA WITH
THEM AD HELPING THEM
UNDERSTAND HOW BEST TO USE THAT
AND TARGET AND AN ADDRESS. THAT
STAND THEIR SYSTEM I WOULD ALSO
MENTION YOUR REALLY NEEDS THAT
HAVE AROUND YOU HI THE EQUITY.
WEIGHT AND IT'S- PERFORMANCE
THAT HURTS SO WE ARE WITH
HAITI'S RIGHT NOW RIGHT HERE
NOW ON A FRIEND YOU. TO ENSURE
THAT THEY MET RACIAL EQUITY
BUILDING CAN HELP THEM WORK IT
WITH THAT BACK. ADAM VERY MUCH
A FOCUS ON THE WORK WE ARE
DOING IT CREATING A- COUNCIL
VERY WE THEY- CRITICAL P. I
HATE THAT WE VERY MUCH THE KIND
OF WORK WE'RE LOOKING AT-
THROUGH THE LATE. THOSE TYPE
ALASKA'S DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT- THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION ABOUT
HOME KEY- SENATOR- WE RELEASED
ON APRIL FIRST A COMPREHENSIVE
REPORT- THAT WAS RIGHT ACTUALLY
REQUIRED BY THE LEGISLATURE-
ONE HOME KEY ON THE NINETY FOUR
PROJECTS THAT WERE PART OF HOME
Q. LAST YEAR- PRODUCING OVER
SIX THOUSAND. NEW UNITS OF
PERMANENT HOUSING FOR PERSONS-
THAT WERE HOMELESS OR AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS AND I WAS
ACTUALLY JUST TRYING TO FIND
RIGHT NOW THE PAGE BECAUSE
THERE IS A SPECIFIC INFORMATION
THAT WE PROVIDED IN THE REPORT-
BILE- THE NOT ONLY DID REGIONAL
DISTRIBUTION OF THESENINETY
FOUR PROJECTS BUT ALSO HOLD
THEY SERVED AS IN IN INCLUDING
THEM YOU KNOW WITH THE EQUITY
LENS THAT YOU MENTIONED SORT
OF- RACE AND ETHNICITY AND WE
HAVE ALL THAT DATA. IN THE
REPORT SO- I. D. WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT YOU GET A COPY OF
THAT REPORT- BECAUSE IT HAS ALL
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU ARE
ARE POINTING OUT WHICH I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO.
THOSE THAT ARE MORE AT AT AT
THE NEEDIEST PERSONS- AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE WERE VERY
INTENTIONAL DURING THE COLD
HERE WE PLAN TO CONTINUE AS
PART OF THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR WALKMAN COMPUTING. FUTURE
THANK YOU FOR THAT I IT'S ALSO
IN. TO ACKNOWLEDGE- YOU KNOW
OUR WHOLE POP. IS NOT A
MONOLITHIC GROUP THERE ARE
FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN HOMELESS
FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
THERE HAVE BEEN HOME FOLKS WHO
ARE HOMELESS. FOR EXTENDED
PERIODS OF TIME IT IS MORE THAN
JUST OR DEEPER THAN JUST SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE HOUSING
AND MENTAL HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH-IS A VERY. BROAD BRUSH STROKE
IT TOO WAS A WATERCOLOR IF I'M
GOING TO- SHARE THE ANALOGY
GIVEN BY- MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
NIELSEN- YOU KNOW THERE IS
TRADE THAT HAVE. THERE KINDS OF
AKON THAT- THERE DO KIND OF.
THAT ARE OF TO SINGLE. HOMELESS
AS A TO- FAMILY OR THE WITH
TWO- FIRST WOMEN. I YOU KNOW
HOW YOU MAY- SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
HOME FOR TH NINE YEARS- IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN HOW YOU. MANAGE
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN HOMELESS
FOR. MAYBE LESS THAN ONE OR TWO
OR IS HOMELESS AND WORKING SO I
AM HOPING THAT PART OF THESE
PROPOSALS ALSO RECOGNIZED THAT
KIND OF NEW ONES. AND THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THE STATE
NEEDS TO BE USING- AND
INCORPORATING INTO THE GRANTS
AND THE FUNDING THAT IT IS
GIVING OUT TO LOCALITIES- TO
COMBAT THIS ISSUE. I JUST HAVE
ONE- FINAL QUESTION MADAM CHAIR
AND IT'S ME IT'S ME IT'S. A
EXAMPLE. YOU KNOW ON MOTHER'S.
HI I WAS IN MY DISH IN A FAN OF
FIVE- LIVING IN THEIR CAR. OF A
MAN AND HIS WIFE AND THEIR
THREE KIDS- AND THEY HAVE BEEN
HOMELESS. BECAUSE THEY GO TO
THESE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND TO OUR-
CITIES IN OUR COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS TO FILL OUT
PAPERWORK AFTER PAPERWORK AFTER
TO PAPERWORK AND FOR A REASON
AFTER ANOTHER THEY ARE EITHER
DENIED A SERVICE OR ARE ASKED
TO COME BACK. SO THAT
DEPARTMENT- THATORGANIZATION
IS STILL EARNING REVENUE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SEEN AN
APPLICANT BUT THE APPLICANT HAS
NOT GOTTEN ANY SERVICE. AND AS
I TALKED TO THIS FAMILY FOR
TWENTY FIVE MINUTES ON MOTHER'S
DAY WATCHING STARS BABY COVER
HERSELF IN YOGURT. AND
LISTENING TO THEM TELL ME THAT
THEY ARE LIVING WITH THE
DIGNITY THAT THE STATE HAS
DECIDED TO GIVE THEM. I AM
COMPELLED TO ASK WHAT IN THESE
PROPOSALS ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
WE ARE SENDING PEOPLE MILES AND
MILES AWAY TO GET SERVICES THAT
FOR ANY REASON AFTER ANOTHER
THEY ARE DENIED. YOU CANNOT
DRIVE TO THE FREE PARKING PLACE
TO STAY IF YOU'RE ON PROBATION
IF YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO GET YOUR TAGS RENEWED. YOU
CANNOT GET HOUSING IF YOU DON'T
HAVE APPROPRIATE I. D. IT IS
CRITERIA AFTER CRITERIA AFTER
CRITERIA THAT THEY FEEL WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING. TO KEEP THEM FROM
THE SERVICES. AND IT RUNS
COUNTER TO HOW FLUSH WE ARE
WITH MONEY EXCITED ABOUT GIVING
IT OUT. SO CAN SOMEONE SHARE
WITH ME. HOW STAR IN DIJON ARE
GOING TO BE ADDRESSED BY THESE
PROPOSALS THAT WE WILL BE
VOTING ON. HAVING TO TAKE A
CRACK ABOUT REALLY- I'M VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE IT BEING
BROUGHT DOWN THE PEOPLE WE
SERVE I THINK I CAN PART OF ME
IMPORTANT AND ANTHONY HE'S VERY
MUCH TRYING AND CENTER I'M NOT
ONE OF THE- THAT I AM MOST
PROUD OF AS AS A CITIZEN OF
CALIFORNIA AND IN A ROLE THAT I.
PLAYED FACT THAT WE ARE THE
ONLY STATE IN THE COUNTRY- THAT
IS BY LAW HOUSING FIRST STAGE
WHICH ESSENTIALLY MEANS THAT
THERE IS NO BARRIER NO PRE
CONDITIONS THAT EVERYONE IS
READY TO GET PERMANENTLY HOUSE
AND YET. SO WE HAD A CSP THAT
AS PART OF OUR OUR MANDATE IS
TO ENSURE THAT ALL STATE
FUNDING THAT GOES OUT IS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE SIDE FIRST
PRINCIPLES I'M STILL PART OF
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO WORK TO
DO LIST REDUCE SOME OF THOSE
BARRIERS ARE MENTIONING- PART
OF THE REASON THAT WE ARE
DOUBLING DOWN. HOMELESSNESS IN
THIS IS THAT LAST HOMELESS A
TIME K. OUT FROM I'M US HAS AND
URBAN. SURE THE FAMILY HOME AND
THE MOST MONEY IN POPULAR OF
ALMOST IN OUR STATE ADAM IS A
THAT YOU SEE AROUND REMEMBERING
ONCE THAT THE THING IS
INCREASES SPSS- WITH OUR AROUND
AS WELL AS THAT AND IT'S HARD
IN OUR- FOR HOME HE HAVEN'T
DOLLAR FOR THAT I MEAN GOING
TOWARDS. PERMANENT FAMILY HOW-
IS MUCH FOR ARE HOPING HE WILL
HELP SEARCH LIKE- AND SO
UNDERSTANDING THE THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH FOR. RIGHT NOW I THERE
MAKING SURE EVERY MAKES
HOMELESSNESS THAT IS MUCH FUN
YOU'RE TRY TO DOUBLE IN FOR AND
ENSURE THAT ALL THAT MONEY IS
BEING THROUGHOUT FIRST CLIENTS
IS NOT ANY ANY ADDED BY ANY
MEANS NECESSARY I'M GETTING.
EARNERS ACCOUNTABLE TO DOING
WHAT WE'VE ASKED THEM TO DO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT SENATOR-
CAMPBELL- I WANNA- REALLY
CONFIRM WHAT- THE SENATOR JUST
JUST SAID IS ON. PART OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE PUT A LOT OF
MONEY OUT OF OVER THE PAST-
NUMBER OF YEARS AND I AND MY
CONCERN IS BEEN THAT M. AND I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
HOMELESS DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE FIRST STEPS TO GETTING US
DATA BUT I THINK THERE HAS TO
BE ACCOUNTABILITY AND I THINK
THERE HAS TO BE TRACKING AND-
SO- MY COMMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
GENERAL IN IN THIS REGARD- BUT
I DO THINK NUMBER ONE IS WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO PRESERVE THE
GAINS AND PROTECT THE HOME KEY
INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
UP TO THIS POINT. IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO ME THAT ANYBODY. HAS
MADE SURE THAT THE UNITS THAT
ARE BEING PURCHASED. ARE BEING.
RETAINED AS AFFORDABLE UNITS
INTO THE FUTURE AND THAT IF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. DECIDES THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO MOVE AWAY FROM
USING THOSE UNITS THAT. THEY
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR THE NON
PROFITS TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE I
JUST I FEEL VERY STRONGLY WE
NEED TO START PROTECTING THAT
INVESTMENT NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO IS THAT. I THINK WE SHOULD
USE THE FEDERAL FUNDS FIRST
THEY HAVE A DROP DEAD DEADLINE
AND SO I THINK WE GOT TO
PRIORITIZE AND GET THAT MONEY
OUT. IN AND UTILIZED- IN
REGARDS TO THE- THE ISSUE THAT
THE DOG. SENATOR NIELSEN RACED.
IS THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
PROPOSAL A NUMBER. OF HOUSING.
MONEY GOING TO ENTITIES THAT
WHOSE. FIRST PRIORITY IS NOT
NECESSARILY HOUSING SO- THE
MONEY GOING TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES THEY HAVE
THEIR JOB. IS ON THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM- AND- AND THIS IS A
REALLY GOOD ADDRESS TO IT I
BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT AND I
WANT TO SEE IT HAPPEN. BUT I DO
THINK THAT IT SHOULD BE UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF A CD BECAUSE
EACH CD UNDERSTANDS HOUSING AND
THEY UNDERSTAND. KIND OF THE
PARAMETERS AROUND- BUILDING
HOUSING PROTECTING IT FOR.
CERTAIN PURPOSE AND- AND THEY
HAVE THE EXPERTISE IN THAT AND
BY THE SAME TOKEN- THE MONEY IS
GOING TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NO
QUESTION WE NEED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVCES. BUT BUT THERE MAY BE
LIMITATIONS ON WHAT WELL WE
NEED THE DATA WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT THAT DATA TO
SAY- IF WE MARRY. HOUSING WITH
THESE PARTICULAR SERVICES THAT
YOU GET MORE BANG FOR YOUR BUCK
WE NEED TO KNOW THAT AND WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THE
DATE IN THE INFORMATION
CONSISTENT. ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS. TOM AND-
THEN- THERE IS A- HM THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES THAT THE HOME
KEY FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM.
WOULD WOULD BE IN TWO PARTS THE
FIRST PART THE MONEY WOULD GO
UP BY A PERCENTAGE OF THE MONEY
WOULD GO TO BIG CITIES
AUTOMATICALLY AND THAT THE
SMALLER CITIES WE WOULD RECEIVE
THEIR BITE INTO THE BIGGER
CITIES WOULD GET IT PER CAPITA
PER CAPITA THE SMALLER CITIES
HAVE TO FIGHT IT'S A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM AS AS
A SENATOR THAT REPRESENTS
NOTHING BUT SMALLER CITIES- I
OPPOSE THAT. I THINK THAT IF
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT
COMPETITIVE IT'S COMPETITIVE
ACROSS THE BOARD OTHERWISE I
THINK WE OUGHT TO DO IT WE ARE
DIVIDED BASED ON- BASED ON ON-
THAT POPULATION BECAUSE I HAVE
HEARD NOTHING BUT CONCERN FROM
THE SMALLER CITIES ABOUT.
MONEY'S GOING TO THE COUNTIES
AND THE MONEY NEVER GETTING TO
THE SMALLER CITIES IN THAT
COUNTY AND SO I WANT TO I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT I DON'T
THINK THAT. THERE'S ALWAYS A
CARVE OUT FOR THE BIG CITIES
AND I GET THAT THEIR ISSUES MAY
BE A LITTLE BIT BIGGER THAN
SOME OF THE SMALLER CITIES BUT
EVERYBODY IS SUFFERING UNDER
STAFFED WITH THIS HOMELESS
ISSUE AND I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD. WE SHOULD PENALIZE THE
SMALLER. THE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES AS WELL I THINK
THAT PRETTY MUCH TAKES CARE OF
THE ISSUES THAT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT. THIS THIS IS THE NUMBER
ONE ISSUE THE CALIFORNIANS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT. SO THE REASON
THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE RESOURCES. A MASSIVE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT WE- THAT ARE PART
OF THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL. WHICH
I THINK IS APPROPRIATE- THAT WE
HAVE THE SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT JUST
THROWING MONEY OUT THERE AND
AS- SENATOR COM AUGER SAID-
PEOPLE ARE GETTING LOTS OF
MONEY THEY HAVE A LOT TO STAFF
WORKING BUT- WE'RE NOT. HOUSING
THE VERY PEOPLE THAT WERE IN IT
WAS INTENDED FOR SO- THIS IS AN
ITEM THAT IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM
SO WE'RE GONNA. WE'RE GONNA SEE
THIS BACK AGAIN AND- APPRECIATE
ALL THE COMMENTS SENATOR NELSON
YOU HAD ONE MORE YOU WANTED TO
BE ABLE TO ASK ABOUT. ANOTHER
CONCERT ON RISE ON IT IF I MAY
MADAM CHAIR COULD. WE HERE ARE
PRETTY UNANIMOUS ON OUR
CONCERNS. AND AS WE. PROCEED
AND AS WE COME BACK. I WOULD
LIKE TO BE MUCH BETTER. AS TO.
ONE THE WHOLE PERSON OR THE
FAMILIES LIKE BEEF SENATOR FROM
ANGELES GOT TO CONFRONT SADLY
ON MOTHER'S DAY. COME TO THE
OFFICE TO WHOMEVER THEY CONTACT
THEY THEN ARE SAID WELL WHAT
YOU NEED IS THIS SO YOU HAVE TO
GO THERE BUT THAT'S TWENTY
MILES AWAY. BUT THEY GO THERE
AND THEN THEY HAVE A BUNCH OF
PAPERWORK TO FILL OUT WHICH IS
ALSO CHALLENGING AND THEN THEY
SAY WELL SORRY YOU DON'T NEED
TO TEST. THAT SHOW KIND OF A
BUREAUCRATIC ELABORATE THAT
FOLKS THAT WE'VE GOT TO BREAK
THROUGH. SO THE PEOPLE ARE
HELPED THAT THE DISPOSITION OF
THE AGENCY'S FLORAL ART TO HELP
NOT TO HINDER. THIS MESS AND
GET THEM OUT OF THEIR HAIR BUT
THAT THEY WOULD GO AWAY AT
LEAST KNOWING WHAT THE NEXT
STEP CLEARLY HERE'S WHERE TO GO
AND WHAT TIME. TO DO IT WE
DON'T DO THAT AND WE WANT TO
SEE AN IMPROVEMENT IN THAT KIND
OF SEDITION ASSISTANCE BY THEIR
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU MATT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WAIT YOU
KNOW I DID OCCUR TO ME AS YOU
WERE YOU WERE TALKING THERE WAS
ONE MORE ISSUE IN REGARDS TO
THE HOME KEY OR ANY OF THAT
PURCHASE OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PURCHASE SMALL HOTELS THAT MANY
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT I SPOKE
WITH. ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR.
RESOURCE THAT WAS AVAILABLE.
DURING THE AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC WAS IT THEY COULDN'T
MOVE FAST ENOUGH TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN AND SOME OF THE BIGGER
CITIES. WERE READY AND THEY HAD
BEEN WORKING ON THIS CONCEPT
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS HELP FOR
THOSE. SMALLER COMMUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO. TO ACCESS THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
KIND OF WORK IN THE COMMUNITY
AS WELL SO. MORE ON THIS LATER
AND I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS SENATOR- THERE'S-
THERE THERE WAS AN OFFER OF A
REPORT. FROM THE M. EIGHT CD
AND SO IF YOU COULD GET THAT TO
THE COMMITTEE WE CAN SHARE IT
AND TAKE A LOOK AT IT TOGETHER-
WE'RE GONNA THIS IS A HOLDOVER
OPEN ITEM SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN. WHICH IS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. AND IT'S
THE EIGHT CD BUDGET SUMMARY.
I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO-
THE DIRECTOR GUSTAVO VELASQUEZ.
THANK YOU SENATOR- APOLOGIZE I
WAS HAVING TROUBLE- GETTING MY
VIDEO ON- SO I AM HAPPY TO
DISCUSS- THE SECTIONS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMEBACK PLAN. ARE
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BROADER ISSUE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- I'M A SECRETARY CUSTER
I MEET ITS MISSION- EARLIER. IN
THE HEARING EVERYTHING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S COMEBACK PLAN.
DEDICATED TO HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. REAFFIRMS- VERY
IMPORTANT FRAME THAT IS
CENTERED ON FOUR PRINCIPLES OF
PRODUCTION. PRESERVATION
PROTECTION. AND LET ME THE MOST
IMPORTANT ONE INVESTING PEOPLE.
OFF FOR EXAMPLE OVER THE LAST
YEAR HONKY SHOWED. WHAT IS
POSSIBLE WHEN WE WORK TOGETHER
WITH A SHARED VISION AND A
SENSE OF URGENCY. HOME Q.
BROUGHT INCREDIBLE SIX THOUSAND
PLUS UNITS ONLINE IN A MATTER
OF MONTHS. N. ADAM HI BRIDGE
COST ONE THAT EASTER SCALABLE.
ARE BUILDING ON THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S CALIFORNIA COMEBACK
PLAN PROPOSES TO INVEST THREE
AND A HALF. BILLION DOLLARS
MORE TO ACQUIRE AND RENOVATE
HOTELS MOTELS AND OTHER
PROPERTIES. THIS WILL BE THE
SINGLE LARGEST INVESTMENT OF
ITS TYPE IN HISTORY. AT ONE
BILLION OF THAT IS TARGETED FOR
FAMILIES. THIS INVESTMENT AND
ALL OTHER SIMILAR STRATEGIES.
THAT TOGETHER COULD BRING
UPWARDS OF FORTY SIX THOUSAND
UNITS OF HOUSING TO- DOES
ADDRESS COUGH OR IT OR
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. ARE
CONDEMNING ALSO UNDERSCORED THE
CRITICALITY OF GETTING NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS BUILT
AND BUILT QUICKLY. BECOME BACK
PLAN ADDRESSES THIS NEED TO
WITH A PROPOSED. ONE POINT
SEVENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TO SUPPORT. READY TO
GO THESE ARE SHOVEL READY EIGHT
CD. I FOUR DOUBLE HOUSING
PROJECTS THESE ARE. PROJECTS
THAT HOW'RE EDDIE BEEN BY THE
STATE BEEN UNDER WAY LIST FOR
CREDIT. AND WITH THIS MORE THAN
SIX THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED YOU
OF I CAN READY UP HEALTH
PROJECTS COULD MOVE. IN FAIRLY
SHORT ORDER. OUR NOW IT HAS AND
GONE. TO BE A PRIMARY TO MORE.
IN A WAY THAT'S- WHAT THE
STATE'S CLIMBING AND REDUCE.
MILES OVER OF COURSE WITH A
FOCUSED ON ALSO FOR DURING FAIR
AND EQUITABLE HOUSING ACROSS
THE STATE. ARE THESE PLAN CALLS
FOR FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS TO REGIONAL ENTITIES FOR
INFILL DEVELOPMENT. ALL
TARGETED TOWARDS MEETING THE
STATE CLIMATE AND HOUSING GOALS
TOGETHER. IN THE SAME VEIN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO PROPOSED
IN TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE TIME.
DOLLARS TO OUR INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT OR I. I.
G. FOR BROWNFIELD REMEDIATION.
COMBINED WITH THE ONE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY MILLION. PROPOSITION
ONE APPROPRIATION IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET IDEAS WILL
PROVIDE A TOTAL OF FOUR HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
COMING YEAR. TO STIMULATE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT INCENTIVIZES LONG TERM
AFFORDABILITY WHILE CREATING
WELL. PAYING JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIANS. ONE THING. THE
GOVERNOR HAS YOU KNOW SHE TO
BEGIN OF HIS MR HAS IN IN.
GETTING X. STATE LAW. AVAILABLE
FOR MORE OF HOUSE. A FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
CONVERTING EXCESS STATE LINE
INTO SITES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS ALSO PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR. THIS BUILDS ON THE
SUCCESS OF A JOINT HCV GENERAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT AND WOULD
GO TOWARDS BUILDING THE
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
FOUNDATIONAL TO TRANSFORMING
TRANSFORM THIS EXERCISE INTO
VIABLE HOUSING PROJECTS. NOW WE
SPEAK A LOT ABOUT A HOUSE IN
PRODUCTION BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT LIMITED SUPPLY
IN CALIFORNIA KEEPS MAKING
HOUSING. EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE
AND THIS EXACERBATES POVERTY
AND INEQUALITY BUT WE MUST ALSO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
PRESERVING THE EXISTING STOCK
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS JUST
AS IMPORTANT. MANY PROPERTIES
INDICATE CD PORTFOLIO ARE
COMING TO THE END OF THE CALL
BUTTON AND USE THAT INSURED
BELOW MARKET RATES. FOR
QUALIFIED AT TENANTS WE ALL
HAVE HEARD STORIES OF
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE PHASE
WHEN GENTRIFICATION AND RISING
DISPLACEMENT PRESSURES
COMMUNITIES THAT IN THE PAST
FACE THIS INVESTMENT AND NOW
ARE RAPIDLY CHANGING WITH
ACCELERATING HOUSING COST. WE
NEED TO PRESERVE THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE HAVE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES BEFORE IT'S TOO
LATE. AND THE COMEBACK LAND
WITH ENABLED THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO KEEP THIS
HOUSING AFFORDABLE FOR MANY
MORE YEARS TO CALL. ANOTHER APP
HOUSING TYPE THAT IS PART OF
THE PRESERVATION MISTRETTA G.
A. IN THE CALIFORNIA COMEBACK
BLACK IS A STATE SPONSOR FARM
WORKER HOUSING THAT. ARE AT THE
SECRETARY MENTIONED EARLIER
THIS IS HOSTING IT FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS A HALF OF THE COUNTRY
FAN IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PANDEMIC RISKING THEIR OWN
LIVES SO THE PROPOSAL HERE
CALLS. FOR ANOTHER TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON TOP OF THE
TEN MILLION PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED
FOR SEASONAL FARMWORKER HOUSING
TO PAY. FOR CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND RENOVATION. ARE
MIGRANTS AND I ALSO COUPLE
CENTER CAREER- I. MY APPLE. FOR
HAVING YOU JOIN US I DEBASING
IN IN YOU BEST RECENTLY. AND
LAST BUT NOT LEAST RAIN RELIEF-
WE HOPE BUILD A THE COVER
NINETY RENDERING PRO CURRENT
FUND. AT TWO POINT SIX BILLION.
IN FOR RAN SIX. THE COMBAT
BUMPER THE- OF AN ALL. TWO
POINT SIX BILLION. AND THIS
COMBINED. POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IS DESIGNED TO HELP
PEOPLE STAY HOUSE AS WELL AS
ENSURE LANGUAGE RECEIVE AND
THIS IS NEW SEEMS TO KIND OF
RELIEF PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED IN
MARCH. THAT LANDLORDS WILL GET
THE FULL 1100% COMPENSATION FOR
UNPAID BACK RENT DURING THE
PANDEMIC GOING BACK TO APRIL.
OF LAST YEAR IN ADDITION SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD GO TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING LEGAL ASSISTANCE
GRANTS TO ORGANIZATIONS. TO
HELP THEM. SO WE'RE EXTRA PROUD
AND MAKE. THE BOLD BY TO GO. I
WANNA THANK OUR TEAM H. U. SOME
OF WHOM ARE THIS CALL FOR ALL
THE WORK ON THE BIKE FORMULA.
AND THEY WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER AS WELL. ARE THE
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK YOU
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DIRECTOR I BELIEVE THAT- YOU
MAY HAVE COVERED ISSUE SIXTEEN
AN ISSUE SEVENTEEN. BOTH
TOGETHER SO WE'LL WE'LL TAKE
THOSE BOTH TOGETHER SINCE TAKE
KIND OF GO TOGETHER ANYWAY- AND
I APPRECIATE THAT THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL THAT YOU PROVIDED TO US
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I AM
TURNING NOW. TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS DINNER CUISE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS BUT HAVE
BEEN ANSWERING QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HOW
ABOUT THE- LMAO. THIS MY LIST
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE MANY OF OUR OVER ARCHING
COMMENTS THAT I MADE RELATED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSALS ALSO APPLY TO THE MAY
REVISION HOUSING PROPOSALS-
SPECIFICALLY IN MANY CIRCLES
ALSO REQUIRE TRAINER BILL
LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT WHICH IS
NOT YET AVAILABLE. CANCEL BE
LOOKING FOR THAT LANGUAGE TO
ASSESS HOW SOME OF THESE KEY
IMPLEMENTATION DECISIONS WILL
BE MADE. FOR EXAMPLE ON HOW
EACH CD WOULD ASSESS HOW IT
WOULD AWARD- AND ASSESS A
LEGIBILITY FOR THE ONE POINT
SEVEN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BACKLOG
FUNDING IN THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRESERVATION. HOWEVER IN OTHER
CASES SUCH AS FOR THE PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTATION GRANT
PROPOSAL THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
INDICATED ITS INTENT TO
FINALIZE ITS ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY ADMINISTRATIVELY
FOLLOWING THE ADOPTION OF THE
BUDGET. RATHER THAN TWO TRAILER
FELL AND THE TEMPERATURE. WOULD
LIMIT THE LEGISLATURE'S
AUTHORITY. AND FINALLY AS WE
SET FOR. AS WELL. THERE ARE
MAJOR AND IN SPACE INTO IT'LL
BE MORE CRUISE THAN EVER FOR
THE LUNCH TO. THAT IT HAS
STRONG IN A CALIBER BY USING
STATUE AND BILL LANGUAGE
ANOTHER. OR AND AGAIN THESE ARE
JUST OUR INITIAL AND WILL. LOOK
FOR TO SEE THE REPORTING BACK
ONCE WE DO A CHANCE REVIEW THE
BELOW. THANK YOU. LET ME ASK
ROQUE COULD YOU TELL US WHICH
ARE THE- THE PROPOSALS THAT
ANTICIPATE- DOING IT AFTER THE
PATCH IT'S ALREADY BEEN PASSED
ME JUST SAY THAT I'M NOT A BIG
FAN OF THAT STRATEGY BUT COULD
YOU. COULD YOU CALL THEM OUT
FOR FRESH VERY QUICKLY ON THE
IN. THESE ISSUE SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN. WHERE AWARE OF THE
PLANNING. GRANT TO SOMETHING
THAT FALL. FOR THE OTHER IT'LL
BE A MATTER OF WHAT ADULT
INCLUDE IN THE TRAILER BELOW
AND WHICH IS NOT TO BE LET
THERE MAY BE SUFFICIENT. THERE
MIGHT NOT BE SO THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN REPORT BACK
ONCE THE LANGUAGE IS AVAILABLE
IT'S ONLY. THE ONE THAT WE'RE
AWARE THAT THE INTENT IS FOR
THERE TO BE- FOR IT TO BE DONE
AFTERTHE FACT MR DOUBLY. OKAY
YEAH I JUST I GUESS NINO THE
LEGISLATURE IS DOING SO MUCH
WORK IN THIS AREA- SOME REALLY
CONCRETE WORK THAT THAT- THE
IDEA OF WAITING. AND JUST
LETTING THE ADMINISTRATION. DO
THE- AFTER WE'VE ALREADY THE
BUDGET DOES NOT APPEAL TO ME-
SO I WOULD. I WOULD I WOULD
JUST PUT THAT CABBIE OUT THERE
AND SAY THAT THERE ARE ENOUGH
BILLS IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT.
CAN BE PLAGIARIZED OR CAN BE
INCLUDED AS PART OF THIS
BUDGET- THAT THAT THAT MIGHT
MAKE MORE SENSE TO GETTING US
ARE NOT OF APPROVAL- BUT THAT'S
JUST MY GUT REACTION SENATOR
NIELSEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
SOME COMMENTS. AND I THINK YOU
FOR THAT THAT- INFORMATION
TODAY. JUST KIND OF. FOLLOWING
THIS ALL CLOSE WITH THIS MADAM
CHAIR AT THIS IS BEEN A
PRODUCTIVE. SEGMENT IN.
CAREFULLY REVIEW OUR DOCTOR.
AND THE COMMENTS TODAY. HI SHE-
AGREED. ABSENCE OF ANY
DISCUSSION OF EASING THE
REGULATORY BURDEN ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR PROVIDING
HOUSING FOR THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AND EVEN AS WELL FOR
OUR FARM WORKER HOUSING.
SOMETHING JUST STICKS SO
PROFOUNDLY IN MY MIND OF LAST
YEAR A HOMELESS ADVOCATE
TESTIFYING PASSIONATELY. THAT
WOULD LEAVE THE BUILDING THE
SMALLHOUSES FOR SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS CHEAPER. IF THE
REGULATORY BURDEN WAS EAST EVEN
ON THIS VERY NECESSARY HOUSING
SO I'M ASKING THE
ADMINISTRATION KNEW EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT TO SEND
OUT THE WORD TO THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES. TO EXAMINE WHAT THEY
THOSE AGENCIES CAN DO TO EVEN
EVEN THE IMMEDIATE THE
REGULATORY BURDEN THAT SOUL AND
FIGHTS THE COST OF LOW INCOME
HOUSING. HOUSING FOR HOMELESS
HOUSING FOR. MIGRANT FARM
WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT- COMMENT- ON TEM
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN AND ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AGAIN-
FLEXIBILITY IN USING THE
FEDERAL FUNDS FIRST WOULD BE-
PROVIDE MOST IMPORTANT AND THAT
THOSE RESOURCES GO TO EITHER
CHEVROLET THE PROJECTS ARE TWO
PROJECTS WHERE THE RESOURCES
CAN BE USED TO GET US READY TO
BE SHOVEL. SHOVEL READY
OTHERWISE I AM. I THINK THESE
ARE ARE- THIS IS A GOOD
EXPENDITURE OF RESOURCES AND
AGAIN WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EAC EIGHT CD IS REALLY.
OVERSEEING HOUSING RESOURCES NO
MATTER WHERE WHERE THEY WERE
SENDING THE RESOURCES TO DO SO.
THE BOTH ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
AND ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN OR
HOLD OPEN ITEM SO EXPECT TO GET
TO SEE THEM BACK AGAIN. MAYBE
WITH THE- SOME TRAILER BLLING
WHICH IT'LL HELP US TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY HOW THEY'LL
BE- ROLLED OUT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON NOW TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
WHICH IS A KELLY CHIEF A
PROPOSAL. AND LIKE TO INVENT
THAT INVITE THE- DIRECTOR OF
COLLEGE OF A- AND IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION. THAT
IS CORRECT- CHAIR ALSO GOOD
AFTERNOON JUDGE SHARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY MY NAME IS FRANCIS
MARTES AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATION AND POLICY AT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY. COLLEGE OF FATE AND
I'LL BE TALKING TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT THE TWO COLLEGE OF A
ITEMS AND THEN THE REVISION
REGARDING HOMEBUYER ASSISTANCE.
AN ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS. SO
FIRST ON ON HOME JUST SO ARE
ENOUGH IN IN HER OWNERSHIP YOUR
INCOME. R. O. STANDING I'M THE
CORNER BAND AND MAKE FOR THE D.
AND HAS. THE LOBSTER. THAT
LOWER INCOME HOW FOR. WHEN THEY
SEE TO BUY ALL. AND BUILDING TO
JENNA WEALTH SO IN ORDER TO.
ENCOURAGE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
RESILIENCY AND ALSO EQUITY. THE
MEROVINGIAN PROPOSES A HUNDRED
MILLION. IN ONE TIME FEDERAL
BOTH FUNDS. TO COLLEGE OF FAME
TO EXPAND ITS FIRST TIME
HOMEBUYER ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
WHICH HELPS FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS WITH MAKING I DON'T
PAYMENT SECURING ALONE AND ALSO.
PAYING CLOSING COSTS AND ALL.
SO IF APPROVED COLLEGE FATE.
PLUS THE DEPLOY THESE FUNDS TO
GREATER LEVELS OF ASSISTANCE
FOR THOSE AT THE LOWER END OF
THE HOME BUYER IN STACKED. I
NEEDED OF HOME A- FOURTEEN MORE
CALLOUS. AND I WILL SPEAK.
ABOUT EIGHTY USE ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNIT. IN RECENT YEARS
THAT LEGISLATURE HAS IT
POSSIBLE FOR HOUSEHOLDS INVEST
BEST WAY GREATER OF LOCAL
APPROVAL. IN A SENSE WE DO WANT
UNIT TO WANT TO THANK
RELIGIOUSLY FOR THIS- SO I
DON'T FIND A- HAS AND REMAINS
IN A FOR MANY. THAT DON'T WANT
BUILD- AN EXCESS DWELLING YOU
SO FOR THIS WE COLLEGE A FABLE
BE STARTING UP FOR TO THE
PRODUCTION. OF EIGHTEEN USING
MILLION AN EXISTING FUNDS I
WONDER MAYBE FOR. TO EXPAND
THIS PROGRAM BY ADDING AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHTY ONE MILLION
SO IT'S THE EIGHTY ONE MILLION
ON TOP OF THE EXISTING. NINE
NINETEEN FOR A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED- I NEVER PROVED THE
EDITION ALL WE SAW. ARE
EXPECTED TO BRING-
APPROXIMATELY FIVE THOUSAND
UNITS OF HOW ALL OF US LEGAL
IMMUNITY ONLINE QUICKLY AND
INEXPENSIVELY WITH THE ADDED
BENEFIT OF HELPING LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES CREATE
WEALTH BUILDING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE HOUSE. AND THAT IT IS
ALL FOR AND IN TERMS THE
COLLEGE OF THE ITEMS AND I'LL
HAVE TO TALK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- TURNING IT OVER NOW TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
pDEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. VERY GOOD
HOW ABOUT THE LA- NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM. VERY
GOOD I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DYESS AND- SENATOR NELSON. NO
QUESTIONS- I WAS QUICKLY TRYING
TO DO FIVE THOUSAND INTO. A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND I'M
NOT EVEN GONNA TRY IT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I'M I AM. I'M I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER
FIVE THOUSAND IS A CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATE ON WHAT YOU DO ON WHAT
WE'D END UP SEEING- BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME LIKE A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS A PRETTY BIG
INVESTMENT AND WE SHOULD BE
EXPECTING A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN FIVE THOUSAND UNITS BUT I
DO. I DO APPRECIATE THE FOCUS
ON EIGHTY YEARS I THINK IT'S A
REALLY GOOD WAY TO- TO ADDRESS
AN ISSUE BUT TO TURN TO GET IT
A QUICK- TURN AROUND. IN IN
UNITS WHICH IS WHAT IT MEANS
FOR THE WHOLE ISSUE IS WE NEED
MORE UNITS TODAY AND THE
QUICKER WE CAN GET HIM ON THE
GROUND THE BETTER THEY ARE. ME
ASK YOU THIS DO YOU ANTICIPATE
COMING UP WITH THE PLANNED. WE
GET BACK UP I AM. PLANNED PLANS
THAT HAVE BEEN PRE APPROVED SO
THAT THEY DON'T YOU DON'T HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A HUGE BURDEN AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO ARE YOU. LOOKING AT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO GRANTS
FOR HOMEOWNERS SO THAT THEY
CAN. USE THIS GRANT MONEY TO DO
THE EIGHTY YOU AND KEEP IT
AFFORDABLE. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS. FIRST
OF ALL LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT THE
FIVE THOUSAND. THE UNIT
ESTIMATE WAS FOR THE- EIGHTY
ONE MILLION. SO IF YOU CONSIDER
THE NINETEEN MILLION AN
EXISTING RESOURCES WE ARE ALSO
PUTTING FORWARD A NUMBER COMES
OUT CLOSER TO SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED. SO IT'S ABOUT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND IN ASSISTANCE FOR
UNITS THAT WERE KIND OF
ESTIMATED AND- I THINK A VERY
GOOD POINT THAT YOU RAISE IT
REGARDING- YOU KNOW PRE
APPROVALS- AND ALSO- PROVIDING
GRANTS- I THINK THE EXACT
DETAILS ON THE FINANCING.
ESTRUCTURA MECHANISM WILL BE
FORTHCOMING BUT- YOU KNOW WE
LOOK FORWARD TO. SPEAKING TO
YOU ANOTHER ABOUT AND ANY
SUGGESTIONS OR THANK YOU I
WOULD IT WOULD GOING TO BE HARD
TO DO WHEN MILLION. AND
AMERICAN IT WAS KIND OF AN EASY
NOW. I GUESS THAT. THE MINE. IS
THE COW OF SANTA CRUZ IS COMING
UP WITH A WAY TO BE ABLE TO
EXPEDITE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
EIGHTIES AND THEY- THEY HAVEN'T
DEVELOPED SOME PLANS THAT- THAT
ARE PRE APPROVED. AND THAT
DON'T REQUIRE ANY REVIEW FROM
THEIR THEIR PLANNING- ENTITY
OTHER THAN TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY- FOLLOW THE SET BACKS AND
THE KINDS OF. OF POLICY SAID
THAT DON'T DELAY A PROJECT BUT
THEY ALSO WILL FIND IT AND SO
IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE THE
QUICKEST WAY TO GET THESE
THINGS DONE IS TO FIND IT. AND
THIS TO COME UP WITH PLANS AND
SO I'M- I'M HOPING THAT'S
WHAT'S INTENDED- IN IT IN
ADDITION TO THAT THE- THE FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS PROGRAM IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THE SENATE
HAS PRIORITIZED FIRST A FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS PROGRAM- J. TO
START TO DEVELOP. WEALTH IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE EQUITY IN A
HOME PROVIDES THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE INTO THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND SO THIS IS
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT- THE
PRIORITY FOR MYSELF IN
PARTICULAR BUT ALSO FOR THE
SENATE AND SO. WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT WE GET REAL
GOOD DETAILS ON HOW THIS WOULD
OPERATE AND HOW WHEN WOULD
ACCESS THIS KIND OF OPPORTUNITY
IN MANY OF MY COMMUNITIES THE
OPPORTUNITY BACK HOUSE STILL
WITHIN REACH BUT THERE. THERE'S
A NEED FOR PROGRAM SO- THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THIS IS
ANOTHER HOLDOVER OPEN ITEMS- SO
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THIS BACK AGAIN. I
REMEMBER WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
OPEN THIS THIS ITEM- WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE-
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH IN IT IS IT IS
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN THE O. PR
BUDGET SUMMARY. END LIKE TO
INVITE THE DIRECTOR. KATE
GORDAN. TO START US OFF HOW
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH CARE
GOOD AFTERNOON A TRICKERY AUTO
CENTER COME LONGER INTENDED-
NIELSEN I AM CAIT GORDON SIX
YOU AGAIN. ACTOR OF GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO PLAY AND RESEARCH AND-
OF THE CALIFORNIA STRATEGIC
COUNCIL. AND I'M HERE JUST TO
PROVIDE BRIEF AND HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF- PR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS WHICH INCLUDED AS
ITEMS NINETEEN ON YOUR AGENDA.
AS YOU KNOW- PR'S ROLE IS TO
PROVIDE ADVICE AND GUIDANCE TO
THE GOVERNOR AND CABINET ALL
LONG RANGE PLANNING AND
RESEARCH ISSUES INCLUDING LAND
USE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMIC GROWTH.
AND INCREASINGLY CRADLE TO
CAREER HEALTH EDUCATION AND
PUBLIC SERVICE- PR JUST AS A
REMINDER INCLUDES IN ITS BUDGET
UNIT BOTH THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL AND HELP ON. THE
INTERIORS SH WHAT IMPORTANT
NOTE AS YOU WERE CONSIDERING
ALL THESE BUDGET ITEMS. I'LL BE
OURS VERY SMALL. CONSIDERING
OUR REACH WE CURRENTLY HAVE
JUST ONE HUNDRED AND SIX PEOPLE
WORKING ACROSS APPEAR STC AND
CALLAN TEARS. RESPONSIBLE FOR
GETTING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
GRANT DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR
DIRECTLY TO COMMUNITIES AND
PROJECTS AND TO PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT GUIDANCE AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO LOCAL
AND REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS ACROSS
THE STATE OUR TEAM WORKS VERY
HARD TO COORDINATE AND
COLLABORATE WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND PROVIDE. THAT GUIDANCE. TO
REGIONAL LOCAL AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TO EVALUATE OUR
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS- WITH
METRICS DRIVEN EVALUATION. WE
ALSO SPEND SIGNIFICANT TIME
COORDINATING AMONG AND ACROSS
STATE AGENCIES TO IMPROVE
COLLABORATION INSURE OUR
POLICIES ARE AS ALIGNED AS
POSSIBLE. AND WORK TO ADVANCE
THE LEGISLATURE'S IMPORTANT
GOALS. IN MANY WAYS WE'RE THE
FAN IT BUT VERY STRONG GLUE
THAT CONNECTS MANY OF THE
LARGER PIECES OF THE STATE'S
GOALS AND PRIORITIES. I'LL GIVE
A QUICK OVERVIEW TODAY ABOUT R.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
PROPOSALS THAT- PR AND- SPC.
AND THEN MY COLLEAGUE GOT
FRIDAY DIRECTOR PALANTIR'S IS
HERE TO GIVE A QUICK BACKGROUND
ON THAT CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEER
ITEMS. I'LL NOTE THAT JUST
GIVEN THE- ACTING DIRECTOR.
BEST YOU SEE IS ALSO. RUSSIANS
THE PANEL. SO QUICKLY- QUICKER
OF THE PIECES YOU HAVE HERE
WHICH ARE CUTTING HAS ALL OF
OUR ON SEVERAL OF THESE P. ARE
RELATED TO THIS AND MUCH LIKE
CLIMATE AGENDA THE GOVERNORS
COME PLAN IS- AND PROPOSAL IS
CUT AND A WHOLE OF APPROACH ON
CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH IS AS YOU
KNOW AN ISSUE THAT AFFECTS
EVERY ASPECT OF OUR STATE
ECONOMY OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OUR QUALITY OF LIFE. AND TODAY
I WANT TO JUST OUTLINED SOME
FOUNDATIONAL INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE PROPOSED TO BE HOUSED A
COORDINATED- PR AN STC THAT
WILL ACTUALLY SUPPORT EVERY ONE
OF THE OTHER PIECES IN THE
COMEBACK PLAN NOT JUST THE KIND
OF PIECES BUT ACROSS EVERY AREA
OF GOVERNMENT. BY EMPHASIZING
DECISION MAKING BASED ON SOUND
SCIENCE AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT RATHER THAN TOP DOWN
APPROACHES WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE ND
THE LEGISLATURE ON TO MOVE
THESE PIECES SO BRIEFLY WHERE
THOSE PIECES ARE FIRST- THEY'RE
A LITTLE OUT OF ORDER FROM
WHERE THEY ARE IN YOUR AGENDA I
APOLOGIZE. BUT I'M I'M DOING
THEM PHONETICALLY. ON THE FIRST
THE FIFTH CLIMATE YOU ASSESSED
THIS WOULD BE TWENTY TWO
MILLION OVER FIVE. TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OF PLANNING RESEARCH
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AND THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL TO IMPLEMENT.
THE FIFTH CALVARY CLIMATE
CHANGE ASSESSMENT WHICH WAS PUT
INTO STATUTE LAST YEAR THROUGH
S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY. IF WE
CAN'T MEASURE CLIMATE IMPACTS
WE CAN'T MANAGE THEM AN
INVESTMENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATECHANGE ASSESSMENT AND
SUSTAINED INVESTMENT IN CLIMATE
CHANGE RESEARCH AND SCIENCE IS
FOUNDATIONAL. TO IMPLEMENTING
EVERY ONE OF THE STATE'S CARBON
NEUTRALITY IN RESILIENCE
PRIORITIES. THIS ASSESSMENT
WILL FOCUS ON TURNING SCIENCE
TO ACTIONABLE ACTUALLY DOUBLE
DOWN ON THE ON THE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES PUT FORTH AN SP
THIRTEEN TWENTY. OF PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
REDUCING RISK TO VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND BUILDING
ECONOMIC STABILITY IN THE IN
THAT PHASE OF CLIMATE CHANGE. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
FIFTH CLIMATE ASSESSMENT WOULD
INCLUDE THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
EITHER HERE IN CALIFORNIA OR
NATIONALLY THE FIRST OF ITS
KIND TRIBAL CLIMATE RESEARCH
PROGRAMS A TRIBAL DRIVEN
SECTION OF THE CLIMATE
ASSESSMENT REALLY PAYING
ATTENTION. TO TRIBAL APPROACHES
TO SCIENCE AND TO- WHEN
MANAGEMENT. THE SECOND IS ALL
TALK ABOUT IS. REALLY FINDING
ACTIONABLE CLIMATE SCIENCE
THAT'S ABOUT TURNING AGAIN THAT
SCIENCE ACTION JUST FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
THROUGH OUR INTEGRATED CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY
PROGRAM WHICH WAS CREATED
THROUGH SB TWO FORTY SIX. THAT
IS THE ONLY STATUTORILY CREATED
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PROGRAM IN
THE STATE THIS WOULD INVEST IN
I. KERR- WHICH IS A PUBLIC BODY
HI BY INVESTING IN TOOLS TO
TRANSLATE COMPLEX CLIMATE
SCIENCE INTO ACTION AND
IMPORTANTLY WOULD ALSO SUPPORT
A NEW ID CARD VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES PLATFORM WHICH
ALLOWS US TO START MAPPING.
THOSE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE THAT ARE MOST VULNERABLE
TO CLIMATE IMPACTS MANY OF
WHICH ARE RURAL COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE NOT ALWAYS CAPTURED
EASILY BY OTHER. TOOLS THAT WE
HELP TO MEASURE EQUITY IMPACTS.
THE THIRD BIG AREA THE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION RESILIENCE GREAT
GRANT PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OVER TWO YEARS TO OPR TO FIND.
LOCAL AND REGIONAL CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
GRANTS ONE THING WE HEAR OVER
AND OVER TO A PR IS THAT
THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH SUPPORT
AT THE REGIONAL AND LOCAL
LEVEL. FOR A LONG TERM CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
PLANNING. OUT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF CODE NINETEEN ON
LOCAL AND REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS
ONLY EXACERBATED THIS DYNAMIC
AND MADE IT EVEN HARDER FOR
THESE GOVERNMENTS DO THAT KIND
OF PLANNING. THESE GRANTS WILL
SUPPORT LOCAL AND REGIONAL
ADAPTATION PLANNING AND
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE ESSENTIAL
TO THAT LONG TERM RESILIENCE.
BUT NEXT DECIDE LIKE TO POINT
TO IS REALLY A PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY DRIVEN STRATEGY WE
KNOW THAT CLIMATE IMPACTS ARE
FELT VERY DIFFERENTLY ACROSS
THE STATE WE KNOW THAT HAD THE
SOLUTIONS PLAY OUT VERY
DIFFERENTLY ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THAT THOSE SOLUTIONS NEED
TO BE COMMUNITY DRIVEN. ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT PROGRAMS AT
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
THAT DEMONSTRATES HOW TO DO
THOSE PROGRAMS ON THE GROUND.
THEY BRING TOGETHER CLIMATE
HOUSING WORKFORCE
TRANSPORTATION. OUT AT WORK AND
TRAINING ALL IN ONE PROJECT IS
THE TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM. THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION OVER THREE
YEARS TO THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL TO CONTINUE THAT
PROGRAM. AND MAKES A STAINTHE
PLACE BASED IN INVESTMENTS INTO
THE STATE'S MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND THIS PROGRAM
REALLY SHOULD BE SEEN AS-
INTEGRATING ALL THOSE ELEMENTS
I TALKED ABOUT BUT IT'S ALSO A
HOUSING PROGRAM AND A AND T. C.
C. IS REALLY HOUSING
INNOVATION. KIND OF
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT HOUSING
PRODUCTION AS A PRIORITY ACROSS
ALL T. SHE. GREAT T. IMMUNITIES.
THIS PROPOSE PARTED MILLION.
INVESTMENT WOULDN'T MORE K. TO
BENEFIT FROM THESE INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY DRIVEN APPROACHES.
TCC I WANT TO KNOW IT ALREADY
HAS A PIPELINE OF FOURTEEN
COMMUNITIES WAS SHOVEL READY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS READY
TO APPLY FOR THIS KIND OF
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING.
INCLUDING SEVERAL IN SOUTH LA
WHICH I KNOW CENTER COME UNDER
YOUR DISTRICT EAST LA AT
RICHMOND FOR MINE AND MCFARLAND
AND INDIA. NEXT YOUR PROJECTS
WILL BE READY IN BAKERSFIELD
COACHELLA VALLEY UNINCORPORATED
SOUTH SACRAMENTO FOR BILL SAN
DIEGO TO LARRY. AND WEST
OAKLAND SURE REALLY EIGHT CROSS
STATE. URBAN SUBURBAN RURAL ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
LOOKING. AT TAKING THESE
INTEGRATED APPROACHES. AND
FINALLY I HAVE THE- I'D LIKE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES TWENTY
MILLION OVER FIVE YEARS TO THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL TO
IMPLEMENT THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE PROGRAM. AS
ENVISIONED BY SP TEN SEVENTY
TWO. THIS PROGRAM REALLY DOES
THE WORK TO HELP DIRECTLY
PROVIDE GRANTS TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE KINDS OF STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS IS THAT WE ALL TALK
ABOUT ALL THE TIME. BUILDING A
PLAN WE'RE DOING AN INFORMATION
STRATEGY WE'RE LOOKING AT A- A
REGIONAL APPROACH TO
DEVELOPMENT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL COMMUNITIES ARE
PART OF THAT. I DID PART OF
THAT PLANNING PROCESS AND THIS
PROGRAM ALLOWS THAT TO HAPPEN
BY PROVIDING DIRECT CAPACITY
SUPPORT TO THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT CAN BE THINGS LIKE CHILD
CARE AT MEETINGS THAT CAN BE
DIRECT HONORARIA TO PARTICIPATE
IT CAN BE. A CAPACITY BUILDING
IT WILL BE VERY VERY LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THIS IS A CRITICAL PIECE THAT
UNDERLIES SO MUCH OF OUR
BUDGET. REALLY JUST INSURING
THAT WE ARE TAKING A COMMUNITY
DRIVEN APPROACH. I ONLY SEE
MORE THING ABOUT HANDED UP TO
MY COLLEAGUE GOT FRIDAY TO SEE
IF YOU WORDS ABOUT. THE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEER PIECES OF
THIS- PROPOSAL I DID WANT TO
SAY THAT- PR IN ADDITION TO ALL
OF OUR WORK ON CLIMATE. ALSO
DOES A FAIR AMOUNT OF WORK ON
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION WE DO
HAVE A BUDGET ITEM FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
FOUR K. THROUGH SIXTEEN
REGIONAL COLLABORATIVES THAT'S
BEING HEARD OVER THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IS INSIDE ONE TOUCH
ON THAT TODAY. I WILL SAY
THOUGH THAT THE BUDGET DOES
INCLUDE ABOUT TWELVE POINT FOUR
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
EXPAND OUR ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES. RESEARCH WORK
THROUGH OUR PRECISION MEDICINE
PROGRAM WHICH ASSISTS IN
DETECTING TOXIC STRESS TO
PREVENT LONG TERM HEALTH
IMPACTS OF YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
AMONG OTHER THINGS. THIS IS
VERY COMPLEMENTARY TO THE
SURGEON GENERAL'S WORK ON IT
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES.
AND REALLY FUNDAMENTAL TO
MAKING SURE THAT SOME OF THE
EXPERIENCES THAT FOLKS ARE
HAVING ACROSS THE STATE WHETHER
IT'S HOMELESSNESS WHETHER IT'S
WILDFIRES OR OTHER CLIMATE
SHOCKS. ARE ACTUALLY BEING
LOOKED AT AND EVALUATED WHAT
WE'RE DOING- I HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH AND PHYSICAL HEALTH.
EVALUATION OF THESE
CALIFORNIANS. WITH THAT I'M
GONNA TURN BRIEFLY TO DRAW
FRIDAY. OF CALIFORNIA. TO JUST
TO HIM ITEMS AND THEN CAN TAKE
WHAT. VERY GOOD. WELCOME THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK U.
K. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
JUST GOING TO BRIEFLY GO OVER A
COUPLE OF THE- PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THE FIRST IS THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL COLLEGE
PROGRAM AND WITH THIS PROGRAM
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO CREATE A
CULTURE OF SERVICE BY INSPIRING
A NEW GENERATION OF SERVING
THEIR COMMUNITIES WHICH ALLOWS
TO HELP TACKLE SOME OF OUR
BIGGEST CHALLENGES TODAY LIKE
EDUCATION DISPARITIES AND
LEARNING LOSS FROM COVE IT.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND FOOD AND
SECURITY AND MANY OTHERS AND
THEN ALSO MUCH LIKE THE GI BILL
HAS DONE FOR GENERATIONS OF
VETERANS IN OUR COUNTRY WE'RE
HOPING TO MAKE COLLEGE MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR THOSE WHO COMMIT
TO SERVE OUR STATE SO IF YOU
JUST KEEP ASPECTS OF THE
PROGRAM THROUGH A STATEMENT ON
A SCHOLARSHIP- THE CUT
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COLLEGE
PROGRAM CREATES ACTUAL DEBT
FREE PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS TO
COMMIT TO AN ACADEMIC YEAR
SERVICE WHILE STAYING ON TRACK
TO GRADUATE AND WE'RE GONNA BE
WHEN WE ARE WORKING WITH THE UC
CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEMS. ON THIS PROGRAM AS
WELL AS PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES IN
ADDITION AB FIVE FORTY ELIGIBLE
DREAMERS HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED FROM NATIONAL SERVICE
PROGRAMS LIKE AMERICORPS AND
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSED
PROGRAM INCLUDES THEM ALLOWS
THEM TO PARTICIPATE IN THE SAME
SERVICE EXPERIENCES ELSE AND
ALSO GIVES THEM THE SAME ACCESS
TO RESOURCES THAT EVERYONE ELSE
HAS WHICH WE THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND ALSO JUST IT AND
FINALLY TO GET A KIND OF A
SENSE OF THE INTENDED IMPACT OF
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM. THIS
WOULD CREATE A CORE SERVICE
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA LARGER
THAN THE PEACE CORPS FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES A SECOND
WE HAVE A YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT-
AN OPPORTUNITY- PROPOSAL WHICH
WILL INVEST IN SCALE JOB
PROGRAMS FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO HIRE YOUTH IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THOSE THIS IS
ESPECIALLY FOCUSED ON YOUTH WHO
ARE AT RISK WHO ARE NOT COLLEGE
TRACK AND WHO HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY COBIT
OVER LAST YEAR AND A HALF. WITH
THAT. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH- FOR. AND SEE
IF THEY HAVE ANY COM. AFTERNOON
WEBER TO COVER OF FINANCE NOTRE
WILL COME BUT AT HEAVY HELP
INTERCOURSE YOU MAY HAVE VERY
GOOD- SHOULD HAVE SOME REAL
REAL QUESTIONS ARE FOR AND
PRETTY SOON BE YOU CAN EVER GET
OFF EASY SO- ABOUT- THE OF. HI
THIS IS BRIAN WITH
AFFORDABILITY ANALYST'S OFFICE
OUR COMMENTS ON THE- OPR
PROPOSALS HAVE BEEN INCLUDED IN
THE AGENDA SO I WILL MOVE
THROUGH THESE ARE RELATIVELY
QUICKLY. THINK REGARDING THE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS PROPOSALS
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS ARE STILL
WORKING OUT SOME OF THE KEY
DETAILS ON THE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL COLLEGE
SERVICE PROGRAM BUT- IT APPEARS
TO BE CLOSELY COORDINATING WITH
THE STATE. COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS. WE NOTE
THAT CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS WILL
NEED TO WORK CLOSELY WITH OTHER
STATE AGENCIES IN IMPLEMENTING
THIS NEW PROGRAM. IN ORDER TO
AVOID NEGATIVE INTERACTIONS
WITH THE STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS. I DO WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT WELL WE URGE CAUTION ON
THE CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL COLORS
SERVICE PROGRAM WE DO NOT
RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL. WHICH IS- SOMEONE
CLEAR IN THE AGENDA. WE DO
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE REGIONAL K.
THREE SIXTEEN EDUCATION
COLLABORATIVES WHICH HAS
DIRECTOR GORDON NOTED IS BEING
HEARD IN A DIFFERENT SUB
COMMITTEE SO THAT'S A GOOD.
TIME FOR ME TO CLARIFY THEIR-
MOVING ON THE- THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR A
YOUTH WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
GRANT PROGRAM. COULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
EXISTING- PROGRAMS. IN CITIES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT PROVIDE.
SOME EMPLOYMENT FOR USE WE
RECOMMEND HOWEVER THAT YOU
DIRECT TELEPHONE TO AWARD ALL
OF THE GRANTS ON A COMPETITIVE
BASIS. THE CURRENT PROPOSAL HAS
THREE QUARTERS OF THE GRANTS
BEING AWARDED- BY AFORMULA. TO
THE THIRTEEN LARGEST CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA- LESLIE WE DO
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR STEM
TEACHER RECRUITMENT GRANTS
BECAUSE IT IS DISCONNECTED FROM
THE STATES BROADER TEACHER
RECRUITMENT ACTIVITIES. AS
NOTED IN THE AGENDA WE DO NOT
HAVE CONCERNS RAISED REGARDING
THE OTHER- OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH PROPOSALS BUT WE
ARE STILL REVIEWING PROPOSALS
RELATED TO CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AND DO NOT AT THIS TIME HAVE
SPECIFIC COMMENTS A
RECOMMENDATION. ON THOSE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MA'AM I'M GONNA BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE- THE DIOCESE
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM AND SO
WE MIGHT JUST WANT TO GIVE
COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO SOME OF
THE DETAILS HERE- ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M
SAYING MAN- I DO WANT TO- ECHO
WHAT B. ELLIE- SAID IN REGARDS
TO THE GRANT I WAS LOOKING FOR
IT RIGHT NOW THE GRANT PROGRAM
THAT. GIVES A MAJORITY THE
MONEY TO THE BIG BIG CITIES AND
THEN THE REST ON THE
COMPETITIVE GRANT ANY ANY
FRAMEWORK THAT USES THAT. AS
THE MODEL- HAS PROVEN TO BE
EXTREMELY DETRIMENTAL TO RURAL
CALIFORNIA- AND SO I PROBABLY
WON'T VOTE FOR ANYTHING THAT
THAT IS. WHERE THE BIG CITIES
GET A MAJORITY OF THE MONEY AND
THEN EVERYBODY ELSE EXCEPT
THAT. THE CRIME SO- I DON'T
HAVE THAT RIGHT IN FRONT OF MY
FACE RIGHT NOW BUT THAT'S ONE
OF THE COMMENTS OTHERWISE I
THINK- THERE'S SOME GOOD
RECOMMENDATIONS HERE- I GUESS I
HAVE I DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR
HELP ALL IN TEARS AND IT'S
PROBABLY NOT IN YOUR WILL HOUSE
BUT- I JUST WANT TO GET IT OUT
THERE- WE- I HAD A TERRIBLE. A
WILDFIRE SEASON LAST YEAR AND
THIS YEAR IS GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY DRY AND I WONDER IF
WE SET UP A PROGRAM TO-
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM FORMER
INMATES WHO MAY HAVE SERVED ON
THOSE FIRE CREWS WE'VE MADE IT-
AN- EASIER FOR THEM TO BE GET
HIRED BY THE FIRE SERVICE OR-
FOR THE WILDFIRE YEAR IN I'M-
I'M WONDERING FOR DOING
ANYTHING TO. TO MAKE IT. CLEAR
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO I ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO BE HIRED BY THE
STATE. I'M SORRY TO PUT MR
FRIDAY ON THE- ON THE HOT SEAT
HERE BUT- IF YOU'VE GOT SOME
INSIGHTS. HAVING WORKED WORKED
WITH THE- YES SIR WITH THE FIRE
SERVICE. ANY ANYTHING YOU CAN
TELL HE'S IN ANOTHER- AND I
WILL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU IN
A SPECIFIC ANSWER WHAT I WILL
SAY IS THAT POPULATION IS VERY
MUCH THE INTENDED TARGET FOR
THIS PROGRAM TO BE ABLE TO
HIRE- FOLKS LIKE THAT WHO COME
OUT OF THAT PROGRAM AND SO- WE
WILL GET BACK TO YOU
SPECIFICALLY AND HOW WE WILL BE
COMMUNICATING. TO THAT
POPULATION BUT THAT IS VERY
MUCH THE SPIRIT AND THE
INTENTION OF THIS PROPOSAL. ONE
GLAD THAT I DO APPRECIATE THAT
I'VE HAD A NUMBER OF PHONE
CALLS FROM. FROM INDIVIDUALS
THAT WOULD. WOULD LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE AND I I'VE BEEN AT
A LOSS AS TO EXACTLY WHERE TO
DIRECT THEM SO- I JUST THINK
RIGHT NOW IS A REALLY GOOD TIME
TO GET THEM. WORKING IT'S A LOT
HARDER TO BE TO RECIDIVIST.
RECIDIVISM IF YOU'VE GOT A GOOD
JOB AND YOU'VE GOT A FUTURE IN
THAT JOB SO. SENATOR NELSON YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'LL PICK
UP ON YOUR LATTER POINT. FIRST
OF ALL THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
EMPTIED THE PRISONS OUT OVER
TWO OR THREE ADMINISTRATIONS.
THERE AREN'T VERY MANY LEFT.
THAT MEANS THAT THE FORCES THAT
COULD BE DEPLOYED AS INMATE
FIREFIGHTERS REALLY AREN'T
THERE. AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
BE THERE BECAUSE THE PLAN IS
IT'S CONTINUING TO EMPTY THE
PRISONS OUT TILL I GUESS THERE
AREN'T ANY. AND MOST OF THOSE
ARE NOT GOING TO GO. WORK AT
ALL AND THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO THEIR CRIMINAL
WORK. EDITORIAL OPINION
CONFESSED. THAT'S NOT MY POINT
BUT MY POINT IS. AS FAR AS
DEALING WITH THESE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WILL HELP US ON THE FIRES.
ONE PLACE HAS BEEN CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS. THEY'VE
BEEN A RELIABLE FORCE OF
REHABILITATING OR ALL READY TO
WORK. INDIVIDUALS WE'VE GOT TO
RELY ON THEM. THEY ARE GOING TO
BE THE HOPE FOR THE FUTURE. AND
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SECURE
MORE CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS. IF
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP UP WITH
THIS DISASTROUS CIRCUMSTANCE.
LET ME HAPPEN- ECHO ALL THROUGH
THE HOUSE THAT SHARES CONCERN.
ABOUT BIG CITIES VERSUS THE
SMALLER COMMUNITIES. IT'S
ALMOST AN INSULT TO SAY THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GET SO MUCH
AND THE LITTLE PLACES ARE GOING
TO GET COMPETITIVE GRANTS. I
THINK THE BIG CITY SHOULD
COMPETE WITH EACH OTHER AND
GIVE THE LITTLE CITIES. THE
ADVANTAGE. BIG CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE MULTIPLE
RESOURCES MONEY SOURCES THROWN
AT THEM AVAILABLE TO THEM. IN
OUR SMALLER COMMUNITIES DO NOT.
I'D LIKE US TO START REALIZING
THAT AND PAYING SOME ATTENTION
TO IT END UP PRIORITIZING IT
JUST A LITTLE BIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SENATOR
WELL I FEEL LIKE I HAVE TO
DEFEND THE BIG CITIES- I'M.
GLAD HE WALKED IN JUST. HI GOOD
GARNISH IT AGAIN THROUGH THIS
BEFORE AND IT MAKES YOU WALKED
IN. WHAT WHEN YOU DO DOUBLE
DUTY ON SO APOLOGIES- YOU KNOW
I JUST WANT TO- THE- DETAILS I
SAY THAT I TOO BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S GREAT BENEFIT IN
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS-
WHO ARE WORKING WITH YOUNG
FOLKS AND MORE MATURE FOLKS- IN
PROVIDING A GREAT SERVICE. BUT
I WOULD HAVE TO- ALSO SAY THAT
I THINK THAT HERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE WHO SOMEBODY'S IN PRISON
BECAUSE I GET TONS ON LETTERS-
FROM FOLKS THAT ARE IN PRISON.
SO I KNOW THAT THEY'RE THERE
AND I KNOW THAT THEY'RE
INCREDIBLY INVESTEDIN
LEARNING- TRADES AND SKILLS
THAT WILL HELP THEM FIND
EMPLOYMENT WHEN THEY GET OUT.
AND SO- AN EXAMPLE BEING CAL
FIRE OR ACTUALLY- FOR SOME TIME
THAT AND THOUSANDS OF OTHER.
PROFESSIONS I HAVE BEEN
EXEMPTED REALLY THROUGH OUR BNP
AND FORMER PENAL CODE OF FROM
FOLKS BEING ABLE TO LEARN THAT
KIND OF SKILL WHILE THEY ARE
INCARCERATED IN GETTING OUT AND
FINDING A JOB IN THAT
PARTICULAR TRADE. SO YOU KNOW I
AM HOPING THAT AS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT SERVICE
INTEGRATION AND COORDINATION OF
DOLLARS- THAT WE USE THAT CAL
FIRE- LEGISLATION FROM LAST
YEAR IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF WAYS
THAT WE CAN. OFFER MULTIPLE
BENEFITS- IT USING THE SAME
KIND OF DOLLARS IN A WAY THAT
ALSO SPEAKS TO THE VALUES OF-
THE STATE. OKAY VERY GOOD-
THERE IS A RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE LA- THAT WE- THIS MIGHT BE
A GOOD ISSUE THIS THIS AREA
MIGHT BE A GOOD EIGHT AREA TO
DEFERRED TO LATER ON IN THE
SUMMER- AND NOT TRY TO INCLUDE
THIS IN. IN THE JUNE BUDGET-
PROPOSAL- BUT WE'LL SEE YOU
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM WE
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE TO MAKE THAT
DECISION TODAY. UP BUT WE MAY
NEED TO TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME ON IT. THIS IS A HOLD OPEN
POSITION- ITEM AND SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO OPR FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
HERE TODAY WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY. WHICH
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL. MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER. TO MARK
WILSON WHO IS THE ACTING ACTING
CHIEF OF THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL. ACTUALLY MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS KIMBERLY HARVESTING FOR
FINANCE AND I'LL DO THE REVIEW
OKAY SOUNDS GOOD I'LL TAKE ONE
FOR THE FINANCE TEAM TODAY.
RIGHT WE ARE WE I JUST THOUGHT
WE WERE GIVING YOU ENOUGH WORK
TO DO. SO THE TEAM EFFORT- SO
GOOD I CAN MADAM. AND COMMITTEE
MY- I'M CAN REALLY. AND THE
DEPART OF FINANCE. AND I'D LIKE
TO SAY YOU. FOR YOUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP IN THE EVOLUTION OF
CANNABIS OVERSIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA I'LL GIVE YOU A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW. OF THE CANNABIS
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION. AND THEN WE HAVE OUR
PROJECT LEADERS FROM THE BUREAU
OF CANNABIS CONTROL FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
FOR YOU. SO THE FIRST
COMPONENT- IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL IS REQUESTING
TWO HUNDRED FORTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IN CANNABIS CONTROL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
ONE APPOINTED POSITION AND
THAT'S FOR A NEW DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF EQUITY AND
INCLUSION. THIS POSITION WILL
HELP STRENGTHEN THE
DEPARTMENT'S ROLE IN REDUCING
BARRIERS. FOR LOCAL EQUITY
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES.
FURTHER SUPPORT DIVERSE WORK
FORCES AND CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS EQUITY ACT
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND I'D
LIKE TO THAT THERE ARE A FEW
OTHER EQUITY PROPOSALS
INCLUDED. ELSEWHERE IN THE
MERRY VISION BUT THEY'RE NOT
DUPLICATIVE WITH THIS REQUEST.
OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR POSITION
WILL BE FOCUSED ON PROMOTING
EQUITY WITHIN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY SPECIFICALLY- GEARED
TOWARD FOSTERING EQUITABLE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO LICENSURE
AND BUSINESS OWNERSHIP IN THE
REGULATED CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
AND MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
MOST HARMED AND ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED BY PREVIOUS
CANNABIS CRIMINALIZATION ARE
OFFERED ASSISTANCE. AND
PRIORITY LICENSING ONE POSSIBLE
TO ENTER THE INDUSTRY AS
ENTREPRENEURS. THE SECOND
COMPONENT OF OUR PROPOSAL IS
UPDATED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
OR STATUTORY CHANGES- IT SAYS
THAT IN ADDITION TO WHAT WE
PROPOSE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THEY CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THE
AUTHORITY NEEDED TO TRANSITION
INTO A CONSOLIDATED DEPARTMENT
OF CANNABIS CONTROL. THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IS LANGUAGE
TO EXTEND THE DEPARTMENT'S
ABILITY TO ISSUE NEW COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS LICENSES BY SIX MONTHS
SO THAT THEY WOULD GO THROUGH.
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- IT MAKES. ENVIRONMENTAL
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS BEFORE
AN LAST. AND REQUIRES THAT THE
TO PROMULGATE REGULATIONS.
IDENTIFYING STEPS THAT MUST BE
TAKEN FOR PROVISIONAL LICENSEES
SHOW PROGRESS TOWARD ACHIEVING
ANNUALIZED INJURE. AND THE
THIRD AND FINAL COMPONENT OF
THE MERRY MISSION PACKAGE THIS
YEAR. IT IS A ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
REQUEST FOR A LOCAL
JURISDICTION ASSISTANCE GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD SUPPORT
TRANSITIONAL PROVISIONAL
LICENSEES TO ANNUAL LICENSES.
ACCIDENTALLY 82% OF
CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS LICENSEES
ARE PROVISIONALLY LICENSED.
THIS FUNDING WILL SERVE OVER
60% OF OUR- OF THAT GROUP AND-
IT WILL BE THE DIRECT SUPPORT
TO THEM AND TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TO QUANTIFY IT
MORE CLEARLY. THE STRUGGLE
EIGHT NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND OF
THE EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
PROVISIONAL LICENSES ISSUED BY
THE STATE AS OF MAY FIFTH- JUST
EARLIER THIS MONTH AND THE FANS
ARE INTENDED TO LIGHT TO AID.
THE IDENTIFIED LOOK JURIST AND
MORE EXPEDITIOUSLY
EXPEDITIOUSLY REVIEWING
PROVISIONAL LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS NOTABLY THOSE
RELATED TO SICKLE. AND CAN BE
PASSED THROUGH TO LICENSEES FOR
THINGS. LIKE MITIGATION
MEASURES MEASURES INCLUDING
WATER CONSERVATION SO- THAT'S
EVERY CAT AND IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS WERE HAPPY TO TAKE
THEM. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH- LET'S SEE IF THE- ELLIE-
HAS ANY COMMENTS. ADAM SHARED
BY MEMBERS SO LA. ANALYST
OFFICE- WE HAVE COMMENTS ON THE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR-
GRANT PROPOSAL THAT WAS
MENTIONED. THIS PROPOSAL RAISES
A NUMBER OF ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
INCLUDING WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO USE GENERAL FUND
TO OFFSET LOCAL COTS THAT ARE
NORMALLY COVERED WITH LOCAL
FEES. AND OR LICENSEES PRIVATE
FUNDS WHETHER IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO SUBSIDIZE THE COST OF ANNUAL
LICENSURE FOR ONLY A PORTION OF
LICENSEES. WHETHER STRUCTURING
THE PROGRAM AS A LOAN RATHER
THAN A GRAND WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE. HOW DCC WOULD
ENSURE FUNDING IS PRIORITIZED
FOR LICENSEES WHO WOULD NOT
OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO TRANSITION
INTO AN ANNUAL LICENSE HOW DCC
WOULD ENSURE THAT FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED TO LICENSEES WHO ARE
LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO OPERATE
SUCCESSFULLY FOR THE LONG TERM.
AND HOW DO YOU SEE C. WILL
ENSURE JURISDICTIONS THAT
RECEIVED FUNDS OFFER FULLY
PURSUE OTHER AVENUES OF
EXPEDITING THE TRANSITION TO
ANNUAL LICENSES RATHER THAN
RELYING SOLELY ON STATE GRANT
FUNDS. AND FINALLY WHAT
ACTIVITIES DCC WOULD AUTHORIZE
FUNDS BE USED FOR BEYOND THOSE
EXPLICITLY IDENTIFIED IN THE
PROPOSAL. I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT THE-
VISITATION BRING IT BACK TO.
THE CENTERED IN NIELSEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS A VERY
SENSITIVE AREA. INDEED IN MANY
RESPECTS. THERE'S MENTION MADE
OF CLEANING UP OUR WATERWAYS.
THAT'S NOT A NEW PROBLEM IT'S A
HISTORIC PROBLEM AND IT'S
HAPPENING ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
THE GROWERS OUR GREATEST OF ALL
POLLUTERS DISREGARDING ANY
LOCAL INTEREST WHATSOEVER AND
NOT TRYING TO GET ALONG IN FACT
THAT ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES.
CROCKED THE ILLEGAL GROWERS
BURTON FIFTY LEGAL GROWERS THE
ILLEGAL I'M SORRY I DID NOT
NEED THE LEGAL GROWERS THANK
YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION. AND
DO NOT TRY TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TO GRANT MONEY
SHOULD GO TO THEM. TO HELP WITH
THREE CRITICAL REQUIREMENTS. TO
HELP IF YOU WILL SUBSIDIZE
THEIR LICENSING FEES WHICH I
THINK SOME OF THIS IS DIRECTED
TO. I JUST CANNOT BUY THAT. IF
WE'RE GOING TO DIRECT ANY MONEY.
IN TERMS OF CLEANING UP OUR
WATERWAYS WE SHOULD DIRECTION
TO LOCAL SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
WHO CAN THEN SEND DEPUTY
SHERIFFS OUT WITH THE WATER
BOARD PERSONNEL TO INVESTIGATE
THE GIRL WISH. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE NOT POLLUTING.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM. AND THEN
HOLDING THEM LIABLE FOR THOSE
WHO ARE THE POLLUTERS TO WHAT
DEGREE WE CAN LEGALLY TO CLEAN
UP THEIR OWN MASH. I THINK
WE'RE GOING PROCESS THE VERY
WRONG WAY AND IT'S ONLY
GETTING. MORE WRONG AS WE
PROCEED. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR COME LONGER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- WHY I MY QUESTIONS
WERE SORT OF AROUND- THE EQUITY
ISSUES AROUND THE ISSUE OF
CANNABIS AND LICENSING- GUYS
CERTAINLY CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
WATER ISSUE- BUT THE I IN MY IN
MY MIND FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD
FROM FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT IN
AROUND LOS ANGELES COUNTY WERE
DEALING WITH IT THE ATAP
MYSTERY OF ISSUES BASED ON THIS
VERY PATCHY- COORDINATION-
BASED ON VERY DIFFERENT LOCAL
ORDINANCES AND HOW THEY ARE
EITHER WORKING OR NOT WORKING
TOGETHER- COUPLED WITH THE FACT
THAT. YOU HAVE FOLKS THAT WERE
PARTICIPATING IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER IN THE INDUSTRY AND NOW
ARE TRYING TO GET INTO THE
INDUSTRY IN A LEGALIZED FASHION
AND A REALLY HINDERED- BY A
SOME OF THE CRITERIA AND THEN
AROUND THE LICENSING YOU KNOW
AND THEN IF WE'RE JUST GOING TO
HAVE A REAL CONVERSATION WE'RE
GONNA SAY THAT- IN MANY
INSTANCES THERE. THESE SORT OF
ON TAX BURDENS AND SO FOR THE
CONSUMER WHO'S TRYING TO YOU
KNOW JUST IN. WE WERE GOING TO
BE HONEST HERE IS ABOUT
CANNABIS NEED WHAT WE GONNA BUY
CANNABIS FOR SEVEN DOLLARS FROM
A TRUSTED SOURCE YOU GONNA BUY
CANNABIS FOR FIFTY NINE DOLLARS
IN SOME OLD MINIMALIST HIPSTER-
YOU KNOW STOREFRONT. AND SO IF
WE'RE TRYING TO PULL FOLKS INTO
THE LEGALIZE MARKET THAT HAS TO
COME WITH- A STRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS EQUITY AND HOW WE'RE
GIVING OUT THE LICENSES AND
OFFERING TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND
ALSO TALKING ABOUT THE EQUITY
IN THE CAPITAL THAT'S NEEDED
FOR FOLKS WHO WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT GETTING INTO. THIS SPACE
LEGALLY- BASED ON EQUITY
DISCUSSIONS AND SOCIAL EQUITY
PROGRAMS YOU KNOW AND THEN
HAVING THAT MANIFEST SO. I
GUESS TO SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE ECHOED BY THE LA O'S
OFFICE YOU KNOW I'M WONDERING
WHERE IN THESE PROPOSALS SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED
BECAUSE YOU STILL DON'T WANT IT
TO BE THE WILD WILD WEST THERE
HAS TO BE COORDINATION- WITH
DIFFERENT LOCALITIES. THERE HAS
TO BE AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE WHAT THE GOALS ARE- WITH
MAYBE NOT HAVING SO MANY
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES AND
MOVING TOWARDS- NOT HAVING THAT
VERY TEMPORARY LIMBO STATE AND
THEN ADDRESSING YOUR EQUITY
DISPARITIES- THAT HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGING. FOR SO MANY FOLKS
ACROSS THE STATE. SO AND LIKE
DEPARTMENT OF DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THINK.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I'M
GONNA- DEFER TO OUR EXPERT EVER
TOOK PART FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGRICULTURE FROM THE-
SEQUOIA AND SOME OF THE EQUITY
COMPONENT. THANK YOU THIS IS
RICHARD CURRENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE- ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU'RE COMING
IN PERFECTLY. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I'M I DO WANT TO-
ANSWER THAT THE SENATOR'S
QUESTION AND SEE IF I COULD
TOUCH ON HOW WE DEVELOP TO THIS
FORMULA IN LOOKING AT THE
VARIOUS COUNTIES AND CITIES
ACROSS THE STATE WHERE WE'RE
INTENDING. TO PROVIDE THESE
FINDS. OUT WHAT WE DID IS WE
LOOK AT THE TOP EIGHT
JURISDICTIONS. WEST THE MOST
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
PROFESSIONAL LICENSED CANNABIS
CULTIVATORS- FOR TWENTY FIVE
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF THE FINES.
ON THE OTHER 25% OF THE FUNDS
WE LOOKED AT THE TOP EIGHT.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ALLOWING
FOR LICENSED CANNABIS
MANUFACTURING- AS WELL AS
DISTRIBUTING TESTING MICRO
BUSINESSES AND RETAIL. THE THE
OTHER 50% OF THE FINES ARE
INTENDED FOR JURISDICTIONS THAT
DO HAVE SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAMS.
SO IN LOOKING AT- THE BEST WAY
TO MAKE USE OF THIS MONEY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS. PROVIDE
MONEY TO THESE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO HELP PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THESE LICENSEES
THAT WHOLE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES- PROVISIONAL LICENSES
ARE NOT FULL FULLY APPROVED-
FULLY COMPLIANT LICENSES WITH
ALL THE STATUTORY AND
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS. AND
LICENSE IS WHAT GETS THEM
THERE- THE PATHWAY TO FROM A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE TO AN
ANNUAL LICENSE IS A BIT OF A
LEFT SHE- IS ONE OF THE-
HURDLES TO GET THROUGH- OUR
INTENT HERE IS TO. HELP THESE
JURISDICTIONS MOVIES
PROVISIONAL LICENSEES INTO
ANNUAL LICENSE LICENSURE- THERE
THEREBY I'M NOT REMAINING IN
LIMBO AND POTENTIALLY- NOT
BEING ABLE TO TAKE IT. TO AN
ANNUAL LICENSE FOR AND-
POTENTIALLY LOSE THEM OUT TO
THE- MARK. I'M ONLY GET ONE WE
LOOKED OUR NUMBER- THIS IS THIS
CAPS OR OR BE TO SEE A PROP SO.
PER OF ALL OF THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSEES IN GETTING TO ANNUAL
LICENSURE- D. ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
THAT WOULD RECEIVE THIS FUNDING
ARE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT THEIR-
THEIR PROPOSED PLAN TO THE
DEPARTMENT THAT WILL BE
REVIEWED. THERE WILL BE
PERIODIC MONITORING SO THOSE
PLANS TO ENSURE THAT THAT MONEY
IS BEING USED- FOR WHAT IT'S
INTENDED FOR- AND WHERE WE'VE
ALSO- WILL BE SPEAKING WITH-
FEES ARE PROPOSED
JURISDICTIONS. I'M IN THE NEAR
FUTURE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ON
HOW- IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT WHAT THESE PLANS.
NEED TO TELL. THE CENTER KEMANA.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
BE SEEN AS A GOOD PARTNER- IN
THE CANNABIS SPACE. AND WE NEED
TO MAKE IT- EASIER FOR PEOPLE
TO WANT TO APPLY YOU KNOW AND
COMPLY- BECAUSE I THINK THE
GOAL IS FOR. AT LEAST FOR ME
BUT FOR OTHERS TO NOT HAVE TO
SEE THESE KIND OF DISCUSSIONS
COME UP IN OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEES BECAUSE WE ARE
FIGURING OUT A WAY. USING DUE
DILIGENCE- AND REALITY TO
ADDRESS THIS MARKET YOU KNOW
AND TRUTHFULLY AN OPPORTUNITY-
IN WAYS THAT BENEFIT THE STATE.
AND THIS INDUSTRY SO. JUST MY
COMMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT AND I AM I
APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR COMMENTS
I THINK WHAT THIS. PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES AND I. I'VE BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD IN THE
SPACE BECAUSE I HAVE A BILL
THAT IF WE APPROVE THIS BUDGET
DISAPPEARS. SO BUT BUT- AND
HAVING HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT-
STAKEHOLDERS- THE BLOCKAGES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND WHAT THIS
ANTICIPATES IS PUTTING THE
RESOURCES OUT TO THE LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT TO HELP FIND THE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO GET DONE-
THE TESTIMONY AT THE HEARING
WAS THAT THERE'S SOMETHING LIKE
TWENTY DIFFERENT AGENCIES THAT
ARE INVOLVED IN AND LOOKING AT
WHETHER IT- THAT PROPERTY
SPECIFIC SEQUENCE ANALYSIS IS
BEEN DONE APPROPRIATELY- ALL OF
THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT IT'S A
QUESTION OF PUTTING THE
RESOURCES. TO CREATING THE
ORDINANCES THAT MAKE IT
POSSIBLE TO ACTUALLY MOVE THIS
FORWARD AND SO- HI I AM A- I
THINK THIS. THERE'S SOMETHING
FOR EVERYBODY TO LIKE AND NOT
LIKE IN THIS WHICH MEANS IT'S
PROBABLY A GOOD COMPROMISE- I-
APPRECIATE THE- ON. THE THERE
WERE THERE WERE THE PROPOSAL IS
IT FOR IT TO BE A GRANT PROCESS
RIGHT NOW AND I'M THINKING THAT
IT MAY BE IT MAY MAKE AND I
UNDERSTOOD THAT IF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION EXCEPT ACCEPTS A
GRANT AND THEN DOESN'T DO WHAT
THEY SAID THEY WERE GOING TO DO
THAT THERE'S A CALLBACK PERMIT
PROVISION I DIDN'T HEAR THAT
MENTIONED TODAY BUT IT MAY MAKE
SENSE FOR US TO DO IT AS A AS A
GRANT THAT CAN BE FORGIVEN. IN
OTHER WORDS IT'S A LOAN THAT
CAN BE FORGIVEN IF YOU GET YOUR
ACT TOGETHER AND YOU START-
APPROVING THESE THESE- THESE
LICENSES MOVING I'M HEARD FROM
PROVISIONAL TO ANNUAL IS REALLY
WHAT WE WANT- AND I DO WANNA
SECOND WITH MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SAID
IS THAT I THINK ALONG WITH THIS
PROPOSAL UP WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A DROUGHT AND TO HAVE
ILLEGAL DIVERT HERS OF WATER-
TO MAINTAIN AN ILLEGAL PRODUCT-
IS PARTICULARLY EGREGIOUS AND
I'M TOLD THAT IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WATER I
THINK WE OUGHT TO PUT MONEY
INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BE ABLE
TO GO UP THERE AND- TO STOP THE
ILLEGAL DIVERSIONS- AND- IT'S A
IT'S A WATER BOARD ISSUE AND
THE MORE THAT WE CAN. CREATE
THESE TEAMS TO GO IN AND DO THE
WORK I THINK THAT WOULD BE
REALLY IMPORTANT I'VE BEEN
INVITED TO GO ON A TOUR WITH
THEM SENATOR DOLLY AND I'D BUY
AND. PLANT PLAN TO TAKE HIM UP
ON THAT. BECAUSE IF IT MEANS
WE'D HAVE MORE WATER FOR THE
LEGITIMATE USES THAT WE NEED IN
THE STATE WE NEED TO DO THIS
RIGHT AWAY SO I SECOND WITH MY
COLLEAGUE HAS TO SAY SO THIS
IS- AND OTHER ITEMS THAT IS
EASY. HOLD OPEN. IDMS SO WE
WILL DO THAT I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE ANY MORE. QUESTIONS ON
THIS ITEM SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT WHICH IS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION FUNDING. AND I'D
LIKE TO TURN THAT OVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT- YES GOOD AFTERNOON-
MADAM CHAIRS AND MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE- ANYTIME HERE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
ALSO THE STATE TROOPER
INFORMATION OFFICER JOINING ME
TODAY AREMY COLLEAGUE SAID
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR RUSS
MICHAEL AS WELL AS THE CHIEF
TECHNOLOGY OFFICER RICK CLOUGH
AS WELL AS THE CHIEF TECHNOLOGY
OFFICER. LIANNA BAILEY
CRIMMINS- WE ALL HEAR TOO READY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE A LET ME
START JUST TO PROVIDE FIVE
SIMPLE POINT OF- CONTEXTUAL
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
TECHNOLOGY MODERNIZATION FUND
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY ARE THAT
MINISTRATION IS ASKING. FIRST
OF ALL- THIS FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR ASK IS A OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD- AND IS TO FIND-
LOOKING TO FIND SMALLER
INITIATIVES IN THE RANGE OF TWO
TO THREE MILLION DOLLAR EACH-
WITH A TOTAL OF POSSIBLY TEN TO
FIFTEEN MILLIONS OVER THREE
YEAR PERIOD- IT IS A MODEL THAT
WE ARE LEARNING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- THAT HAVE
HAD THIS TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION FUND ESTABLISHED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
AND RECENTLY WITH THE INFLUX
OF- FURTHER INVESTMENT UPWARDS
OF A ONE BILLION DOLLAR
INTERNET TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION FUND GIVING THE-
IMPORTANT ROLE WITH THAT THAT
DIGITAL PLATFORM IF NEEDED. IN
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS. AND THAT-
SO I WANT TO SURE THAT THE IS
NOT A BRAND COST BUT IT'S- A
PROGRAM- THIRD BAD THIS FINAL
PRETTY. GOING TO BE YOU. FOR
ACTUALLY MAIN. WHINY IS TO- PER.
A STAR UP FUND IF YOU- TO SERVE
SOME OF THE PROOF OF CONCEPT
DATA VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS IN THE
STATE GOVERNMENT WOULD LIKE TO
LAUNCH AND THEY MAY NOT BE
PERFECTLY FIT INTO THE- BUDGET
CYCLE. BUT INSTEAD OF WAITING
FOR THE BUDGET CYCLE THIS WOULD
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO FUND SOME
OF THE INITIATIVE IN THE
SMALLER SCALE- SECOND ID IF
THERE WERE- HIGH RISK. MISSION
CRITICAL SYSTEMS THAT WERE
DISCOVERED BASED ON THE
STABILIZATION EFFORT THAT MY
DEPARTMENT HAS PROPOSED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR THIS
FINDING WOULD POTENTIALLY HELP
TO ACTUALLY MITIGATE SOME OF
THE MOST RISK IN A MORE RAPID
MANNER INSTEAD OF. WAITING FOR
THE FULL- BUT JUST CYCLE. AND
THIRD IF THERE ARE SOME- A
SECURITY VULNERABILITY THAT WAS
DISCOVERED YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR THIS COULD POTENTIALLY
HELP WITH THAT EFFORT AS WELL.
SO REALLY THOSE ARE THE PURPOSE
OF THIS PARTICULAR FUND- LASTLY
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
MADE CLEAR- AND I BELIEVE THIS
IS MIGHT HAVE BEEN SOME OF THE
CONCERN THAT. THIS TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION FUND- IT'S NOT
SOMETHING I DEVELOPED TO
CLINICAL CIRCUMVENT THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT WITH THE
MUCH LARGER- INVESTMENT- DEEP
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
PROCESS BUT THE LARGER
INVESTMENT CONTINUE TO. EXIST
AND IN FACT IF SOME OF THESE
PROOF OF CONCEPT YOU KNOW
DEVELOPS TO BE. WORTH A LARGER
SCALE INVESTMENT A BAD WAY TO
GO THROUGH THAT OR COMPLETING
THAT PROJECT APPROVALS LIFE
CYCLE WHICH INVOLVES
LEGISLATIVE- DE OVERSIGHT-
LASTLY ONE OTHER THINGS I WANT
TO POINT OUT. IS TIED TO- WE
UNDERSTAND THERE MIGHT THE
CONCERN TO STAY HEY I SO- WE IS
LET. INVOLVED AND IN TODAY'S.
THAT MANY THE PAR- WHEN IT
COMES TO OF IN A AS SUCH DATE.
FIND A WAY TO IT COMES. WITHOUT
BIZ THE- TO DEBORAH SENSE
INCLUDING RELIGIOUS. OR THE
JUST THE FAR DOING THAT AND
TELL THINGS BECOME DIRE THEN
YOU GET A BIG- INVESTMENT
REQUEST TO SAY WE GOT TO DO IT
BECAUSE NOW IT'S- A YOU KNOW A
BAD. STAGE SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS TO GET IN FRONT OF
THAT NUMBER ONE THAT WE DID
AGREE TO- IF THIS HAVE THE
APPROVAL OF THE LEGISLATURE
DIED OUT WE WILL BE PROVIDING
TWICE A YEAR REPORT. ON THE
UTILIZATION OF SUCH FUNDING
PROVIDED VISIBILITY THAT
OTHERWISE STATE LEGISLATURE
WOULD NOT HAVE HAD. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS WOULD ALLOW US
TO GET IN FRONT OF THE SOME OF
THE- YOU KNOW MISSION CRITICAL
SYSTEM BEFORE THEY BREAK- SO
WITHOUT OUR- I WILL WRAP UP MY
PRESENTATION AT OPEN FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DIRECTOR. SHE'D HERE- YOUR
PRESENTATION I'M GOING TO ASK.
SINCE IF THEY HAVE A- QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS. ISSUES RIGHT
FINANCE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY-
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS HOW ABOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PANEL OFFICE.
PRIME MINISTER LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE HAVE
SEVERAL CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL OUR FIRST THE REQUEST
WOULD LIMIT THE LEGISLATURE'S
OVERSIGHT OF I. T. SYSTEM
STABILIZATION AND MODERNIZATION
EFFORTS BY INCOME BRING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF GENERAL
FUND OVER SEVERAL YEARS WITH
ONLY SEMI ANNUAL LEGISLATIVE
REPORTING LANGUAGE WE BELIEVE
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
INVOLVED THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN THE REVIEW APPROVAL
AND PRIORITIZATION OF THESE
EFFORTS ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. SECOND THE REQUEST
PROPOSES NO NEW STAUTE TO
AUTHORIZE OR ADMINISTRATIVE
POLICY TO GUIDE THE NEW FUND
ADMINISTRATION SAYS THE
PROPOSAL IS MODELED AFTER THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION FUND PROGRAM BUT
THAT PROGRAM WAS AUTHORIZED BY
FEDERAL LEGISLATION AND
IMPLEMENTED SOON THERE AFTER
WITH CLEAR POLICY GUIDANCE BY
CONTRAST THIS REQUEST INCLUDES
SOME EXAMPLES OF CRITERIA TO BE
USED. AND PROCESSES TO BE
FOLLOWED BUT NONE OF THE
EXAMPLES PROVIDED ARE REQUIRED
IN STATUTE OR POLICY ANY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE WAY
THE STATE BUDGETS FOR THE
STABILIZATION AND MODERNIZATION
EFFORTS SHOULD BE PROPOSED
WITHOUT A MINIMUM TRAINER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR CONSIDERATION BY
THE LEGISLATURE. THIRD THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BENEFIT FROM
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
STATE'S IT SYSTEM STABILIZATION
AND MODERNIZATION NEEDS THE
THREE NEW PROGRAMS PROPOSED BY
CITY TEEN IN THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET APPROVED BY BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES ARE EXPECTED TO
PROVIDE SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION AND SO WAITING
UNTIL CDC IMPLEMENTS THESE NEW
PROGRAMS AND PROVIDES THIS
INFORMATION WOULD HELP THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDE HOW BEST TO
PRIORITIZE THESE EFFORTS AND
SO. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK. YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WHEN I BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE DIET IN C.
IF THERE'S ANY KIND. SENATOR
NOW. MADAM CHAIR AT A- THE VERY
DAY. OBSERVATION FOR. DIFFICULT
BECAUSE I HAVE SUCH HIGH REGARD
FOR THE LEADERSHIP AT THIS
AGENCY I'VE KNOWN HIM FOR MANY
MANY YEARS AND I FIND THEM TO
BE TOP TOP PANTS EXCELLENT
PEOPLE VERY DEDICATED VERY
SINCERE. I HAVE TO WEIGH THAT
AGAINST THE FACT THAT THIS
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN A MESS
EVER SINCE IT STARTED. NOW IT'S
BEEN IMPROVING AND I GIVE THE
CURRENT LEADERSHIP A LOT OF
CREDIT FOR THAT HAPPENING. BUT
IT'S STILL A PROBLEM AGENCY WHY.
MOST RECENTLY ET D. ANOTHER
TERRIBLY PROBLEMATIC AGENCY HAD
TWO CRASHES AND BURNS OF A THAI
TEA APPOINTMENT AT A CRITICAL
MOMENT. WHERE OUR CITIZENS ARE
SUFFERING GRIEVOUSLY. BY THE
INCOMPETENCE OF THAT AGENCY AND
I WONDER I CAN'T QUIT GOES DOWN.
THE ISSUE IS THAT FOR DECADES
FAR PRE DATING THIS LEADERSHIP-
BEEN PUT THERE TO STRAIGHTEN
OUT THE MESS. AND I FEEL FOR
THEM BECAUSE IT'S A FORMIDABLE
MASS. BUT FOR DECADES THESE
BILLION DOLLAR PROJECTS HAVE
NEVER COME IN ON TIME THEY'VE
NEVER COME IN ON BUDGET. AND I
FOR THE I. T. COMPANIES
THEMSELVES. FOR THE WAY THIS IS
ALL COME DOWN. THEY ARE
EXPLOITING THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYER FOR THEIR OWN BOTTOM
LINE ADVANTAGES. GIVING US A
QUICK BUT THAT DOES NOT
FUNCTION AS PROMISED. BUT BUT
RATHER OFFERS HOLLOW PROMISES.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE DARE NOT
AT THIS TIME GIVE UP ANY MORE
OF OUR REVIEW AUTHORITY
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY AND THE
SANCTIONING AUTHORITY MEANING
THAT WE AND I AND CORPORATE A
LITTLE BIT OF GENERAL SERVICES
IN THIS TOO I THINK THEY HAVE
BEEN UP SOME GUILT IN THE
NEGOTIATION OF CONTRACTS. SO WE
CAN'T WE CAN'T TAKE THIS
LIGHTLY IT'S COSTING US
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND NOT
DELIVERING. THAT WHICH HAS BEEN
PROMISED BY THE I. T. COMPANIES
AND THIS IS THE I. T. CAPITAL
OF THE WORLD. IT SHOULD BE A
HUGE EMBARRASSMENT TO
CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE THIS
CONTINUE. WELL SAID- SENATOR I
IDEA I FEEL THE SAME WAY I HAVE
A GREAT DEAL OF RESPECT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE WORKING
THERE AND- YET I ALSO FEEL LIKE
WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME OVERSIGHT.
ADD INTO THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
LEVEL- I WHEN I HEARD THE LA-
SAY AND I AGREE IS THAT THERE
THEY HAVE TO BE PARAMETERS
AROUND IF YOU'RE GOING TO
RECEIVE A POT OF MONEY TO BE
ABLE TO DO THIS KIND OF
INNOVATIVE WORK AND I SUPPORT.
I SUPPORT IT- THAT THERE HAVE
TO BE- SOME- SOME WAY FOR US TO
EVALUATE WHETHER YOU ACTUALLY
ACHIEVED. THE SUCCESS IN THE
PROVINCE THE EXPENDITURE OF
RESOURCES SO- THIS IS PROBABLY-
AT A SUBJECT FOR A FUTURE DATE
WELL IT'S HOLD OPEN I. ITEM SO
WE'RE GONNA HOLD IT OPEN BUT I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT- THAT THIS
THE EDITOR SOME PLICY ISSUES
HERE THAT ARE IMPORTANT- AND
THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT AND IT
WE MAY NEED TO BILL. RATHER
THAN AT THAT THROUGH A BUDGET-
PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO GET US
THERE- SO HAVING SAID THAT THIS
IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER- ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO. T IS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
HEADQUARTERS COMPLEX
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS. SO
WE WILL ASK. IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE GONNA ASK THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO PRESENT THIS.
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GUSTAVO
MADONNA WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I'LL BE SPEAKING ON
THE HEADQUARTERS COMPLEX
PROJECTS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT VERY GOOD.
SO THE FOR THE FOR THE
SACRAMENTO CONSOLIDATED
HEADQUARTERS COMPLEX THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTINGAT TWENTY FIVE.
POINT EIGHT MILLION
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATION FOR
THE DESIGN BUILD PHASE THE
PROJECT INCLUDES THE NEW
HEADQUARTERS COMPLEX WHICH WILL
ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA MILLION
MILITARY DEPARTMENT TO.
CONSOLIDATE PERSONNEL LOCATED
IN SEVERAL LEASE BUILDINGS
THROUGHOUT SACRAMENTO INTO A
SINGLE COMPLEX AFTER THE RECENT
CHALLENGES THAT WE DISCUSSED
WITH YOU AT THAT IN THE
LEGISLATURE LAST WEEK. THESE
FUNDS WILL HELP STEER THE
PROJECT BACK ON TRACK AND
MAINTAIN ITS TRAJECTORY TOWARDS
COMPLETION. WITH THE ADDITION
OF THESE FUNDS TO ASSIST WITH
PROJECT MANAGEMENT INSPECTION
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
AN INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
ENGINEERING SUPPORT SERVICES.
BOTH CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT AND THE CONTRACTOR
OF THE PROJECT SHOULD BE ABLE
TO RESUME ONSITE ACTIVITIES
QUICKLY A PARTNER- MEETINGS
HAVE ALREADY BEGUN LAST WEEK TO
START ADDRESSING THE ISSUES
THAT WE DISCUSSED LAST WEEK-
THAT HAD TO RESTART THE PROJECT
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD. GOOD
ANALYSTS OFFICE. HERE'S OF
BORED LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
VERY GOOD BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. I THOUGHT LET ME JUST
SAY THAT IT LOOKS LIKE THERE
AREN'T ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS WE DID HAVE A FAIRLY
EXTENSIVE BRIEFING ON THIS
EARLIER- IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
GET THIS BACK ON TRACK AND-
IT'S DISAPPOINTING TO BE IN
THIS POSITION WHERE. OUR OWN
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS GETS- RED
TAGGED AND SO THE SOONER THAT
WE CAN GET ON WITH THE TASK OF
BRINGING THIS UP. IT UP TO CODE
AND DO IT IN A SAFE WAY- IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT SO THIS IS A
HOLDOVER HOLD OPEN ITEM. OUT SO
WE WILL DO THAT AND- WE'LL MOVE
ON THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION WILL MOVE ON TO.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND DEVELOPMENT. ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE ADDITIONAL
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS. CAN THAT
WE WILL TURN OVER TO THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE. CAROLINE
GRAY. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
REQUEST- THE IN FOR AN
ADDITIONAL. FIVE- BILLION
DOLLARS TO- ADD TO THIS
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF GRANT FUND AND I DO
BELIEVE ON THE ARMED OFFICE OF
FINANCE IS ON BOARD FOR COMMENT.
VERY GOOD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
TIM WEBER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I CAN I ENTER THIS PROPOSAL SO
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY REALLY GREAT PROBLEM
PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TO
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO
SMALL BUSINESSES AFFECTED BY
THE PANDEMIC BUT BY GRANTS UP
TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
SO FAR TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS HAS BEEN ALLOCATED THIS
PROGRAM OVER SIX ROUNDS OF
GRANTS INCLUDING A AROUND FOR
NONPROFIT CULTURE INSTITUTIONS.
THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDED JUST
A ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND THREE DIGITAL
ROUNDS OF GRANTS. IN ADDITION
FIFTY NINE DOLLARS ALLOCATED TO
YOU THE- ROUND OF FUNDING FOR
NONPROFIT CULTURE INSTITUTIONS
ONLY THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT BEING AWARDED
SO THE MAYOR VISION PROPOSES
STATUTORY CHANGES TO ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL ROUND- GRANTS TO FOR
THE RAIN SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS.
EVERY INTERNET QUESTIONS- AND
OF COURSE I GO THERE'S A LINE.
FOR QUESTIONS AS WELL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MOVING
ON TO THE LEAD. ANALYST'S OFF.
THANK YOU SENATOR KABIRU
WHETHER FORD LATEST ANALYST'S
OFFICE- WE DO NOT HAVE A
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION
REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL BUT WE
HOPE WE CAN PUT SOME THE
AMOUNTS IN CONTEXT TO DATE THE
PROGRAM HAS RECEIVED A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND MORE
APPLICATIONS AND WAS ABLE TO
FIND AND THE PROPOSED FUNDING
IS SUFFICIENT FOR ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
MORE GRANTS. AND THE GRANTS ARE
FIVE THOUSAND TEN THOUSAND AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
DEPENDING ON THE APPLICANT'S
GROSS REVENUE AND SO WE
ESTIMATE THAT ANOTHER. THREE
HUNDRED MILLION WOULD BE
NECESSARY TO FIND ALL OF THE
GRANTS THAT HAVE BEEN REQUESTED
TO DATE- THE STAFF AND THE
AGENDA NOTED SEVERAL IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATIONS REGARDING THE-
CONTINUATION AND EXPANSION OF
THIS PROGRAM AND WE'D BE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOU IN YOUR STAFF
TO HELP THINK ABOUT SOME
VARIOUS ALTERNATIVES. ON THE
MAY REVISION ALSO REALLOCATE
SIXTEEN MILLION FOR NON PROFIT
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS THAT WAS
NOT AWARDED IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FOR A SECOND ROUND
OF NONPROFIT CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS GRANTS IN JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- GO BUSINESS
SUGGESTED THAT AN AUDITION-
ROUND OF GRANTS COUPLED WITH
TARGETED OUTREACH MIGHT
INCREASE THE DEMAND FOR.
COMFORT RELIEF PROGRAM AMONG
THIS GROUP. HOWEVER IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE THAT A LARGE AMOUNT OF
ADDITIONAL DEMAND MAY NOT
MATERIALIZE AND WE WOULD
SUGGEST STOPPING SOME BUDGET
BILLING WHICH THEY GIVE SCOPE
IS ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY.
OUTSIDE THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS TO ADDRESS THAT AND WE
CAN WORK WITH- STUFF ON THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT- UP.
FLEXIBILITY IS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT AND I ALSO APPRECIATE
THAT. THE IDEA THAT WE MAY WANT
TO. REDO THE DIFFERENT- PHASES
OR I THINK RECALLING ON. ROUNDS
RIGHT ROUNDS- SO- WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DYESS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS- SO I DO HAVE A UP A
COMMENT IN A CONCERN THIS IS
THIS- SMALL BUSINESS GRANT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS
SUCCESS SUCCESSFUL AND YOU HAVE
TO SAY THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS
DONE A VERY GOOD JOB IN IN-
MANAGING THE PROGRAM AND
GETTING THE RESOURCES OUT TO
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE IT HAS BEEN
A SUCCESS AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED AND I'VE BEEN OUT
SPEAKING TO SMALL BUSINESSES IN
MY DISTRICT AND- I HAVE HEARD.
SOME GOOD THINGS- SO THAT THE
EXTENSION OF THE PROGRAM AND
ADDING A NUMBER OF ROUNDS IS
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT. THERE THE GRANT
APPLICATION IS ONLY IN ENGLISH
AND- GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
THE NUMBER OF ROUNDS AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY DO THAT
GRANT APPLICATION WHICH IS
FAIRLY BASIC IN OTHER- PRIMARY
LANGUAGES IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT SO I'M I'M RAISING
THAT NOW BECAUSE I. HAVE SOME
CONCERNS IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
MANY PEOPLE COULDN'T ACCESS THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY OR
COULDN'T FILL OUT THE
APPLICATION IN A WAY THAT WOULD
HAVE PROVIDED THEM WITH
RESOURCES. AND IT DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE TO ME NOT TO HAVE. I
HAVE- ENOUGH IN SPANISH AND ONE
IT'S NOT THAT IT'S- FOR
L'INDUSTRIE TO TRANSLATE NUMBER
TWO. AND THEY'RE MAKING A LOT
OF MONEY OFF OF THIS PROGRAMME
SO- I WOULD REQUEST THAT. WE
CONSIDER MAKING IT A
REQUIREMENT IT FRANKLY IN
CALIFORNIA. TO OFFER. RESOURCES
TO THE COMMUNITY AND ONLY DO IT
IN ENGLISH I ONLY DO THE
APPLICATION IN ENGLISH BECAUSE
I KNOW I PARTICIPATED IN THE
NUMBER OF. OF WORKSHOPS IN IN
SPANISH AND SO THAT'S BEEN
REALLY GREAT AND HAS BEEN
REALLY IMPORTANT AND THAT THAT
COMES THROUGH- THE M. THE
DEPARTMENT IN A MINUTE THANK
YOU FOR DOING THOSE WORKSHOPS
IN IN ENGLISH AND SPANISH
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY IMPORTANT
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE ALSO DO IT IN SPANISH SO
IT'S NOT A QUESTION WHICH I
THINK IT'S JUST AN ISSUE THIS
IS A HOLD- OPEN ITEM- SO WE ARE
GONNA. WE ARE GONNA HOLD IT
OPEN. JANITOR AT MY KNEE YES D.
LIMITATION ON MY MIND THE
APPLICATION BEING RUSSIA'S ROLE
ON ABOUT THE BANKING SOFTWARE
AND ARE WHERE. THERE ATTACKS
MEANING WE WENT BEYOND- JUST
WEBINARS AND OUTREACH IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES ARE WE
PROVIDED SAMPLE APPLICATIONS IN
YOUR LANGUAGE SO THAT
APPLICANTS WOULD BE ABLE TO
EXPERIENCE THE APPLICATION IN
THEIR NATIVE LANGUAGE WELL FOR
HAVING. TO HAVE IT. COMPLETE I
FOR SYDNEY. SEPARATELY ON WE
ARE IN LEVERAGE TO OUR OF
PARTNERS. AND WILL PROVIDE TAX
WAS SERVICES IN LANGUAGE FOR
THIRTY DIFFERENT. AND WORKING I
SENT FOUR DIFFERENT ETHNIC
MEDIA AT IN EACH. THAT IT WILL
WIDELY KNOWN THAT THERE WAS
RESOURCE WERE. THANK YOU THAT
AND I DO A ALL OF THE I JUST. I
GUESS I'VE- HAVE A HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING WHY YOU CAN'T.
HAVE A PLATFORM IN- IN A
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR COMPLICATED. DATA
FROM THE SMALL BUSINESSES
SPECIFICALLY DID NOT RUN THE
PROGRAM LIKE THAT PPP PROGRAM
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. HE
DID AND SO- I UNDER I-UNDERSTAND IT'S BEEN SAID IT'S
HARD TO DO IT BECAUSE THEIR
BANK THEIR BANKING OR OTHER
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION. TYPE OF
FORMS BUT FRANKLY- I JUST I AM
JUST NOT COMMENCED AND- YOU
KNOW OFFLINE WE CAN HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AND YOU CAN TRY TO
CONVINCE ME THAT THESE FORMS
ARE REALLY COMPLICATED AND THAT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR INFORMATION
THAT. LEADS TO HARD TO
TRANSLATE BUT I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS A REALLY LONG TIME IN
TERMS OF- A SPANISH LANGUAGE
TRANSLATIONS- OF LEGAL
DOCUMENTS IN PARTICULAR AND
IT'S NOT JUST NOT THAT
DIFFICULT SO- I BUT I DO
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
BECAUSE I KNOW.
IRAN LONG RUN
TERM SORRY LONG TERM BUDGET
CONDITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. YES SENATOR NELSON.
MADAM CHAIR I MOVED TO COMMENT
THIS IS A SMALL ITEM. I
STIPULATE. BUT MAYBE NOT SO
SMALL I THINK A LOT OF US ARE
GETTING VERY TIRED. THE FILM
AND MOVIE BUSINESS.
PROSELYTISING AS THEY ARE AND
USING THEIR BULLY PULPIT
EXPLOITING THEIR OWN FREE
SPEECH. TO DIMINISH OR CENSOR
OTHER PEOPLE'S FREE SPEECH. IF
THEY'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO HAVE
BENEFITS IN CALIFORNIA BY
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS. IT MIGHT
BE WELL FOR THEM TO MODIFY SOME
OF THEIR SCREED. I'M GETTING A
LITTLE WORRIED ABOUT MYSELF
THAT IS JUST A POLITICAL
STATEMENT ON MY PART BUT I
BELIEVE IT IS ONE THAT SHARED
BY AN AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
NELSON- I DON'T HAVE ANY. CAN
IN REGARDS TO THIS. BUDGET ITEM
IT IS A WHOLE OPEN I SO I.
WE'RE GONNA SIT BACK AGAIN. SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
FRENCH I TAX BOARD. ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE IS THE GOAL
STATE STIMULUS TO POINT OH.
WILL TURN THE MIKE OVER TO
DEPARTMENT OF FACT- ME SEE HERE.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GOD
CALLED THE LIGHT DEPARTMENT
FINANCE I'LL BE PRESENTING ON
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU YOU SAVE
ME. BY WAY OF BACKGROUND IN A
IN MARCH THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
IN THE STATE ENACTED THE FIRST
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS. WHICH IS
EXPECTED TO PROVIDE. AT TWO
POINT EIGHT BILLION TO FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS TO HELP THEM DEAL
WITH THE ECONOMIC DISTRESS
CAUSED BY THE PANDEMIC. YES
THIS ONE PROVIDED SIX ON OUR
PAYMENTS TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS THAT QUALIFIED FOR
THE I. T. C. AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWELVE AT OUR PAYMENTS TO
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES A
QUALIFIED FOR THE I. T. C. A
SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR PAYMENTS TO
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES. MAKING
UP TO SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT DID NOT QUALIFY
FOR THE I. T. C. THE STATE'S
SECOND GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
PROPOSED HERE IS- REPRESENT.
CHANCE OF SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION
OF THE GIRLS TEXTING US AND
TARGETS LOW TO MIDDLE INCOME
INDIVIDUALS WITH AN ADDITIONAL
FOCUS ON FAMILIES IS EXPECTED
TO PROVIDE EIGHT POINT ONE
BILLION IN TAX REBATES TO
ELEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS AND OVER TWENTY ONE
MILLION INDIVIDUALS GSS TWO HAS
THREE WAYS TO QUALIFY FOR
PAYMENT ONE A SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR PAYMENT TO ALL TAX.
FILERS FILING A TWENTY TWENTY
TAX RETURN WITH ADJUSTED GROSS
INCOME OF SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR LESS WHO DID NOT
ALREADY RECEIVE A- GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS. TO A FIVE IN OUR
PAYMENT TO ALL TAXPAYERS WITH
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME OF
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR LESS WITH A DEPENDENT ON
RETURN. AND THREE AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES WITH
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME OF
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR LESS WITH THE DEPENDENT ON
THE RETURN. UNDER GSS TO
TAXPAYERS CAN QUALIFY FOR
MULTIPLE PAYMENTS SO MANY
HOUSEHOLDS WHISPER C. ONE
THOUSAND OR ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN TOTAL. THIS
PROPOSAL HAS A SECONDARY
pCONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT
UNDER STAT APPROPRIATIONS
LIMIT TO ALLOCATE EXCESS
REVENUES EQUALLY BETWEEN TAX
REBATES AND SCHOOLS TO
IMPLEMENT THE STAFF PROPOAL
THAT FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IS
REQUESTING LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES FOR ACCESS I'M SORRY
REV LIMITER RESOURCES FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO TOTALING THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION WITH FULL DETAILS
INCLUDED IN THE B. C. P. FOR
IMPLEMENTATION RELATED TO STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IT IS
REQUESTED THAT PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE BE ADDED TO S. U. THE
GENERAL FUND ITEM OF
APPROPRIATION. FOR THE MINISTRY
OF COST OF PROCESSING AND
DISPERSING THE PAYMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH CONSTANT
STIMULUS PROGRAM. THE PROPOSED
OFFICIAL LANGUAGE IS INCLUDED
IN SCO'S MAY REVISION FINANCE
LETTER. AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
PREPARED REMARKS AND I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MOVE MOVE ON TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ACTUALLY THERE WAS A DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WITHIN IT YEP.
LOOKING AT MY NOTES AND TRYING
TO ORGANIZE MYSELF SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE LA- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
CHAZ ALLEN OVER THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON OUR OFFICE RELEASED
AN ANALYSIS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED A SECOND ROUND OF
GOLDEN STATE'S STIMULUS
PAYMENTS- MUCH OF THE CONTENT
ON OUT. OF THAT ANALYSIS IS IN
YOUR AGENDA TODAY SO I'LL BE
BRIEF- THE SECOND ROUND AS
PROPOSED IN INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION IS A BROADER ROUND OF
STIMULUS PAYMENTS IN THE FIRST
ROUND. AS MR WHITE MENTIONED.
MINISTRATION ESTIMATES IN THE
SECOND ROUND WILL TOTAL EIGHT
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS. FOR
PAYMENTS FOR FAMILIES WITH
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME UP. TO
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
I THE COST OF SECOND ROW IS
SLIGHTLY MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
COST OF THE FIRST ROUND AND
THIS IS PRIMARILY BECAUSE IT
WOULD REACH A LARGER NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS BECAUSE
OF THE HIGHER. INCOME
THRESHOLD. BACK IN JANUARY WHEN
WE WERE FIRST EVALUATING THE
GOVERNOR'S FIRST RADICAL STATE
SINGLES PAYMENTS. WE NOTED THAT
ESPECIALLY RELATIVE TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THIS TIME
THE STATE'S CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
PANDEMIC RELIEF IS LIMITED. AND
SO MINDFUL THAT WE POINTED OUT
THAT I NEVER REALLY FOR THE
STATE SHOULD FIRST TARGET THOSE
MOST IN NEED. AND SECONDLY TRY
TO FILL IN GAPS WHERE FEDERAL
AID HASN'T REACHED. OUT AND
LOOKING AT THE GOVERNOR'S
SECOND GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
PROPOSAL WE KNOW THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY. OF STIMULUS PAYMENTS
WOULD GO TO HOUSEHOLDS WITH
ALREADY RECEIVED FEDERAL
CHECKS. FROM THE THREE STAGES
OF FEDERAL STIMULUS PAYMENTS-
ALTHOUGH. BOTH THE FIRST AND
SECOND ROUND. THERE ARE PURPLE
DID INCLUDE TAXES TO
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO FILE
TAXES USING AN ITEM-
COMPARATIVELY SPEAKING THESE
HOUSEHOLDS. WOULD HAVE RECEIVED
MUCH LESS IN COMBINED STATE AND
FEDERAL AID- THAN OTHER SIMILAR
HOUSEHOLDS- IN THE ANALYSIS
WE'VE PUBLISHED. I WAS SHOWN IN
FIGURE THAT OUT- HOUSE OF FOUR
WITH TWO ADULTS AND TWO
CHILDREN THAT WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
ALL FEDERAL AID WOULD RECEIVE
JUST NORTH OF TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IN FEDERAL AID AND
STATE AID- COMBINE TO DATE
WHEREAS ANOTHER Y. SIMILAR
HOUSEHOLD BUT WITH UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS WHO FILE THEIR TAXES
USING AN I. TEN I WOULD RECEIVE
JUST TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO
MINDFUL OF THIS INEQUITY IN- WE
PUT FORTH SEVERAL ALTERNATIVES
TO THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDERED
MORE ACTIVELY TARGET LIMITED
STATE FUNDS TO UNDOCUMENTED
HOUSEHOLDS WHO FILE USING AN
ITEM ON. THE TWO PROPOSALS THAT
THERE WE PUT FORTH. THE FIRST
RECALL THE EXPAND PROPOSAL
WOULD SIMPLY BE TO ADD TO THE
GOVERNORS EIGHT POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSED AMOUNT
AND USE THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO INCREASE PAYMENTS DIRECTLY
TO HEIGHTEN HOUSEHOLDS- YES
MADE BY. ADDING JUST FOR
EXAMPLE TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT
THE FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR PAYMENT
TO HEIGHTEN HOUSEHOLDS COULD BE
INCREASED TO FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EACH ITEM HELSEL.
OUR SECOND ALTERNATIVE FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATIONS WHAT
WE CALL THE RE DIRECT
ALTERNATIVE AND THIS WOULD WORK
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET AMOUNT BUT INSTEAD
REDIRECT FUNDS OR SHIFT ON- FOR
EXAMPLE. THE EXPANSION COULD BE
LIMITED TO HOUSEHOLDS WITH
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME UP TO
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS INSTEAD
OF UP TO SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THESE FUNDS COULD
BE REDIRECTED INSTEAD TO
INCREASE PAYMENTS. TO
HOUSEHOLDS- FILE USING A HIGH
TECH UNDER THIS EXAMPLE WE
THANK THE FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
PAYMENT FOR THOSE HOUSEHOLDS.
COULD BE INCREASED TO THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON JUST A
COUPLE OF. WERE- OVIOUSLY
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND- ALL THE MEMBERS
ON THE OTHER OPTION AS A
CONSIDERS THE GOVERNOR'S.
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
I'M APPRECIATE THEIR ERA. YOUR
DIFFERENT OPTIONS THERE IT'S
VERY HELPFUL. BRING THE ISSUE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. I SEE NO
NO QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR
NIELSEN- SO LET ME LET ME JUST-
ASK A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND
THE QUESTIONS ARE RELATED TO-
YOU KNOW ANYTIME WE ROLL OUT
THESE PROGRAMS IT'S IT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO EDUCATE COMMUNITY
EDUCATION BECOMES REALLY
IMPORTANT AND WE HAD A
CONVERSATION- THE LAST TIME
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT THIS THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS THE ONE
ONE POINT NO- THERE WERE THERE
WERE THERE WAS RESOURCES- THERE
WERE RESOURCES FOR- TO GET
INFORMATION OUT TO EITC.
RECIPIENTS AND SO THE QUESTION
I HAVE IS- IS WHAT WHAT ARE WE
DOING FOR EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH AND- WHAT KIND OF
MONEY IS PROPOSED FOR.
INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY NEED TO
EITHER RE FILE THEIR THEIR
TAXES OR- THAT MAY BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS MONEY AND THAT- HOW DO
WE- HOW DO WE WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO ENSURE THAT THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
MONEY CAN ACTUALLY RECEIVE IT.
I'M SO I'LL START OFF BY SAYING
THAT THE- THE- THE WAY THIS IS
GOING TO WORK IS FOR THAT TAX
FILERS HAVE ALREADY FILED A
TWENTY TWENTY TAX RETURNS SO.
THERE WILL BE NO URTHER ACTION
REQUIRED BY BY TAXPAYERS AND
PARTY FILED A TWENTY TWENTY TAX
RETURN FRANCHISE. TAX BOARD
WILL WORK WITH. THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IN ORDER
TO GET TO GET PAYMENTS OUT TO-
TAPS TO THOSE FILERS. SO IF
YOU'RE ON IF YOU'RE ASKING
ABOUT OUT REACHED OUT
SPECIFICALLY FOR LIKE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT AND THEN I
CAN TURN THAT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THAT WOULD BE FINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURKS AMIDST
PARTNER FINANCE. THE
MINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THAT
THE COUNTY THE ITC PROGRAM.
PARTICIPATION AMONG ELIGIBLE
POPULATIONS CONTINUE TO RISE.
BECAUSE THERE'S A MUCH GREATER
AWARENESS OF THE COUNTY ITC
PROGRAM AS IT ENTERS ITS SIXTH
YEAR AND BECAUSE AVAILABLE
STATISTICAL EVIDENCE INDICATES
THAT OUTREACH IS NOT A
SIGNIFICANT DRIVER
PARTICIPATION RATES. THE
ADMINISTRATION DID NOT POSE IN
THE AVERAGE FUNDING IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. A
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SO IT'S SO
THE- THE ASSISTANCE HAS BEEN-ZEROED OUT IN OTHER WORDS. THAT
IS CORRECT. SO- MATT WHAT MY
BIG CONCERN I HAVE IS THIS THAT
THE DATA THAT THAT I RECALL
RECEIVING BECAUSE I DID I DID A
BUILT. IN THIS AREA. THAT
REQUIRES IF TB DID DO A REPORT.
ON HABIT ON WHETHER THERE'S A
PROCESS THAT WE CAN UTILIZE. TO
EXPEDITE OR TO. IDENTIFY THOSE
IN THAT ARE L. FOR E. I. IT IS
THE BIGGEST POVERTY PROGRAM
THAT WE AND WE DO A IN CONTROL
WITH THE GOVERNMENT SO THE
OPERA TO GET- THAT EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT INTO THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
WORKING BUT ARE STILL POOR AND
HAVE- HAVE HAVE NEEDS THAT ARE
ARE GOING ON AND MATT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- MY BILL REQUIRES IT
F. T. B. CREATE A REPORT TO SEE
WHETHER THERE'S A WAY FOR US TO
IDENTIFY. THOSE WORKERS AND
ADVISE THEM THAT THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE AND OUT WITH THE
POTENTIAL OF NOT HAVING TO FILE
RETURN FOR IT THAT THEY
RECEIVE A LETTER ADVISING THEM
THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE IN ORDER
TO FILE A RETURN. ON THAT. WHEN
I DID THAT BILL THAT WAS IN
THERE WAS AN EIGHTY. THE DATA
SHOWED. THAT WE WERE SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
OUTREACH. AND EDUCATION AND
THAT WE WERE STILL MISSING A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF THE
ELIGIBLE WORKERS. IN OUR STATE.
AND I DON'T SEE I HAVEN'T SEEN
ANY DATA. THAT WOULD INDICATE
THAT THAT SOMEHOW THAT.
POPULATION HAS BECOME EDUCATED
NOW AND THEY DON'T NEED ANY
MORE RESOURCES SO I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT ZEROING OUT ANY
KIND OF ASSISTANCE TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS STIMULUS THE
ATC PORTION OF THE STIMULUS.
THIS IS JAMIE HARRIMAN
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD I CAN KIND
OF JUMP IN AND REGARDS TO
SENATOR CAMEO YOUR REPORT
REQUIRED UNDER SENATE BILL
FORTY NINE NINETY. WE ARE
CERTAINLY WORKING ON NOT IT IS
TO THE LEGISLATURE- TOWARDS THE
END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR AND
WE WILL CERTAINLY- LOOK FORWARD
TO DISCUSSIONS IN REGARDS TO
THAT. I WOULD SAY THERE IS-
INCONSISTENT DATA THAT EXISTS
IN REGARDS TO WHETHER THERE IS
A CAP AND WHAT THAT GOT LOOKS
LIKE- FOR PURPOSES OF OUTREACH-
MISTER WHITE IS CORRECT THAT
INDIVIDUALS FOR THE MOST PART
HAVE FILED THEIR RETURNS ARE
READY. THAT ARE GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE JEEP. THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS TO. SO
THAT THERE REALLY NO FURTHER
ACTION NECESSARY ON THEIR PART.
HOWEVER THERE ARE FOLKS THAT
FILE LATE. AT NIGHT AND THERE
ARE CERTAINLY FOLKS THAT
TYPICALLY DON'T HAVE A FILING
REQUIREMENT AND MAY BE
INTERESTED IN NOW FILING
BECAUSE OF THE GOLDEN STATE
STREET MILLER SO. THE GRANT
FUNDS OF FIVE BILLION THAT WERE
AUTHORIZED IN FEBRUARY OF THIS
YEAR FROM THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS ONE. THERE IS- MOST
LIKELY SOME LEFT AND THEN THERE
AND THAT AMOUNT WILL BE CARRIED
OVER INTO THE FIRST PART OF
THIS COMING UP THIS SCHOOL YEAR.
SO THAT THE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS CAN IN FACT
CONTINUES SOME EDUCATION
OUTREACH- WITH THOSE PRIOR
FUNDS THAT WERE ESTABLISHED BUT
THIS YEAR BUT WILL BE SUBJECT
TO RE APPROPRIATION. FOR NEXT
YEAR. THE HELP CENTER THE
QUESTION- IT IT MAY I
UNDERSTOOD THAT THERE WERE SOME
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAD NOT-
TOTALLY EXPANDED THE RESOURCES
THAT. THEY RECEIVED IN IN
REGARDS TO HELPING. IN THIS
AREA AND THAT THEY IT WHAT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR AND IT IS AN
EXTENSION TO BE ABLE TO-
CONTINUE TO OFFER HELP AND
ASSISTANCE AND SO. IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS
OF HAVING THE RESOURCES- YES
AVAILABLE EXACTLY SO OKAY
APARTMENT EFFECT HAS BEEN- A
GOOD PARTNER WITH US TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WAS.
INCORPORATED INTO PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE WITHIN OUR BUDGET THAT
WILL ALLOW PORTIONS OF THAT
FIVE MILLION AGAIN GRANTED IN
FEBRUARY THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
EXPENDED AS OF JUNE THIRTIETH
TWO CAN BE SUBJECT TO-
EXPENDITURE AND- THAT. THE
FIRST PART OF TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. OKAY THAT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK AND
THEN AND THEN- THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE I. TEN
HOLDERS AND THOSE THAT DO NOT%
HAVE AN I. TEN- AND- THAT- SO
THE CONCERN I HAVE IS OUTREACH
AND COMMUNICATION TO THE NON I.
TEN- GRANTEES IS THERE A
PROCESS THEY'RE USING OR AM I
AGAIN I'M EXPECTING THAT
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE ANY
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH. THAT
THAT HAPPENS BECAUSE THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE BUDGET IS THERE
YEAH HOW IS IT THAT YOU INTEND
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ANY ANY RELIEF
PROGRAM NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER
TWO IS THERE THE MOST
DESPERATELY IN NEED OF HELP
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO ACCESS ANY RESOURCES. YES A
GOOD QUESTION SO I CAN KIND OF-
START THAT CONVERSATION AND
OTHER FOLKS CAN STOP AND- SHOW-
THE NONPROFITS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE
WORKING WITH ARE WELL AWARE OF
THIS GROUP AND ARE CERTAINLY
MAKING EFFORTS TO REACH OUT TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS- SO THAT THEY
CAN GET THE PROCESS GOING WITH
THE- WITH THE IRS. INTERNAL
REVENUE SERVICE TO ACTUALLY
RECEIVE AN I. TEN- OUR
INFORMATION CURRENTLY SUGGESTS
THAT WHEN SHE APPLIED FOR AN I.
TEN IT COULD TAKE ANYWHERE FROM
SEVEN TO ELEVEN WEEKS. AT THIS
TIME OF THE YEAR TO GET ONE SO-
OUR PHONE LINES ARE WEBSITES-
OUR COMMUNITY BASED PARTNERS
ARE ALL AWARE OF THIS TIME
FRAME AND ARE WORKING TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THESE UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS THAT MAY BE FINDING OUT
ABOUT THE GOLDEN STATE STREET
RELEASED FOR THE FIRST TIME-
WHETHER ONE OR THE FIRST OR THE
SECOND- PROPOSAL. CAN ACTUALLY
GET THAT RIGHT TEN IT IS
REQUIRED BY STATUTE-
PARTICULARLY FOR GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS ONE. THAT AN ACTION IS
NECESSARY- BOTH CLAIM THE
CALIFORNIA E. H. U. G. AND TO
GET THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
SO- WE HAVEN'T SEEN LANGUAGE
YET FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS PACKAGE TO BUT- AGAIN.
CONVERSATIONS HAVE SEEMINGLY
BECAUSE THAT AN ITEM ISN'T
NECESSARY SO WE'RE MAKING EVERY
ATTEMPT TO MAKE SURE TAXPAYERS
THAT CONTACT US AND OUR
PARTNERS IN THE COMMUNITY. KNOW
HOW TO GET AN I. TEN WHERE TO
GO WHAT DOCUMENTS DO YOU NEED
TO GET IT AND TO GET THAT IN
THE WORKS. SO THAT THEY CAN GET
THAT . TENDON AND FILE A
RETURN TICKET- GENERATE THIS
PAYMENT AT THIS TIME. VERY GOOD
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR- YOUR INFORMATION IT'S
BEEN VERY HELPFUL I JUST- I.
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THAT AGAIN
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEMS WILL
BE SAYING THIS AGAIN IN THE
FUTURE. BUT- THERE'S A- COOL A
PROGRAM ONLY SIX AS THE OUT
REACH AN AGE. IS PRETTY.
BECAUSE TO REACH POP. AND I
THERE'S GOING TO BE A NEED FOR
IT THE COMMUNITY BASED PARTNERS
TO HAVE SOME RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO. CONTINUE TO DO THE
GOOD WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING
SO- ONE I I'M- MY URGE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER. AS
PART OF THIS- TRAILER BILL THAT
THAT IT INCLUDES SOME RESOURCES
FOR. FOR THE PARTNERS AS WELL
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR US
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT IF
WE'RE DOING A STIMULUS THAT IT
GOES OUT TO THE COMMUNITY THAT
IT IS A DESIGN TO BENEFIT. SO
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
APPRECIATE THAT HERE TODAY.
THIS IS A- HOLD OPEN ITEM THREE
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX. WHICH IS THE
HOMELESS HIRING TAX CREDIT. AND
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE LA
O'S OFFICE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS BRAND WHETHER
FORD WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AND- D. ON
THIS ITEM IS A PART OF THE
SENATE DEMOCRATS BUDGET PLAN OR
AT LEAST IT'S UNDER
CONSIDERATION AS PART OF THE
PLAN FOR A PROPOSAL FOR A
HOMELESS HIRING TAX CREDIT.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW
EMPLOYERS THAT HIRE ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS AND MEET CERTAIN
SPECIFIED CONDITIONS TO CLAIM A
CREDIT THAT COULD BE USED TO
REDUCE THEIR STATE PERSONAL
INCOME AND- CORPORATION TAXES.
AS STATED IN THE AGENDA THE-
THE OBJECTIVE OF THIS PROPOSAL
IS TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING OF
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING INCENTIVES. TO
BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
THE CREDIT WOULD BE CAPPED AT
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR. OUR OFFICE IS LIMITED IN
OUR ABILITY TO COMMENT ON THIS
PROPOSAL BUT WE'D BE HAPPY TO
CLEAR UP ANY FACTUAL DETAILS OF
THE PROPOSAL. TO THE BEST OF
OUR ABILITY AND I UNDERSTAND IT
MAY BE ANOTHER PANELIST WHO CAN
SPEAK TO- SOME THE POLICY
MERITS. VERY GOOD I UNDERSTAND
THAT- BOB LANTER THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION IS HERE.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME AND SEE-
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE VERY
YOU'RE THE VOICE IS VERY LOW IF
YOU COULD. KIND OF TURN IT UP A
LITTLE BIT THAT WOULD BE
TERRIFIC. WHEN I TRY THAT AGAIN.
HOW'S THAT CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
MUCH BETTER THANK YOU. OKAY ALL
RIGHT GREAT. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR CABALLERO AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BOB LANTER
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION A NONPROFIT
ASSOCIATION MADE UP OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS I THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME TO GET SOME
BACKGROUND TODAY ON THE
HOMELESS HIRING TAX CREDIT.
THAT WAS STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AS A WAY TO
HELP THE STATE ADDRESS THE
GROWING HOMELESS CRISIS TODAY
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU SOME
BACKGROUND ON HOW THIS TAX
CREDIT WILL SERVE AS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR THE
WORKFORCE SYSTEM. HOW IT WILL
HELP THE STATE AS IT LOOKS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND HOW
THIS CAN BE A HELPFUL ECONOMIC
DRIVER FOR BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. AT THE HEART OF
THIS TAX CREDIT FOR THE
WORKFORCE BOARDS TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
CONTINUANCE OF CARE THAT WORKED
CLOSELY WITH HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS TO HELP THEM GET
THE ASSISTANCE THEY DESPERATELY
NEED. THE GOALS OF THIS
PROPOSAL ARE NOT JUST PROVIDE
AN INDIVIDUAL WITH THE JOB BUT
TO INCLUDE THIS IS ANOTHER
USEFUL TOOL THAT CAN BE USED
WHEN HELPING THESE INDIVIDUALS
FIND HOUSING JOB TRAINING FOOD
ASSISTANCE AND THE MANY OTHER
WAYS. THAT THESE CONTINUANCE OF
CARE CAN HELP. CALIFORNIA'S
FORTY FIVE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS. UP AND DOWN
THE STATE WILL BE AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT OF THIS PROCESS.
SERVING AS A LINK BETWEEN
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES. THEIR
BUSINESS SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVES ALREADY HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS AND A KNOWLEDGE
OF MAIN STREET LABOR MARKET
DATA. AND CAN HELP BUSINESSES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
CONNECT TO THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THE CASE MANAERS WILL SUPPORT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS BEING HIRED
WITH THEIR CENTRAL SUPPORTS AND
HOUSING AGENCIES ARE HEALTH
CARE SITES AS NEEDED. THE
CULTURAL COMPETENCIES WITHIN
THESE LOCAL BOARD STAFF FOR
ESSENTIAL TO SUPPORTING. BOTH
THE EMPLOYER AND THE EMPLOYEE
AND ENSURING THAT THE RETENTION
AND LONG TERM SUCCESS CAN COME
FROM HIRING THROUGH THIS TAX
CREDIT. THE HOMELESS HIRING TAX
CREDIT SERVICES A TOOL TO HELP
SOLVE THE STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS BY MATCHING HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. WITH JOBS THAT
MUST PAY FAMILY SUPPORTING
WAGES AT OR EXCEEDING THE
JURISDICTIONS PREVAILING WAGE
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR THE TAX
CREDIT. AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
WE'RE NOT JUST LOOKING TO HIRE
FOR HIRING SAKE. BUT TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT AND
INCENTIVIZE IT AND INCENTIVIZE
EMPLOYERS. TO HIRE THESE
INDIVIDUALS FOR A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME. IN ORDER TO TAKE FULL
ADVANTAGE OF THE CREDIT. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS WOULD NOT
BE A STANDALONE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS AND THAT THERE IS A
HIGHER SUCCESS RATE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PAID.
HIGHER WAGES AND ARE EMPLOYED
FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME.
AND CAN COUPLE THIS EMPLOYMENT
WITH OTHER ASSISTANCE THROUGH
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE. THE
PARAMETERS INCLUDED IN THIS
PROPOSAL REGARDING HIRING ARE
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY TO
INCREASE THE ODDS OF SUCCESS.
AND ALLOW THESE INDIVIDUALS TO
GET BACK ON THEIR FEET AND MOVE.
OFF OF THEIR STATE PROGRAMS.
ALL RIGHT NOW IS SHOWS FOR
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS SPENT THE
STATE WOULD SAVE ROUGHLY THIRTY
ONE MILLION ON CAL WORKS IN
MEDICARE. BY HELPING THREE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THE
SAVINGS IS NOT ONLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
TERMS OF HOW IT WORKS IN
MEDICARE. BUT IT CAN BE AND
THEN MENTALLY IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC DRIVER FOR THE
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA AS
THEY LOOK TO RE OPEN THEIR
DOORS AND REHIRE EMPLOYEES. AS
YOU ARE AWARE PARTICULARLY
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN HIT
HARD RECENTLY AND A POTENTIAL
TEN THOUSAND TAX CREDIT PER.
INDIVIDUAL HIRED COULD MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEIR
ABILITY TO RE OPEN AND STAY
OPEN AND THE UNFORTUNATE
OUTCOME THAT WOULD SEE THEM
CLOSE THEIR DOORS PERMANENTLY.
IN CLOSING. CALIFORNIA HAS
SPENT OVER THIRTEEN BILLION ON
ALMOST THIS OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS. AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING ANOTHER TWELVE
BILLION AND HAS MADE REVISED TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. FOR YOU
TODAY IS A PROPOSED SOLUTION
THAT CAN HELP DISPONIBLE
POPULATION. WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
COST FOR THE STATE. AS WELL AS
HELP BUSINESSES RECOVER AND
HELP THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
SURGED BACK TO WHERE IT WAS
PRETTY BAD DAMAGE. WE ASK THAT
YOU VOTE TO INCLUDE THIS IN THE
PROPOSAL IN THE BUDGET AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME THIS. AFTERNOON HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I'M GOING TO ASK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF
THEY'D LIKE TO WEIGH IN ON THIS
ONE. THANK YOU- I'M SURE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THIS
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME-
WE SUPPORT A TWELVE BILLION
DOLLAR PLAN OUTLINED IN THE MAY
REVISION TO TACKLE THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO USE THE STATE'S HISTORIC
REVENUE SURGED TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
I'M GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE-
THE COMMITTEE SEE IF THERE'S
ANY COMMENTS OR CONCERNS ABOUT.
THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET I DON'T.
SEEING NONE I AM. I THINK THIS
IS BUT THERE'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO CONNECT
THIS TO THE HOMELESS SERVICES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FUNDING- SEEMS TO ME THAT
HAVING A JOB IS ONE REALLY
IMPORTANT STEPBUT IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE IT BECOMES
REALLY HARD TO KEEP THAT JOB-
WHICH IS JUST I DON'T SEE HOW
ANYBODY CAN. CAN WORK AND LIVE
OUT OF THE CAR LIVE LIVE ON. ON
THE STREET SO CONNECTING IT TO
THE HOMELESS SERVICES ARM THE
OTHER THING IS THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK THAT WE CAN- WE
CAN DO THIS AS A- AS A PILOT
PROJECT TO SEE IF IT. IF IT. IF
IT DOES AT THE COMPLEX THE
GOALS THAT WE ARE SEEKING TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS IS. REDUCE THE
COST TO THE- IN IN OUR SERVICE
PROGRAMS THE MORE THE PEOPLE
ARE INDEPENDENT AND CAN WORK.
THE LESS THEY HAVE TO RELY ON
SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAMS- AND-
AND SEE IT AS AN ECONOMIC
DRIVER IN OUR COMMUNITIES AS
WELL O. AM I LIKE THIS
PROPOSAL THIS IS A HOLD OPEN
ITEMS SO WE'RE GONNA HOLD IT
OPEN IF THERE ARE NO OTHER
COMMENTS- AND- WELL I'M SURE
WE'LL SEE THIS BACK AGAIN SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY. SO NOW-
THE MOMENT YOU'VE ALL BEEN
WAITING FOR WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO. THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF OUR HEARING. THIS IS
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT. TO ON ANY OF THE ITEMS
THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED TODAY. SO
AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT ONE EIGHT. TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN. SO DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS AND THE
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
OUR CLEANING PROTOCOLS. THE I.
ME AS THE CHAIR I IS THE
CHAIRMAN INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY. TODAY I'M AN
ASSET EACH MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
PROVIDING COMMENT KEEP THE
REMARKS TO WITHIN A MINUTE. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WIH ANY
WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. LIKE TO INVITE
YOU TO COME TO THE MIKE AND IF
YOU COULD STATE YOUR NAME FOR
THE RECORD. WE CAN START. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO. WE WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE PROPOSAL TO DEDICATE
TURNER FIFTY MILLION OF THE
FEDERAL COVETED RELIEF FUNDS TO
CALIFORNIA PORTS- HUGE. IMPACT
POOR LIKE MINE OF SAN DIEGO
FROM CO THAT TO. WE SUPPORT
THIS- THIS IS PROPOSED TO BE
MINISTER BY GO BIZ. AND I'M
HERE TO TALK TODAY BECAUSE WE
WEREN'T QUITE SURE WHERE THIS
IS GOING TO POP UP IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS SO WE
THOUGHT WE'D DO EXPRESS A TODAY
AND- GO FROM THERE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU. SHOWING UP HERE
TODAY ONE NEVER KNOWS WHAT'S
GOING TO POP UP SO I DO
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THIS ROOM WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE THERE WHO- I AM IT IS AS
USUAL- SO WE'RE NOW READY TO
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES THAT ARE
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR BEST. SO MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE CAN BEGIN.
BEN LADEN JUMPING ON THE PHONE
LINE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO RIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME TO JOIN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO
TO JOIN THE QUEUE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS. ENSURE THIS
TIME JUST YOU'RE AWARE WE DO
HAVE NINETEEN IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT'S A
GOOD NUMBER SO- WHY DON'T WE GO
AHEAD AND START TO OPEN THE
LINES UP AND CALL ON MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC INDIVIDUALLY.
ABSOLUTELY WE WILL START WITH
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SENATOR COVER EURO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
NICHOLA- TO LOOK AT I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
OAKLAND BERKELEY SAN LEANDRO
SANTANA HEY WORD IT WAS THE
BEST PHONE FREMONT WE ARE SO
EXCITED TO SEE THE VARIOUS
PROPOSALS RELATING TO
HOMELESSNESS. FROM THE SENATE
FROM THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
GOVERNOR WE REALLY WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE AND
APPRECIATION. OF ALL THE CITIES
MENTIONED SUPPORT DIRECT
ALLOCATIONS OF FLEXIBLE FUNDING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS UNDER THE
EXISTING HAPPY PROGRAMMING AND
GUIDELINES AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
FLEXIBILITY IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE FOCUS IT NEEDS AN
OAKLAND VERY FROM THE FOCUS AND
YOU DIDN'T SING LEANDRO. YET
THE NEED FOR FLEXIBILITY IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT SO WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL WELL WE'RE THANKFUL WE
SHOULD SUPPORT THE HAP PROGRAM
AND OF COURSE WE CERTAINLY
EMBRACE ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIREMENTS APPROPRIATE FOR
SUCH A LARGE BUDGETARY
COMMITMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. J. U. TESTIMONY YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING CHAIRMAN LEWIS
ELIZABETH COHEN AND I AM A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH- FROM
VENTURA CALIFORNIA- I
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS-
SEVERAL OCCASIONS SINCE EXITING
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM BOOK ON
MY OWN AND LISTENING TO YOUNG
CHILDREN. I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME WHICH INCLUDES A 10%
SATISFIED TO SHARE ANY COMPANY
TO HOMELESS YOUTH I'D ALSO LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THREE
ITEMS IN THE REVISED. THAT
EIGHT MILLION FOR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM AND THE FIVE
MILLION FOR HOUSING NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE PROPOSAL
TO INCLUDE ANY KIND OF FIGHT
AND HOCKEY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE.
WELL NO GOOD WILL NOW GO TO
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT NEXT SATURDAY HE
NOMINATED LISTENABLE GUY YOUNG
YES CLICK ON THE ENTACLES. ARE
LOOKING ABOUT HOW VOTERS OF
AMERICA. PART OF THE NETWORK
THANK YOU THAT WAY I WAS
CALLING FOR ANOTHER VIDEO
APPEARANCE YEAH WELL NOT REALLY
THIS IS WHAT HE DOES THEY ARE
PART OF THE OLYMPICS BUT AFGHAN
PEOPLE. BELIEVE THAT MAY LEAVE
YOUR CREDIT OUT OF KENTUCKY BUT
MOST COMPANIES ARE NOT MEANT
THAT BETWEEN WHAT WE LIKE
YOU'RE NOT IMPRACTICAL IDEA BUT
I'M STILL LOOKING FOR ME AND-
IT. MEANT THAT I'VE BEEN
LOOKING UP IN IT WANT HIM. KNOW
WHAT YOU ARE- I FOUND IT ON THE
PHONE I DON'T. WANT A MONTH
AFTER IT LOOKED AT ME AND-
MEDIACORP. YOU ALL MUST COME.
YOU ALMOST PART OF THE LOCAL
MUSIC. RECORD MINUTES THEM ALL.
WELL HE LOOKED FOR A- START ALL
THE VALLEY. DID NOT YET KEEP
THAT THE MOMENT. THAT THE-
WOULD. YES AND HER. WITH ABOUT
THE STIMULUS. A BRAND DOCUMENT
WORKERS THE NEXT. NEXT TO THE
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JENNIFER
FEARING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION BEYOND ABOVE THE
OPEN MEDIUM OAKLAND DO
DISCOVERY SCIENCE CENTER AND
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES BUT ALONG WITH MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED STATE AND%
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS BUSINESSES
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEADERS
CONTINUE TO RECLAIM THE BILLION
DOLLARS TO BE SPENT OVER FOUR
YEARS TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
ARTS CULTURE AND CREATIVITY
FACTOR. WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT OF THE QUESTION
THAT YOU HAD LAST WEEK LIKE WHY
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO SENATOR ALAN
AND RADIO AND A FAMILY MEMBER'S
FREEDMAN QUICKSILVER. THE
CHANTING THIS INVESTMENT WHICH
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL ENDOWMENT TO FUND
PROJECT THAT LOOKED UP UNDER
REPRESENTED STORIES IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. THE FINANCE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU TO CONTINUE
YOUR WORK TO INCLUDE A BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO HELP
INSURE ARE DEEPLY IMPACTED
SECTOR RECOVERS EVEN
CALIFORNIANS CONNECTIONS ARE
HISTORICAL CULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE NEXT IS
NUMBER. SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CLOSED WITH STRATEGY IN
FACT THE YOU HAVE OF THE
NATIONAL AND THEN THE THIRD THE
CALIFORNIA- I JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE CALIFORNIA.
THAT THE NUMBER ONE I HOPE ONE
OURS ADVOCATE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- YOUR ATTENTION FOR THE
CRITICALLY NEEDED THAT WE OR
OUR CULTURE HM INSPECTOR OF
THAT ONE BILLION. NATIONAL AND-
YOU CAN SHOW THEM NOT DOLLARS
GRANT IF MEDICARE BY DEBIT BUT
HOW. AND THEN. GLOBAL DEMAND
PROFIT. THROUGHOUT THE THAT
HAVE BEEN SHATTERED FORTY
MONTHS ABOUT THAT AND ALL OTHER-
D. BATTLE PROGRAM WE WERE
HOPING YOU WOULD BRING RELIEF
TO OUR SECTOR HAS YET TO. GO
BALL OUT I BET CRITICAL RELIEF
IS NEEDED NOW MORE THAN EVER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
POSITIVE DISCUSSION WHAT YOU
CAN ALSO CHOOSE SENATOR ALLEN-
MOVIE OUT AND IF THE NUMBERS
THREE FOURTHS OF ALL. VERY
IMPORTANT THEIR CHANCE OF THAT
HAPPENING STRONGLY URGES THE
QUESTION- IN. CONSIDERATION OF
THE TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK NECK PLEASE. NEXUS FOR
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. REMEMBER
IF POSSIBLE GET OFF ON BEHALF
OF THE COMPANY ARE ADVOCATED
LIKE TO COMMEND THE STEPS TAKEN
BY GOVERNOR NATHAN HIS NAME
REVISION AND WE SUPPORT OF THE
VARIANTS. ARE RELATED
INVESTMENTS MADE IN THE COLD
WELL BUT TODAY WE'RE ASKING THE
COMMITTEE TO GO FURTHER INTO
QUITE A LOT IN THAT BUDGET
REQUEST OF ONE BILLION OVER THE
NEXT THREE TO FOUR YEARS BUT
THEY'RE COVERING THE ARTS
CULTURE AND LIVE EVENT
INDUSTRIES ALTHOUGH WITH THE
SUPPORT OF OUR PARTNERS YOU'VE
REACHED CRITICALLY HURT- WHAT
WAS THAT THE CRITICAL
INVESTMENT IN HUMAN CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE INDUSTRY
THE DIFFICULTY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION VERSUS THE GOVERNORS
ONE HUNDRED MILLION TO HELP THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
TRIPLED THE PROGRAM'S REACH
INTO EVERY COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA INCREASED INVESTMENT
AND I WAS A BIT OF EXPANDING
YOUR POLLUTION THE IMPACT THAT
EIGHTY FIVE ON OUR SECTOR AND
EXPAND AND BANNED THE COCOA
DISTRICT PROGRAMS INCREASE YOU
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
THE CREATIVE INDUSTRY EQUITABLE
QUICKLIME OR NEW JOB AND HE
ACTS OF ART WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT DISCUSSIONS BE HELD
LAST WEEK WE ARE PLEASED THAT
OUR LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP
CHAMPION FOR THE ONE BILLION
INVESTMENT APPS INCLUDE UNDER
AN HOUR AND- THEN THE NUMBER
AND YOU CAN RUBIO AND PHONE
NUMBER. OF OUR FREEMEN. ENGINE
BUT STILL ALL THE PROGRAMS
COULD BE AND- BY SPEED A
STEPHEN BE BASED ON THE CONTENT
MULTI GRANT PROGRAM WITH THE
PRIOR. TOWARD COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN. UNDER REACHED. SUCH
AS WELL AND YOU NEED THE COLOR
THANK YOU. YOU CAN COULD
SUPPORT THE ONES AND- IN THEIR
COPY THE ARTS AND CULTURE AND
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. CEMEX IS NUMBER
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STAYED
CALMLY WITH THE LA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS SPEAKING ON
ISSUE TWENTY SIX THE HOMELESS
HIRING TAX CREDIT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH SENATOR
DIROCCO INVOLVED THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION TO
ADVANCE SUCH POLICY WE BELIEVE
IT'S COMPANION BUDGET AFTER THE
FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING CONTINUED
TO RESPOND TO THE ECONOMIC
EFFECTS OF THE NINETEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT IS FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ALEX KASPER HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WITH SOME COMMENTS ON
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN THE
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS- WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE BOOK THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
ARE COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS AND GLAD
TO SEE THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
ARTICULATED A VISION FOR ENDING
FAMILY HOME THE HOMELESSNESS IN
FIVE YEARS. HOWEVER WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT THE
PROPOSAL FAILED TO INCLUDE
FUNDING DIRECTLY. TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOUSING SERVICES. 57%
OF WOMEN REPORT THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WAS THE IMMEDIATE
CAUSE OF THEIR HOMEWORK THEN.
AND ON ANY GIVEN DAY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SHELTERS AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING UNITS
SERVE MORE CHILDREN THAN ADULTS.
FIBER OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OFTEN EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
AND ENTER SHELTER WITH MULTIPLE
CHILDREN. WE SIMPLY CANNOT END
HOMELESSNESS WITHOUT ALSO
ADDRESSING THAT INEXTRICABLY
LINKED ISSUE WE URGE YOU TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICES
WITHIN THE HOME WHAT THAT
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE
WITH URBAN COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL STATE
HOMELESSNESS INVESTMENTS I GOT
TODAY WE PREVIOUSLY SUBMITTED A
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE
INDICATING WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
ADDITIONAL ACQUISITION PROGRAMS
LIKE PROJECT HOME SHE WITH
APPROPRIATE CAPITALISATION OF
OPERATING COSTS. HE ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED OUR ONGOING SUPPORT
FOR ADDITIONAL FLEXIBLE
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING FOR COUNTY
TO BUILD A HOUSE BAND AND
ADDRESS EACH STEP IN THE
CONTINUUM IN EXPENSE DISCUSSED
TODAY COMBINED WITH ELEMENTS OF
THE SENATE'S PLAN AND OTHER
PROPOSALS BEING CONTEMPLATED
AND SOCIAL SERVICES AND
HEALTHCARE SERVICES ARE
CONSISTENT WITH COUNTIES
PRIORITY. WE KNOW THERE ARE
STILL MANY CONVERSATIONS TO
HAVE RELATIVE TO A FINAL
HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE AND ARE
READY TO ENGAGE FURTHER AT THIS.
THE TOP PRIORITY FOR COUNTIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. TEXAS SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS TWO WEEKS
LATER WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE I SPEAKING ON THE
HELP WITH THIS PACKAGE WE ARE A
MEMBER OF THE BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME COALITION OF MAYORS MENTAL
HEALTH ADVOCATES HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS AND NUMEROUS
OTHERS. ON TOP OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR VARIOUS
PROGRAMS WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THE SENATE BRING BACK BOLDLY
PROPOSAL FOR SUBSTANTIAL MULTI
YEAR INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. SH IN THAT
CONTEXT WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO APPROPRIATE AT LEAST TWO
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR FIVE
YEARS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SHE'S USING THE PROGRAMMATIC
FRAMEWORK IN THE BRAIN
CALIFORNIA HOME ACT OR. EIGHTY
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
INDUSTRY CLASS. THIS SPRING
WORKING VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING
THE COMMITTEE HAS TALKED ABOUT
TODAY IT INCORPORATES SENATOR
COM LOCKERS EQUITY REQUIREMENTS
AS WELL AS INCREASING ACCESS
FOR THE FAMILY SHE DESCRIBED.
IT INCLUDES A ROBUST
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS THAT
SENATOR NELSON FIRST WAVE AND
THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ECHOED. AND FINALLY IT PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY TO LOCALITIES WHILE
FOCUSING PRIMARILY ON THE
PERMANENT SOLUTIONS THAT WE
KNOW ARE ESSENTIAL TO END
HOMELESSNESS. COALITION WILL BE
SHARING SUGGESTED- TBL CAN USE
THIS FRAMEWORK WITH YOUR STAFF
SHORTLY AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. X. PLEASE. NEXT
IS SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT'S
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION WE
APPLAUD THE SUBSTANTIAL FUNDING
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED
TO DEAL WITH HOMELESSNESS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE TWO CONCERNS
FIRST IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION INTENDS TO FULLY
PUSH OUT RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDS BEFORE TE EVICTION CLIP.
LOOMS AT MIDNIGHT ON JUNE
THIRTIETH I'M AS WE UNDERSTAND
IT FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION HAVE BEEN OBLIGATED SO
FAR- WHICH WE BELIEVE IS JUST A
SLIVER OF WHAT THE NEED IS
GOING TO BE FOR THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS- IT MIGHT BE NECESSARY
TO ADOPT TRAILER LANGUAGE THAT
PROVIDES A SOFT LANDING FOR
RENTERS THAT DON'T GET RELIEF
IN TIME. SECOND UNDER CURRENT
LAW IF A NONPROFIT DEVELOPER
USES PUBLIC FUNDS TO DEVELOP
LOW INCOME HOUSING THEY GET UP
TO A 100% PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION HOWEVER NONPROFIT
THAT USES NO PUBLIC FUNDS
RECEIVE THE VERY LIMITE EXAM
EXEMPTION WE SHOULD BE
INCENTIVIZING NONPROFITS THAT
DO NOT USE PUBLIC FUNDS TO HELP
HELP THE STATE MEET OUR HOUSING
NEEDS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT IS NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
HONOURABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN
HINDSIGHT OKAY CONSULTING
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
HIGH LEVEL THAT WOULD PREVENT
IT TODAY TO GET INTO THE
DETAILS WE GREATLY APPRECIATE.
THE HELP THANK YOU PACKAGE THE
FIRST QUESTION ABOUT TARGET IN
ORDER FOR INTERVENTION HELPING.
AROUND WITH SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION OVER HERE
AT- WHAT OF THE ATTENDANTS I
WANT YOU GUYS OF THE- AND THE
SECOND QUESTION ADVANCE
DISPLACEMENT AND HOW. AS A
COMMUNITY ARE- OUR BRAND- THE
DOLLAR CHAMPIONS BY WE
COMPARABLE- YOU REALLY HAVE AND-
HAVE NOTED MULTIPLE TIMES
THROUGHOUT THE DAY- EVERYONE
INCLUDED AND THE THIRD ONE WHAT
I'LL BE HEARING AND- THROUGHOUT
THESE ISSUE AREAS- EQUITY AS
FAR AS RACIAL AND GENDER EQUITY
BUT ALSO GEOGRAPHICAL- EQUITY
FOR URBAN CENTERS ACROSS WELL
AS WELL. AND WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT IS SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAN A LAWYERREPRESENTING- THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND JUST WANT TO SAY THAT YOU
KNOW WE REALLY HOPE THAT THEIR
DETENTION TO YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND I
GOT MARRIED BY DAY AND WE
APPRECIATE THE CALL OUT- AND
PROJECT ROOM HERE FOR YEARS BUT
WERE READING FOR THE DETAILS
UCH FORGETTING THAT. I MEAN
MINISTRATION AND WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN HEARD THE COMMITTEE TO
ALLOW THAT NONPROFIT BUT THOSE
WHO ARE DIRECTLY ABLE TO APPLY
FOR THE FUNDING BUT THERE ARE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE STRUCTURE
WE BELIEVE IS OUTLINED IN THE
REPORT ACT. WE REALLY LIKE TO
GET SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
HOME OF THE PARENTS OF THE ONE
I'M SURE THAT ANY DOLLARS FOR
SERVICES CONTINUE TO FIND A
SIDE. FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXUS FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS-
AND MANNING ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS AND I'M FINE ON
ITEM SEVENTEEN- FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION OR EGP GRANT FUNDING.
PROGRAM OR OR WE DON'T PLANNING
AND- SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
TRAGEDIES- THIS CALL WILL
CONTAIN IT- AS WE READ IT IN
THE P. C. P. AND IN THE BUDGET
SUMMARY BEGINNING THE
ALTERNATIVE THE NEED. TO FIND
INFRASTRUCTURES GO UNDER
UTILIZED PROPERTIES CAN BE
BETTER UTILIZED FOR HOUSING-
IT'S AN ISSUE SENATOR KABIRU
BUT I KNOW IT'S NEAR AND DEAR
TO YOUR HEART. AND YOUR DATE ON
THE UNIT. THE COUNCIL AND A BIG
ISSUE FOR NIELSEN WELL- THE
REASON THIS IS SO MUCH INTEREST
THANK GOD IS- WERE THE FIRST
REGION THAT 19% GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION TARGES ARE. AND HAVE.
A RENOWNED NUMBER FOR THIS
CYCLE. YEAH OUR NUMBER IS THE
ONLY NUMBER AND SAY THE
CONDITIONS ON OUR ABILITY TO
ACCESS FUNDING FOR.
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HOUSING-
THERE'S A HUGE DISPARITY RIGHT
NOW IN THE BUILDING THANK YOU-
CONFLICT THEY- THE ON THE- IT
WILL INFRASTRUCTURE- COMPARED
TO THE COLD FLURRIES WITH YOUR
PART DENSER AND THE CONSOLE
GAMES ARE REALLY BIASED FOR THE
LAST DOLLAR IN AN EARLY DOLLARS.
IN FOOD AND WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE TO OPEN UP HE'S.
UNDER UTILIZED OUTGOING. AND-
IN ORDER TO GET TO THIS. THING
OUT PRODUCTION NUMBER MEETS
ARENA TOLD. ME THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR AND
WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS- WE HAVE
ADOPTED- OR REGION ALL THE
CITIES IN THE COUNTY. I HAVE A
DAUGHTER- THE GREEN MEANS. GO
PROGRAM IDENTIFIED BY. THAT ARE
READY TO GO. AND ALL WE NEED IS
WATER AND SEWAGE INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES DO IT- YOU KNOW WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. ABOUT
THE NEED FOR PRECISE LANGUAGE
CHANNEL WE THINK THIS PROGRAM-
REALLY NEEDS TO GET THE MONEY
OUT THE DOOR WE'VE DONE A LOT
OF THE SITES. WE'RE READY TO
BUILD AND WE NEED THE FUNDING
NOW. AND SO THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO DO MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED BILLION FOR
THE STATE AND- AS MUCH AS A
BILLION WEEPINGAND CERTAINLY.
THANK GOD HE IS READY TO GO AND
NEED A HUNDRED MILLION OUT
DOORS SO WE APPRECIATE IT. VERY
MUCH OR OR YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YES YES WE HAVE A
QUESTION FROM SENATOR NELSON
NOW TO VERIFY MAY TYPE IN HERE
JUST BRIEFLY UP WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS A LONG A LITTLE WHILE AGO
AND NOW WE'VE HAD THE PUBLIC
COMMENT I'M QUITE FAMILIAR WITH
THE ESSAY COG EFFORT HERE AND
HOW THOROUGHLY THEY HAVE
ENLISTED THE SUPPORT AND THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE WHOLE REGION
THEY'VE DONE A DARN GOOD JOB IT
WOULD BE KIND OF A MODEL I
WOULD SAY FOR- WHICH WE PROCEED
AHEAD WITH OTHER REGIONS.
SIMILARLY TRYING TO. MAKE A
COMEBACK SHALL I SAY IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT NICE NAME GO GROW
GREEN. GREEN GHOST FUNDING AS.
MADE WE CAN GO. THREE MEN GO.
IN ANY I JUST THE IT WOULD BUY-FAMILIARITY THAT- IN THE REGION
IT'S SOMETHING TO TAKE NOTE OF
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE IT AND WE DID HAVE
AN EXTENSIVE KIND OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THAT- AND
THE FACT THAT IT IT HITS THE
BIG CITIES MAJORITY THE MONEY
IS- GOES TO THE BIG CITIES AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
THE TEXAS BOWL TO THE SMALLER
RURAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL SO.
JUST KNOW THAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON
THAT AS WELL AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT WORKS FOR ALL OF
OUR JURISDICTIONS. THAT NEXT
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE. AND IF.
YOUR OPERATOR IF YOU COULD TELL
US- HOW MANY ARE IN THE QUEUE.
ABSOLUTELY AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
TWENTY FIVE IN THE QUEUE. OKAY
WE'LL TAKE THE NEXT COMMENT.
NEXT TO THE NUMBER FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ALFRED GIORDANO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS EQUITY
LINE. TODAY WE DO HAV THREE
SIMPLE CONTROL DEMAND WE URGE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR CONSIDERED AS BUDGET
AND LEGISLATION- BECAUSE SHE H.
CONTINUED WE WILL LOVE THE
ALLOCATION OF FIFTY MILLION THE
COLD BEERS FOR SOCIAL EQUITY
FUNDING THAT CALLED FOR. BY THE
HONORABLE SENATOR BRAD DURING
HIS BUDGET REQUEST ON MARCH
THIRTEENTH LOVE YOU GUYS
ALLOCATE FUNDS TO BE LABOUR'S
PROMISE AT SIX OH THREE SENATOR
BRADLEY AT B. SIX OPEN GOLF
VICTOR THIS PROMISE PRIORITIZE
THE CANNABIS EQUITY BACKSTOP IS
EMERGENCY STATEWIDE CANNABIS.
EQUITY PROGRAMMING CANNABIS-
COMMITTEE THIS IS THE SUPPORT
IN OF PROPOSAL AT B. NINE EIGHT
I CAN- SHE JUST IMPORTANT TO
TIME WEEK PRIOR. THE YOU LIKE
MEATBALLS IS A BALL IN IT OUT
SENTENCES- IN FACT IT MAY FOR
MARLOWE ANGELES THE PROMISES
HAVE BEEN COMPLICATED. OPTION
USING JUST RECOMMENDATIONS TO
HELP SECURE THE LEGISLATIVE
PROMISE THAT IT'S BEEN COLD FOR
AS FAR I THANK YOU AND I USE MY
TIME. TODAY THANK YOU VERY.
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS FOUR.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS MY NAME
IS OLENA SHOULD SHE BE ON
BEHALF OF LAS AMIGOS THE ORANGE
COUNTY AND I'M WITH THE COW A.
P. I. T. CV COALITION I'M
TESTIFYING ON I TURNED TWENTY
FIVE FOR REAL EQUITIES
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FUND A REAL
SAFETY NET FOR PEOPLE WHO'VE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL AID
REALLY. WE NEED TO MAKE UP FOR
THE SIMULANTS GAPS FOR EXCLUDED
WORKERS AND STRONGLY CONSIDER
WAIT YOUR PLACEMENTS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WITHOUT I. GI A AND IF NEW YORK
CAN DO IT WE CAN DO IT. THANK
YOU ON ANOTHER NOTE OF THE
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF A
SMALL NONPROFIT GLOBAL HOPE TO
FIFTY FIVE. WHY DID YOU GET A
PORTION OF THAT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT THE DAY IT
OPENED WE HAD YET TO GET. OUR
TURNS THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT NEXT IS
NUMBER FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PARAMILITARY MEMBERS
LIBBY SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF S.
E. I. U. CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE STANDS ALL
BUDGET AUGMENTATION PROPOSED IN
THE MAY REVISE AND ALSO UNDER
THE PLANET BUDGET PROPOSAL AS
IT RELATES TO HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY- WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF CONCERNS.
RAISED THE FIRST OF WHICH IS
WITH THE HOUSEWORK HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM- WE BELIEVE
THAT ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY TO
MAKE HER BOTH THOSE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY HOMELESS AND THOSE
THAT ARE AT RISK OF BEING HOME
ONCE- INSURE THAT THE PROGRAM
IS MOST EFFECTIVE. SECONDLY WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE- 25%
MATCH FOR THE COUNTY ADMIN-
ADMINISTERED PROGRAMS SUCH AS
BRING FAMILIES HOME HOME STATE
THAN H. TOP IT PROBABLY NOT 25%
MATCH REQUIREMENT REALLY I LIED
TO THE POTENTIAL THAT CERTAIN
COUNTIES THAT ARE JUST NOT AS
WELL FUNDED AS OTHERS ARE GOING
TO BE DISENFRANCHISED FROM THIS
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM. FINALLY
WOULD LIKE TO READ THE STARTING
STRONG THE PASSWORD FOR THE
USER WELL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM BUT WOULD LIKE TO
CONCUR WITH SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
PREVIOUSLY ABOUT WANTING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED IN A WAY THAT THOSE
COUNTRIES MOST IN NEED I THINK
LOOTING BERLIN SMALLER COUNTIES
WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THAT VERY.
ESSENTIAL FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. ACTUALLY NUMBER SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBERS MY NAME IS ERICA SAID
ABOUT THAT ON BEHALF OF THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME COALITION SPEAKING ON
ISSUE FIFTEEN FOR HOMEWORK
PROPOSAL I WANT TO REITERATE
WHAT WAS PREVIOUSLY SET BY ONE
OF OUR PARTNERS WHICH IS DOCTOR
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF
THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL. OUR
MULTI YEAR TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TOWARD
SOLVING HOMELESSNESS. AND WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCORPORATE THE PROVISIONS OF
THE PRINT CALIFORNIA HOME. TO
PROBABLE UNDER EIGHTY SEVENTY
ONE BY A FAMILY MEMBER. THE
THREE OF US INTO ALLOCATION TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME ACT WOULD
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY LOCAL
COOPERATION EQUITY. A LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP IT'S INTERESTING
CHALLENGES THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL IDENTIFIED WITH HAPPY
AND IT INCLUDES REQUIREMENTS
FROM STATE AGENCIES TO
COORDINATE. IT ALSO PROMOTES
DATA DRIVEN STATE AND LOCAL
DECISIONS ON HOW TO USE
FUNDING. THE COUPLE BUT BECAUSE
THE OFFERS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
PROPELLED UNPACKED BOXES AND
COULD DO A COUPLE THINGS WHAT
ARE THE KEY. COURT PROBLEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT NEXT IS NUMBER NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY
SORRY ABOUT THAT AMERICAN
INDIANS WITH ELLEN EQUITY
PARTNERSHIP AND THEN A GOOD
EMAIL ADDRESS THE LOCAL PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY DOES
THAT WORK. AND WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL- THE
ANTI DISPLACEMENT AND HELPING
CONVERSION PACKAGE FOR
EQUITABLE RECOVERY L.R. YOU
KNOW MY COLLEAGUE- ANYTIME
CONVENTION CENTER YEAH- WE
REALLY SPPORT UNIT FINDING THE
S. B. SENT SENATOR SKINNER'S SB
TEN THIRTY NINE. WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT LONG TERM SOLUTIONS
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BUILDING COMMITTEE WHILE- AND
THAT MEANT YOU KNOW RESOURCES
STAYING WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE FIVE YEAR PERIOD TWO
FOUR AND THE FORM OF A
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
HELPING PREVENTION PROGRAM. AND
THEN THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THE KEYPAD COMMITTEE AT THE
GYM- AND SO YEAH LIKE WHAT LIKE
WE WERE SAYING WE FEEL LIKE
THAT I THINK FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY THAT WE HAVE MORE
RENTERS VERSUS HOMEOWNERS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND SO IF WE FIND
THESE TYPES OF PERMANENT
AFFORDABLE FOR ABILITY- TYPE
HOUSING I WILL HELP WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO. TO YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT. OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THAT WAS SUPPORT OF THE- ANTI
DISPLACEMENT AND HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM THAT- THAT
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT
AND HOPEFULLY THAT THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY SUPPORT AS WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXUS NUMBER
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CURRENT I'M A FORMER BOSS.
ALMOST DONE HI FROM. EIGHTEEN
TWENTY AND I LOOKED AT IT AND
THE PARENTS AND THE SCHOOL
COLLEGE CORNER COREY GRAVES OUT
BRING CALIFORNIA HOME WHICH
INCLUDED 10% BY TWO THIRDS WHEN
A COMPANY HOMEWORK. I ALSO LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THREE
ITEMS AND MAY YOU LIVE BY EIGHT
MILLION FOUR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM AND THE FIVE
YELLING ABOUT NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM AND THE COUPLE LOOKING
CLUES THANK YOU BYE AND I'M P.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXTTO BE NUMBER
SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE SCRUFF BUCKLEY ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG. WE'D LIKE TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR IN THE SENATE FOR
PROTESTING HOMELESSNESS FUNDING
IN THE MAY REVISE ESPECIALLY IN
THIS THAT WE PRINT HOWEVER WE
CAN WITH OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COLLEGE REQUESTED DIRECT
ALLOCATION TO CITIES IN PARK
HALF ENOUGH TO GO IN HERE FOR
THE NEXT TWO YEARS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT. NEXT
IS SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GENERALLY
WARMER WHEN. YES. DID WE LOSE
THAT THE- INDIVIDUAL. GO TO THE
NEXT CALL OTHER LINE STILL OPEN.
I THINK WE NEED TO MOVE ON NOW
WE CAN MOVE ON TO NUMBER SIXTY
SIX- PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME'S
MARK STIVERS I'M CALLING FROM
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP. WITH RESPECT TO
ITEM SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN MAJOR
HOUSING COMPONENTS. VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSAL FOR ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO ADDRESS
THE BACKLOG OF. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY RECEIVED AN EIGHT YEAR
WAR BUT ARE STUCK IN THE QUEUE
WAITING DON'T COME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT. THOSE FUNDS WOULD MAKE
NINETY PROJECTS- GO TO
CONSTRUCTION WITHIN A MONTH.
OTHERWISE BE STUCK FOR A COUPLE
YEARS AND BRING ABOUT SIX
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ONLINE VERY
QUICKLY- WE'RE ALSO AND IN
SUPPORT OF THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR OPERATION TO.
PRESERVE THE AFFORDABILITY OF-
H. SHE ATTENDED DEVELOPMENTS
THAT- AT THE END OF THE
REGULATORY AGREEMENTS AND CAN
CONVERT TO MARK THE GREAT- THAT
THEY CAN ALWAYS LIKE NEW
CONSTRUCTION IT'S WE HAVE TO
KEEP THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT WE HAVE IF WE'RE GOING TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER. OF THE NEED
FOR A FORMAL HOUSE IN
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION ON
BOTH SIDES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT IS SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS KEVIN
AND GO WITH THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTY ITC
COALITION WE BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FIND A REAL
SAFETY NET FOR PEOPLE WHO'VE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL
RELIEF. AND THAT WOULD MEAN
MAKING UP FOR THE STIMULUS GAPS
FOR EXCLUDED WORKERS INCLUDING
THOSE WITHOUT HIGH TEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT IS SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
HIS LONG TRACK LEAD WITH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU
SPEAKING ON THE HOME WITH THE
PACKAGE ACCORDING TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE SENATE
BRING BACK BOLDLY PROPOSAL AND
SUPPORT THE USE OF THE
FRAMEWORK IN THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME ACCESS SHE THE
PROPOSAL FOR ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. THIS INCLUDES
NEWS OF A. 10% YOU SATISFIED
UNLESS YOU CAN MAKE UP 10% OF
THE HOMELESS POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA ON AVERAGE WHEN
LOOKING AT THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
WE ALSO WANT TO EXPECT THE PORT
THE COMPONENTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS NAMELY INCLUSION
OF H. C. B. EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM PRIORITIZING FORMER
BOXER CORPORATION YOU TAKE TAKE
IT TWENTY FOUR. FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR HOUSING NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM PRIORITIZING CURRENT
ARE YOU TAKING IT TWENTY ONE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S MANSION OF A
TARGETED APPROACH WITHIN HOME
KEEP THE THIRD YOU IDEALLY
USING THE FRAMEWORK DEVELOPED
BY SENATOR WIENER ANDEXECUTE.
VERY POOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. IN YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. THANKS THE NUMBERS FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
KATHY ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR
DEDICATING AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
POINT TWO BILLION TO EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND THE
JUBILEES PRINCIPALITIES. AND
COVERING A 100% ARREARS ACTIN
BRAND WHICH TENANT DESPERATELY
NEEDS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION TO IMPROVE
THE RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AND EXTENDS PROTECTION BEYOND
JUNE THIRTIETH TO ENSURE THAT
THE ASSISTANCE REACHES ALL WHO
NEED IT. WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR RECOGNIZING THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL TOOL TO PREVENT
ADDICTION TO PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES TRANSACTION DECLINED
HOWEVER WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASE THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING ANY WE URGE
YOU TO ADD A HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION ON TOP OF THE THREE
YEAR SIXTY MILLION PROPOSAL BY
THE GOVERNOR. WE DEFINITELY
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE WHOLE MONTH HIRING TAX
CREDIT AND LASTLY THE
GOVERNOR'S TWELVE BILLION
ALLOCATION FOR HOW. AN
IMPORTANT PROPOSAL THAT WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
ELIMINATE THE FUNDING FOR
CLEANUP OF COLLECTING MONEY AND
REDIRECT THAT FUNDING INTO
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL SERVICES
TO PERSONS LIVING IN THE WOODS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS NUMBER
SEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JANELLE IMMER WENN I AM
A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS- WHEN
I WAS AT CAL STATE FULLERTON
WITH MINE. SIX YEAR OLD SON AT
THE TIME I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
TO BRING CALIFORNIA HOME WHICH
INCLUDES A 10% OUTSIDE.
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH
I'D ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE THREE ITEMS IN
IT MAINLY BY. EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM- FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR HOUSING NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM AND THE PROPOSAL TO
INCLUDE YOU BUT ASIDE IN HOME
HEAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JANE
SCHROEDER WITH VERY CLEAN FOR
YOU. FIVE HOUSING INDEPENDENT
LIVING SERVICES THE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE AGING OUT OF
FOSTER CARE AND AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. THE PRESSURES ON
THE POPULATION HAVE REALLY
INCREASED OUR TIME AND- THE
COMPANY NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WE
WERE REALLY HEARTENING TO SEE
THE FOCUS ON USING THE GOVERNOR
FROM HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
INFRASTRUCTURE. PROPOSAL WITH
TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN PROJECT
HOME P. FOR YOU. ENCOURAGEMENT
TO ENSURING THAT NONPROFIT
AGENCIES THAT SERVE NEWS
DIRECTLY AND KNOW THE
POPULATION AND THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS. ARE ABLE TO DIRECTLY
APPLY FOR THE FUN. STRUCTURE
THAT WE BELIEVE AUTHOR OF YOUTH
AND YOUNG ADULTS THE ****
OUTLINED IN THE SUPPORT ACT
SENATOR WIENER BACK B. TWO
THIRTY FOUR. AND WE ALSO HOPE
THAT THERE WILL BE ANY
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FOR
HOMELESSNESS SERVICES WILL
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN A
SPECIFIED. FOR YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXIS SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND I'M SURE MEMBERS
MARTHA GUERRERO REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND- SPEAKING ON-
REGARDING PROJECT HOME KEY. I'D
BE WILLING TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION DIRECTLY TO YOU WE
HAVE MODIFIED OUR POLICY SO
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE A BETTER
BALANCE FOR EQUITY WE WOULD WE
WERE IDENTIFIED SIMILAR ISSUES.
AS THE SENATOR COM LONGER HAS
IDENTIFIED AND- THOSE POLICIES
ARE INCLUDED- IN EIGHTY SEVEN
YOU WANT TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS EQUITY- THAT- THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE MEMBER
GET THE TO DISCUSS- AND SO- WE
DO SUPPORT THE PROJECT HOME TO
FUNDING AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO- ADDRESS
FURTHER ISSUES THAT MAY COME
UP. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. PRECIADO VERY MUCH.
NEXT NEXUS SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CARE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEXIS AND I
AM A FORMER FOSTER YOU STAND
NOW ADVOCATE YOU WOULD WANT THE
GRANT THOMAS AND I'M CALLING TO
ECHO THE NEED AND EXPRESSED
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
BRINGING HOME WHICH INCLUDES
10% SATISFIED THE THIRD
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YEAH. I
THOUGHT I'D ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS IN THE MAY
REVISE THE EIGHT MILLION FOR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
THE FIVE MILLION FOR HOUSING
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM AND THE
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE A YOU HAD A
FIGHT IN HOCKEY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. WONDERFUL EVEN MY
NAME IS MATTHEW CAN'T YOU- WHAT
UNITED WAY THE CALIFORNIA AND
THE COUNTY I KEEP THE
COALITION- I'M CALLING IN
REGARDS TO THE- CONTACTING A
AND I FINANCIAL RESOURCES FOR
LOW INCOME WORKERS ON
CALIFORNIA ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO
FIND- REAL ESTATE UNIT PROPOSAL
FOR- FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES WHO
WERE LEFT OUT OF FEDERAL YOU
LOOKING AT I CAN AND THOSE WHO
ARE- POTENTIAL I CAN BECAUSE WE
HAVE NOT RECEIVED. YET AS WELL
AS CONSIDERING A WAITER
PLACEMENT- I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO- ADDITIONALLY THANK US
SENATOR CAFIERO OR HER COMMENTS
EARLIER RELATING TO THE- NEED
FOR INCREASED OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION- FOR- OUR NONPROFIT
PARTNERS- TO REACH THE
COMMUNITY- AND MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE AWARE OF THE
POTENTIAL FINANCIAL RESOURCES
THAT THEY CAN QUITE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT WILL BE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE DRIVE EURO MEMBERS STEVE
CRUZI CONSTRUCTORS DR COMMENT
ON BEHALF OF MAYOR SAM LICCARDO
AND THE CITY OF SAN JOSE. THE
CARD- ALSO SERVES AS CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA BIG CITY MAYORS
COALITION OF GRATITUDE GOES TO
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR CHAMPIONING
HISTORIC PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS THANKS FOR YOUR
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP WITH BIG
CITY WE SUPPORT THE ONGOING
INCREASED COMMITMENT ON THE%
PLANE AS OUTLINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE. WHATEVER
WE URGE YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP TO SUPPLEMENT THE
GOVERNOR'S TROUBLE IN OUR PLANS
THE CONDITIONAL FUNDING
OUTLINING YOUR BLUEPRINT
ADDITIONAL REQUEST THE DIRECT
ALLOCATION OF FLEXIBLE FUNDING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OF TWO
BILLION PER YEAR FOR TWO YEARS
UNDER EXISTING HAVE GUIDELINE
FORMULAS. STATES REGION
INVESTMENTS TO KEEP POPPING
HOME HE HAD HELPED CREATE MORE
THAN FIVE THOUSAND BEDS IN OUR
CITIES SERVING IN SHELTERING
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND ON HOUSE
RESIDENTS AND SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE. SUPPORT OF
YOUR BLUEPRINT ALONG WITH THE
DIRECT ALLOCATIONS. OF FUNDING
AT THAT ONE THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT IS THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY ONE
PILOTS ARE ALL MARGIN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF WORKSHEETS
SERVICES OKAY. YEAH SH WE
APPRECIATE THE EMPHASIS ON
USING THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL WITH THE RECORDED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION PROJECT THANK
YOU FOR YOU I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT
NONPROFIT AGENCIES DIRECTLY
STARTING THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO DIRECTLY APPLY FOR THE
FINE. STRUCTURE WE BELIEVE SIR
IF YOU DON'T TALK ABOUT THE BAD
pTHE TWO THIRTY FOUR WE ALSO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR YOU EVERYTHING. HAS A
GREATER INVESTMENT IN EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT AND YOUTH LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT EVERYTHING TO
AUTHENTICALLY. AND CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS- CALL. YEAH THE
HIGHWAY OF ADDRESSING YOU MUST.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT ANY FOR.
I THOUGHT IF I BRING WHICH IS
THAT SHE THAT LETS JUST. HAS
STRONG IN THE OR YEARS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
OREGON COUNCIL ACCORDING TO
COUNCIL REPRESENTS LEGACY
CULTIVATORS IN TRINITY THE
SCENE- SO NO MATTER THE DATA
AND MONTEREY COUNTIES SPEAKING
ON ISSUE TWENTY ONE EXPRESS
ACROSS THE BORDER FOR THE
PROPOSED ONE MILLION A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL ON.
THIS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND
THEIR PROFITS BEING A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE AT THAT
POINT IT OUT 82% OF ALL
AGENCIES ARE STILL THE
PROVISIONAL STATUS AT THIS TIME
WHAT I CAN GUARANTEE YOU IS
THAT THOSE WHO COME FORWARD TO
BE LICENSED IN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY WOULD LIKE TO DO THAT
AS QUICKLY ASPOSSIBLE THEY
DIDN'T GET INTO THE PROVISIONAL
SYSTEM TO SIT THERE FOR YEARS-
YOU KNOW ALL OF THEIR OWN
THROUGH THE CONFUSION OF THE
STATE LICENSING SYSTEM AT THE
STATE AND THE LOCAL LEVEL.
BECAUSE FOLKS HAVE BEEN LEFT IN
LIMBO SO WE APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING TO POTENTIALLY RESOLVE
THAT BACKLOG BUT WE WANT TO
KNOW TWO THINGS ONE THERE'S
STILL A STRUCTURAL ISSUE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DELAY IN
MOVING PEOPLE THROUGH THE
PROVISIONAL PROCESS. AND NUMBER
TWO WE REMAIN CONCERNED THAT
THERE IS ONLY A SIX MONTH
EXTENSION FOR NEW PROVISIONAL
LICENSEES AND ON RAMP FOR NEW
PROVISIONAL LICENSING TO WANT
TO COME INTO THE PROCESS AS AN
EXAMPLE. JUST DONE ON THE
EIGHTEENTH THE MODERATOR FOR
SUPERVISORS IS FINALLY REACHING
RESOLUTION UP THEIR OUTDOOR
CULTIVATION ORDINANCE FOR THE
FIRST TIME CULTIVATORS IN THAT
AREA WILL BE ABLE TO STEP INTO
THE LEGAL REGULATED SYSTEM IF
YOU WANNA RANCH HAS NOT
PROVIDED TO THEM TO CONTINUE
OPERATING WHILE THEY PURSUE
LICENSURE WE ARE AFRAID THAT
PEOPLE WILL NEVER COME OUT OF
THE DARK THEY WILL REMAIN IN
THE SHADOWS. AND HE WON'T
FOLLOW KERLEY STEP INTO THE
REGULATED PROCESS WE URGE IN
THE EXTENSION OF NEW
PROVISIONAL LICENSES SHOULD
CONTINUE TO TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
THANK. YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT NUMBER A ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS NUMBER ON THE OF THE
WAREHOUSE RECURRING CENTER
BECAUSE PART OF THE SAFETY NET
FOR ALL COALITION I'M CALLING
TO URGE ELECTED OFFICIALS HERE
TO SUPPORT THE GOLDEN STATE
KILLER THROWN TO. THE BUDGET
THAT REFLECTS CALIFORNIA VALUES
ARE DOCUMENTED WORKERS WERE
SOME OF THE HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES DURING THE PANDEMIC
SECOND ROUNDER YOU KNOW NOT
ENOUGH IN COMPARISON TO HOW
MUCH OUTPOURING TRICK WHILE AT
THE SECURITY NUMBERS HAVE
RECEIVED. IN AID THE PAST YEAR.
COMMITTED WORKERS PAY OVER
POINT TWO. DOLLARS EACH YEAR IN
TAXES TO HELP FUND CALIFORNIA
BUT HAVE NOT SEEN ANY OF THE
FUND UP UNTIL JUST RECENTLY.
AND HAS ONLY BEEN A SMALL MENU
SCHOOL OF ATTRACTION. HOW MUCH
FUN CONTENT I DOCUMENTED
WORKERS. MY MOM IS ONE OF THOSE
WORKERS QUITE PAY INTO THE TAX
SYSTEM. OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
I CANNOT BENEFIT. FROM IT WHEN
SHE NEEDS IT THE MOST. I THANK
YOU ALL TO HELP. HIM WITH
CAPTAIN PROVIDE. WAGER OUR
WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT TO
THE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER
SPONSORED POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
QUESTIONS ON- ON POVERTY ISSUE-
SEVEN WOODARD SUPPORTERS
VITAMIN WANNA THANK THE
MINISTRATION OF THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD FOR ENSURING THE
FUTURE. THE PROBLEM WONDER FOR
THE CARRIER TO SEE CRACKS
CREDIT SPECIALLY THOSE RIGHTS
ARE THAT'S WHAT OCCURS ON ISSUE
TWENTY FIVE ECHOING THE
COMMENTS THAT THEY MADE BY
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS. ABOUT
EXPANDING. THE GOLDEN STATE'S
FINANCE. INTERESTING TO NOTE
ALL CALLS ARE REGARDLESS. IF
THE FILES ESPECIALLY THOSE ARE
UNDOCUMENTED AND I CAN I CAN
REMEMBER- WEWOULD ALSO OCCURS
IN A COLLISION OF GENERAL
ASSISTANCE RECIPIENTS TO BE
INCLUDED IN BOTH STATES AND
THE- OTHER LEFT. OUT OF THE
RESTAURANT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI EVERYONE MY
NAME IS YVONNE WORLD SIGNED THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND MYSELF AT THAT AGEOF
FOURTEEN- HAD TO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS AND YOU HEARD FROM
YOU WHO EXPLAINS HOW MUCH YOURS
NOT ONLY HAS IT UNACCOMPANIED
YOU BUT AS A PARENT TO YOU AND
OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND SO
WITH THIS WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE IMPRESSIONS ON YOU CAN THE
GOVERNOR'S HOUSING AND HOMELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL AND.
WITH THE RECORDED TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. I HOME KEEP YOU. I
ENCOURAGE TO REALLY ENSURE THAT
NONPROFIT AGENCIES WHICH HAVE
BEEN FILLING THE GAPS FOR SO
LONG WITH THE MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES THAT HAVE INDOOR
DURING OUR TIME I ENCOURAGE US
TO PRIORITIZE MAKING SURE THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION RECEIVES
FUNDING AND NATIONAL CHURCH CAN
BE YOU KNOW LOOKED AT AND THE
SUPPORT. BY SENATOR SCOTT
WIENER- AND ASKED ME TO THREE
FOUR AND WITH ALL AND ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING RESOURCES
TO- YOU KNOW COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE LOOK TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE YOU
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OVER
50% OF INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AS AN
ADULT SHE HAD THE EXPERIENCE
THAT I MEAN YOU. I THINK
SPANISH THANK YOU PERFORM YOU
THAT EXPLANATION WE NEED TO ACT
NOW AND WE APPRECIATE THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION I REALLY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT SHE KNOWS.
GET WHAT THEY NEED THE SERVER.
IN YOUTH HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DON'T
LOOK THAT ONLY COMES OUT ALONG
WITH A WAREHOUSE WORKER
RESOURCE AND I'M PART OF THE
SAFETY NET FOR ALL COALITION
I'M CALLING TODAY TO DEMAND
THAT CALIFORNIA PUT FORTH A
REAL EQUITY PROGRAM GOLDEN
STATE KILLER- POINT- THAT'S
REALLY GOING TO PROVIDE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY UNACCEPTABLE THAT
CALIFORNIA ROLLED ON THE TITLE
OF THE CENTRAL WORKER LAST
YEAR. PUTTING ON DOCUMENT. THE
COMMUNITY. WITHOUT PROVIDING
EVERYTHING THEY NEEDED TO.
DEEPER THINGS GO OUT THE CRIME.
I THINK IT'S A SHOW THAT DORK.
I'M OVER FORWARD WHAT WE ARE
LOCKED EVEN THOUGH WE ARE. EVEN
THOUGH OUR THRIVE OFF OF THE
BACK OF A DOCUMENT THE
COMMITTEE THAT LOOKED LIKE YOU.
KNOW LIKE MY PARENTS I ALSO
WANTED TO COME IN. EARLIER
ALEXANDER HAMILTON BUT
SOMETHING THAT WAS QUITE THE
THIRTEEN WHEN YOU STEP OUT ALL
WE WERE GOING TO BE ABLE. TO
FIGHT THE- I'M INSPIRED WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE IN CAR.
IF SUCH A SHAME BUT WE COME.
OUR COMMUNITY. AND YOU SHOULD
BE ASHAMED FOR HAVING MADE THAT
COMMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS SABRINA SANTIAGO AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF GOLDEN
STATE OPPORTUNITY I WANT TO
ECHO THE CULTURE AND GENEROUS
AS POSSIBLE GOLDEN STATE THE
MILLERS TO ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF PREVIOUS
AND FEDERAL SUPPORT STAGE AS
THE PREVIOUS CALLER SAID OF THE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY I
COMPILERS AND LOTS OF OTHER
FOLKS. DEPEND ON THE- DESERVE%
THIS MONEY FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY PUT IN OVER THE LAST YEAR-
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THE COUNTY. OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AS SHE
NOTED. THE PROGRAM REALLY HELPS
REACH THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISCONNECTED AND DESTRUCTIVE
VERMIN. AND IT DID NOT COME
FOLK WHO ARE LEARNING FROM IT
BECAUSE THERE IS A NEW STORY.
OKAY AGREEMENT BECAUSE WE GO IN
WITH CUT TRUSTEDCOMMUNITY
PARTNERS. AND HELP THEM TO-
BUILD THAT RELATIONSHIP I ALSO
WANT TO THINK THOUGH THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
OUTREACH WE APPROPRIATION WHICH
UNDERSCORES THE NEED- ONGOING
FUNDING THAT ORGANIZATION CAN
BEND DOWN. IN A TIMELY FASHION
THIS WAS- IT'S A GREAT RESOURCE
BUT WE ALSO JUST NEED ENOUGH
TIME TO BE ABLE TO DO IT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
WILL BE EIGHTY FIVE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SPARKY
HARLAN AND I'M CEO BILL WILSON
CENTER- SERVING OVER NINE
HUNDRED HOMELESS YOUTH AND
FAMILY MEMBERS AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND SANTA CRUZ COUNTIES
AND I'M- DELIGHTED TO SUPPORT
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION SET
ASIDE FOR HOMELESS YOUTH AND
THE HOME KEY PROGRAM. WE'VE
BEEN BATTLING SET ASIDE FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH FOR DECADES IN
ADVANCE BECAUSE THEY'RE OFTEN
UNDERCOUNTED THE 10% NUMBER-
WHEN YOU'RE NOT TARGETING POINT
IN TIME COUNTS IT'S LOW SANTA
CLARA COUNTY COUNTED 20% OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION AS BEING
USED THE LAST TIME AROUND SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY. LAST YEAR 29% OF
THE HOMELESS POPULATION WHERE
YOU SAID 10% IS A MINIMUM I
ALSO URGE YOU TO BE SURE THAT
IT LINKED UP WITH THE YOUTH
PROVIDER WHAT MY COMMUNITY HAS
DONE IN THE PAST IS CHERRY
PICKED THE NUMBER OF YOUNG
ADULTS BEING SERVED AND
COMPOUNDED THAT AS THEIR YOUTH
SET INSIDE SERVICES SO I DO
HOME WAS A COLLEGE STUDENT I DO
HOMELESS FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
AND I TELL YOU INVOLVING YOUNG
PEOPLE AND INVOLVING SERVICE
PROVIDERS IS THE BEST WAY FOR
ASSURING THIS POPULATION CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL AND NOT BECOME OUR
ADULT. HOMELESS POPULATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT PLAY.
NEXT IS EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JOE MAKER AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THAT STATIC LEGAL
SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES AS WELL
AND BE SAFE ENOUGH FOR ALL
COALITION I'M CALLING REGARDING
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS TO
POINT NOW. THE FUN OF THE
SECOND GOLDEN STATE STIMULANTS
ARE MUCH NEEDED HOWEVER CURRENT
ROPOSAL STILL LEAVES FAR TOO
MANY WORKERS AND FAMILIES WHO
HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND
RESIDENTS WITHOUT AS IT STANDS
OR I. THE SENATE TO TAKE UP THE
OILERS RECOMMENDATION TO
EXPANSION WAS TO UNDOCUMENTED
FAMILIES WHO'VE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM PREVIOUS PAYMENTS. AND THE
BUDGET MUST ALSO GO FURTHER BY
PROVIDING WEIGHT REPLACEMENT
THE FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. COULD YOU
CHECK AND SEE HOW MANY PEOPLE
WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE I THINK
I'M GONNA NEED TO- TO. ASK
PEOPLE THIS WOULD BE VERY
SPECIFIC AND JUST GIVE US THEIR
NAME. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
SEVEN IN THE QUEUE- OKAY WE'LL
CONTINUE THE WAY WE'RE DOING IT
I THINK. IT JUST WE GOT UP TO
THE SEVENTIES IN THE EIGHTIES.
AND I THOUGHT OH MY GOSH. IT'S
GOING TO TAKE ALL NIGHT SO.
THANK YOU. IT WILL TAKE THE
NEXT THE COLOR PLEASE.
ABSOLUTELY NUMBER THE NEXT ONE
IS NUMBER NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BASICALLY- GOLDBERG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK WE ARE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT STORED PERMANENTLY
PORTABLE HOUSING AND BUILD
COMMUNITY OWNERSHIP WE ARE
ASKING THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
THE ANTI DISPLACEMENT AND
HOUSING PRESERVATION PACKAGE.
WHICH WOULD MAKE FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO NONPROFITS
STATEWIDE HOUSING AND
FORECLOSURE AND MAINTAINED FOR
TOO MANY BENEFITS TO THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION.
HOUSING PRESERVATION PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM THAT FOR CLOSURE.
MADE POSSIBLE BY AT NINE. THE
PACKAGE WOULD ALSO SUPPORT THE
ACQUISITION AND REHAB MARKET
RATE HOUSING THE COMPANY
ACQUISITION AND PRESERVATION
PROGRAM WHICH YOU HEARD ABOUT
EARLIER. THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
CRITICAL PARK NEEDS SUPPORT THE
KIND OF CULTURE THE SPECULATION
CRISES BUT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST DECADE CREDIT TO OUR
DISPLACEMENT BLACK AND BROWN
THE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
SAID THIS PACKAGE PROVIDES US
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY BY PHONE
WILL TURN AND CREATE NEW
PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAREN
I'M GREAT AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF WORKSAFE BASED IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I'M ALSO
WITH SAFETY NET FOR ALL
COALITION. I'M CALLING FOR YOU
ALL TO SUPPORT THE GOLDEN STATE
KILLER TWO POINT NOW. A REAL
EQUITY CALIFORNIA SHOULD PONDER
REAL SAFETY NET FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL
RELIEF. WE NEED TO MAKE UP FOR
SALE GAB FOR EXCLUDED WORKERS
AND STRONGLY CONSIDER WAIT YOUR
PLATE NUMBER ALL CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITHOUT I TEND.
NEW YORK CAN DO WHAT WE CAN DO
IT. CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO STEP UP
AND MUST SUPPORT THE UNDER
DOCUMENTED- WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN PAYING INTO OUR ECONOMY
MAKING OUR ECONOMY THRIVE BUT
NOT RECEIVING THE ADEQUATE
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT IN RETURN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JORDAN HAVE A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION WE APRECIATE THE
EMPHASIS ON YOUTH IN THE
GOVERNOR'S HOUSING AND HOME AND
HOMELESSNESS INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL WITH THE REPORTED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN HOME
KEY PROJECT FOR YOU AND WHAT
ENCOURAGED THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT THAT NONPROFIT
AGENCIES SERVING. DIRECTLY
CURRENT AND FORMER FOX EITHER
ABLE TO DIRECTLY APPLY FOR
THESE PLANS WHICH IS OUTLINED
ON XP TWO THIRTY FOURTH
DISTRICT COURT ACTORS WE ALSO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR HOMELESSNESS SERVICES AND
WANT TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
DOLLAR FOR SERVICE SHOULD.
CONTINUE TO- I SET ASIDE FOR
YOU WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAMS IN THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR HOUSING NAVIGATOR
PROGRAMS ARE PROUD SUPPORTERS
OF EIGHT B. SEVENTY ONE.
BERKELEY YOUTH HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
DURING ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND
THE PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED
THE TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS THE
CURRENT FORMER BOSS YOU OUT
CURRENT AND FORMER FOX YOU
FACE. CALGARY NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE YOU WHO ARE IN
FOSTER CARE OR HAPPY EXPERIENCE
THE CALIFORNIA. FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLAY. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS COULD G. AND CO FOUNDER OF
THE US EQUITY OWNERS AND
WORKERS IN ASSOCIATION. AND I'M
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS EQUITY ALLIANCE WE
REQUEST. HERE THE VOICE THE
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. I'VE BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE WAR ON DRUGS CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET IS A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND ONLY FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE CANNABIS
EQUITY PROGRAM. WE URGE THE
MEMBER TO PRIORITIZE EQUITY IN
YOUR BUDGET APPROPRIATION WE
URGE YOU TO PUBLIC TENDER
BRADFORD TO DELL THE CLERK
THREE. PROMINENT BLACK HERE IN
FIVE NINETY FIVE WE NEED TO BE
DEFERRALS AND FEE WAIVERS IN
ORDER TO GET OUT OF BUSINESS
OKAY. IN ADDITION PLEASE REPORT
NUMBER OF GRAPHIC BUDGET
REQUEST ALLOCATING FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WE NEED AND
THEN CREATE WE SHOULD BE CLOSE
TO THE FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS. THAT MEANT.
I AND CREATE. THAT WILL TRAIN
THE LAN. OF BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU YES WE CAN HEAR HIM. A
WONDERFUL HI MY NAME IS EVELYN
SCOTT ON THE SOCIAL EQUITY
ENTREPRENEUR I'M ALSO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS EQUITY
ALLIANCE- AND WE HAVE THREE
DEMANDS THE DAY THAT WE ARE
DEALING JUST LATER AND THE
GOVERNOR TO CONSIDER AND BUDGET
AND LEGISLATIVE. NEGOTIATIONS
CONTINUE WINDS WILL AFTER YOU
LOOK AT YOU GUYS THE POWER
THANK CANADA'S EQUITY BY
SANDWICHING AN EMERGENCY
STATEWIDE CANNABIS EQUITY
PROGRAM WHAT THE CANNABIS
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE. SUPPORTING
POLICY PROPOSAL AND BEAT THREE
NINETY EIGHT BY EDITOR IN CHIEF
WHO ALSO LIKE YOU GUYS TO
ALLOCATE THE FUNDS TO THE
SHOULD IT BE WAIVERS PERMITTING
F. B. SIX OH THREE SENATOR
BROOKE. BRADBURY AT LEAST SIX
OH THREE WILL BE HELPED WELL
HELPFUL FILTERS THE COMIC. SHE
ALSO ALLOCATION AS THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO GO TO
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE EQUITY
FINDING. A COMPLIMENTARY
BRADBURY IN HIS BUDGET REQUEST
AS OF MARCH FIFTEENTH WE ARGUE
THAT THE POWER THE- POWER THANK
CANADA'S EQUITY BECAUSE THIS
MIGHT BE THE DAY. THAT THE
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITY WE
NEED WE NEED THE FUNDING. WE
NEED. THEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK PLEASE. THANKS
TO NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY TOM WITH THE
CITY OF SECTOR. AND WE ARE A
MEMBER OF THE SACRAMENTO
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS WE
SUPPORT THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTING IMPERIAL'S SP
THREE SEVENTY FIVE PLANS BUT WE
NEED MORE WE ASKED SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IS ALLOCATED TO SAY COG
TO IMPLEMENT OUR GREEN MEANS GO
CLAM FOR INFILL HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS.
THE WATER AND SEWER CAPACITY
AND WE ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
INCLUDE THAT SPECIFIC ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CHICAGO IN THE FINAL BUDGET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. NEXT IS ONE OH TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY MY
NAME IS NINA PART I AM CALLING
IN A REPRESENTATION OF THE DAY-
EQUITY TRADER NETWORK WHICH IS
ALSO PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS EQUITY ALLIANCE- ALSO
HERE TO SUPPORT THE THREE THREE
DEMANDS THAT WE HAVE WHICH IS
THAT THAT- ALLOCATION OF AT
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION MORE
DOLLARS TO GO BAD FINE FOR TO
SUPPORT THE SOCIAL EQUITY
PROGRAM- BECAUSE THE SOCIAL
EQUITY PROGRAMS WHICH ARE THE
FIRST OF ITS KIND OF WITHIN THE
COUNTRY THAT ARE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED- CAME FROM
LOCALITIES. THE WAY THAT THE
BUDGET FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISBURSED IS BAD. IT WAS THE
ONLY BASED ON THE FEW. EQUITY
PROBE WE- THAT NOW AROUND TEN
EQUITY PROGRAMS THAT EXIST WITH
ONLY FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
ASSETS ALLOCATION SO IT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY MAKE SENSE WE HAVE TO
INCREASE TE BUDGET- BY FIFTY
MILLION THAT WIDE BUT ALREADY
PROPOSED BY SENATOR BRADFORD-
AND THEN ALSO- WE NEEDED THEIR
APPROVAL FOR THAT FOR THE C.
WAIVERS THAT WERE PROMISED IN
AT THE NINETY FOUR BUT THAT.
THE BUDGET ALLOCATION OR JUST
NEVER- PUSHED THROUGH LAST YEAR
SO- SIX OH THREE AND IT BEING
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WILL
ACTUALLY ALLOW THAT PROMISE- TO
OUR EQUITY BUSINESS THERE. SO-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NICK
PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU HOW
MANY MORE- PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
SPEAK BECAUSE I'M I THINK I'M
GONNA GET TO THE POINT WHERE I
JUST SAY GIVE ME YOUR NAME AND
THEN GIVE ME THE ITEM NUMBER.
BUT WE ARE BACK ON. THE QUEUE
ALL RIGHT THEN WE'RE NOW AT THE
NAME AND THE NUMBER AND IF
SOMEONE ELSE HAS SAID SOMETHING
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR JUST SAY
I AGREE WITH THEM. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE. OKAY ONLY SOMEONE WITH
A SAFETY NET FOR A COLLISION-
AND WE JUST WANTED TO.
EMPHASIZE THE FACT THAT- A LOT
OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN LEFT
OUT FROM. THE STIMULUS OF
SPECIALLY ON PEOPLE WITHOUT ID
NUMBERS AND REALIZING THAT
THERE. WILL BE A CORE OF LIKE
SAY CONNIE AND REALIZING THAT
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO ARE
PUTTING OUT. THEIR LIFE IN
DANGER DURING THIS CONDEMNING-
BUT SHOULD BE WHEN THEY CAN
AFFORD TO YOU KNOW WORK ONLINE.
SO THAT'S IT THANK YOU AND IF
HE CAN DO IT THEN WE CAN DO IT
AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. THANK PLEASE.
THANKS TO EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHEN I READ THE NUMBER.
WHEN IT'S ON THE LETTER THERE
WILL BE A LITTLE. BROWN YEAH.
IT WILL BE THERE ARE A LOT OF
FUN GUARANTEES TO NINE IN YOUR
I. WILL COME BACK AND TALK.
BEYOND THAT BLOCK OF BERNARDI
ARE. HELLO YOU FOR. THANK I E.
B. RIGHT NOW ARE THERE. IN THE
FIRST OF RANKS YEAH YES YES THE
NECK PLEASE. NEXT NUMBER ONE OH
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS HALEY CORP AND I'M CALLING
ALSO IN AGREEMENT- JUDY CALIBER
YOU CAN'T EXACTLY ALLIANCE AND
R. THREE TENTHS OF A MAN- ALL
URGING LEGISLATORS AND THE
GOVERNOR TO CONSIDER BUDGET AND
LET THE LEGISLATIVE NEGOTIATION
AND- AN ALLOCATION OF FIFTY
MILLION TO GO BIZ FOR SOCIAL
EQUITY FUNDING THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE OF SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS FINALLY. MAY I KNOW
WHAT THAT'S GOING TO COME BACK
OVER TO THE CENTER I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THEIR DOMESTIC
WORKERS. OR FRIENDS ARE ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAVE
AN IMAGE OF THE KALYA MASSAGE
AND CODY ENTREPRENEUR HERE IN
LOS ANGELES MICHAEL THE SAME
THING OF MY CONSTITUENTS- KEEP
A KEY EVIDENCE COTTON IN THE
PARKS BASICALLY IN THE
ADVOCACY- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS EQUITY ONLINE THROUGH
DEMAND. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS
ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JAMES HARDY I AM
CALLING THE CALIFORNIA CAN THE
COMPANY ALLIANCE I'M CALLING TO
REQUEST YOU PRIORITIZE EQUITY
NOW- YOU ALLOCATE FUNDS TO THE
FEE WAIVERS THAT WERE PROMISED
THE NEXT VEHICLE THREE AND THE
ALLOCATION OF FIFTY MILLION TO
GO BAD FOR SOCIAL EQUITY
FUNDING THAT SENATOR BACKWARDS
BEFORE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT TO
BE ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M CALLING FROM THE
SOCIAL EQUITY FROM LOS ANGELES
MY NAME IS CAN BE WASHING.
CALLING TO ASK THE LEGISLATIVE
IN CONGRESS EVERYONE PLEASE
RELEASE THOSE FUNDS FOR OUR-
SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAM A LOT OF
THOSE ARE HURTING. BECAUSE OF
LEGAL FUND I'M ALREADY UP FOR
INSPECTION AND I STILL HAVE NO
FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO BE OLD
PLEASE YOU KNOW RELEASE THE
FUNDS TO US THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT IS ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
PHOTOBOMB I'M A MEMBER FOR
INVOICES CALIFORNIA I'M SO
BEFORE THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL
POLICEMEN WE NEED TO CREATE ALL
REAL EQUITY ON PROBABLY FOR
INDIA ARE WE STILL RECOGNIZE
THE PEOPLE THAT I WORK FOR-
UNDER CALIFORNIA HEAT WE NEED
TO SUPPORT THE PEOPLE THAT I
HAVE AN ID NUMBER AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT. IT CALLED THE
FEDERAL RELIEF I. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR THAT WHEN I. YES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS EDWARD FLOORS AND I'M
AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
PATHOLOGY WITH THE YOU CAN MAKE
THAT COMMUNITY AND LABOR CENTER
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
PUBLIC GOOD THAT WHICH
REPLACEMENT FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS WITH SIR FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WAGE
REPLACEMENT HAS BEEN A KEY
POLICY FOR PROTECTING THE WELL
BEING OF OUR NATION'S WORKERS
IN THE COMING CRISIS HOWEVER
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ARE THE
ONLY GROUP PROHIBITED FROM
RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AS A RESULT THE CODED
CARCASSES HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. IN OUR
ANALYSIS- FROM- THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE
CONTENTS OF THAT FILE WE FOUND
AT THE FOOT IN THE FIRST TEN
MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC.
IMMIGRANTS COMPRISE 35% OF
PANDEMIC RELATED DEATHS AMONG
WORKERS AGED PERSONS BUT THEY
ACCOUNTED 4403% OF PANDEMIC
RELATED DEATHS AMONG WORKERS
AND THOSE INDUSTRIES AT THE
HIGHEST RISK OF THE SPREAD OF
KOBE AGRICULTURE FOOD
PROCESSING RESTAURANT EMIGRANTS
WERE 58% OF PANDEMIC RELATED.
ENABLING WAGE REPLACEMENT
ALLOWS WORKERS TO TAKE TIME OFF
FOR COVERT SYMPTOMS TO CARE FOR
CHILDREN THAT ARE HOME FROM
SCHOOL TO CARE FOR A SICK
FAMILY MEMBER TO COPE WITH THE
DEVASTATING LOSS OF A LOVED%
ONE. THE PINNACLE PROTEST TO
PANIC ATTACKS A NATION OR TO
DEAL WITH THE VACCINATION SIDE
EFFECTS AND CONTRARY TO PUBLIC
DISCOURSE ABOUT LATINOS BEING
BACKED INTO THE TENT AND
NEEDING EDUCATION A RECENT
SURVEY BY KAISER HEALTH NEWS
FOUND THAT UNVACCINATED LATINOS
ARE TWICE AS LIKELY TO WANT A
COVERT ACTION ACTION THAN
WHITES OR BLACKS. BUT AMONG THE
UNVACCINATED AMONG POTENTIAL
UNDOCUMENTED LATINOS NEARLY
THREE AND FOUR WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT MISSING WORK AT THE SIDE
EFFECTS MAKE THEM FEEL SICK FOR
A DAY OR MORE- IN OTHER WORDS
THEY HAD TO MAKE TOUGH CHOICES
ABOUT SHE- TAKING THE MAX MAX
THE NATION O SHOWING UP TO
WORK. WHICH REPLACEMENT FRIEND
DOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WILL
PROVIDE A PUBLIC GOOD TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT'LL
PROVIDE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WITH THE SAME
SAFETY NET THAT IS HELPING TO
MITIGATE THE COOKIE CRISIS
AMONG CITIZEN WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT IS ONE EIGHTEEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD- WHEN I STARTED BACK IN
BUT THERE FOR ME NO CLEAR UP
FOR. YES SIR ALAN BALL A NUMBER
OF THEM BECAUSE ME THAT ARE
COMMONLY PRESENT BUDGET BUT
THOUGHT THAT THERE WERE NOT
ENOUGH FOR AN ITALIAN GUY YOUR
YEAH HE. BUT BECAUSE THAT ARE
FUNDED. THE YOUNG MAN HE- ARE.
THOSE ON THE PLANET I'M NOT. HE
AT YOUR BANK. FIVE K. FOR. A
PLACE DOWN IN THERE CULTURE TO.
TELL YOU WHAT YOU CAN DO A LOT
WITH IT. ABOUT THOSE BUT OPEN.
ABBOT I THANK YOU HAVING THE
YEAH NINE SEVEN LIVE IN. LEVEL
OUT BUT I THOUGHT I LEFT A
BUNCH CAN BE YOU THERE ARE YOU.
AT THE FAMILY COMPOUND GOT
ABOUT THAT DON'T THINK EAL
ELECTRICAL THAT AND BLACK ABOUT
NINETY BUT I ALMOST. AT THE
TIME I GOT A YOUNG THE
NINETEEN. YEAR OLD BOY. NO SO
THE A WALK UP THE ROAD FROM ME
YOU GOT IT. TO OUT HIS INTO.
SOCIOLOGY MUST GIVE MARKETED AS
THEY SAY LET ME EVEN ON A
MECHANIC IN THE SEC IT IS
STORY. THE CARD LOOK ON LOOK AT
THE WHOLE LESSON NOTIFICATION
YET MUCH CAN DO MOST OF IT SO
NOBODY. HE AND THE KIDS. I'M
EMPHATICALLY THAT THE K. IT
KATE IS. I ASK- SUPPORT BATTLE.
IT. MIGHT BE AN APPLE YOU.
PRIORITIZED IT WILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. NEXT
PLEASE. NEGATIVE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS A RAIN QUICKLY THAT
ENCOMPASS CENA AND I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE. THAT NEEDED A
COMPANY NOT THE NETWORK OF
WOMEN FARMWORKER LEADERS ARE
WITH THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL
COALITION. WE CAN- REAL EQUITY
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FIND A REAL
SAFETY NET FOR PEOPLE WHO'VE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL
RELIEF AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF. OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THAT ARE ARE MARKET LEADERS.
AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY CAN YOU
HEALTH WORKERS WHO ARE
RESPONDING TO THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE OVER
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AS WELL.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. HELLO THIS IS
MARCY LYLES I'M CALLING TO A
DEGREE WHERE. THE CANNABIS-
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS EQUITY
ALLIANCE AND WE'RE ASKING THAT
YOU PRIORITIZE EQUITY. AND WE
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING AND HERE NOT OUT
ON THAT CANNABIS. PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE GOING ON THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. NEXT
PLEASE. IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT
FOR OUR NEXT- PUBLIC COMMENT.
OUR NEXT PUBLIC CALLER
COMPLAINED OF ONE TWENTY THREE.
ONE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT ONE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THEY WILL
MOVE ON- AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO FURTHER IN OUR QUEUE. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH- LET ME
JUST. I SAY THAT HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC- COLLEAGUES DO YOU HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. ABC
NINE. I WANT TO THANK YOU TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY- IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR TO VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
SUGGESTIONS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I AM YOUR
TESTIMONY IS REALLY IMPORTANT
WE TAKE IT VERY SERIOUSLY AND
MOST OF THESE ITEMS ARE KEPT
OPEN SO THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE
DONE ON HIM. KNOW THAT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE THIS INFORMATION
AND- TRY TO PUT TOGETHER THE
BEST PLAN THAT WE CAN IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE ASSEMBLY
AND WITH THE GOVERNOR
OBVIOUSLY. SO WE'RE GONNA GET
READY TO VOTE AND I'M JUST
GONNA WAIT IT REAL QUICK MINUTE
WE HAVEWHERE WE HAVE ONE
MEMBER THAT IS- ON HIS WAY.
AND- I WANT TO MAKE SURE HE
HEARS THE- THE MOTION AND IS IN
IS IN AGREEMENT WITH IT. I
REALLY WANT TO THANK THOSE
MEMBERS WHO WERE- WHO WERE
BRIEF I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
KNOW I HATE IT I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN ON THE LINE FOR A LONG
TIME AND- THAT YOU REALLY WANT
TO SAY A LOT BUT IT IT REALLY
HELPS US A LOT WE KINDA GET
WHERE YOU'RE GOING. WANT TO SEE
WHAT THE ISSUE IS AND- SO OUT
WE APPRECIATE THAT.
HERE'S THE
RIGHT. NUMBERS THERE'S NO PROB
WE UNDER YOU WERE HOLDING DOWN
THE FORT AT THE ASSEMBLY
HEARING AND I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE I WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
THERE TO. SO I DID MY THANK YOU
FOR EVERYBODY THAT AND SO WE'RE
NOW READY TO VOTE ON. ON THESE
ISSUES AND I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE YOU HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE AS WELL. READY TO VOTE ON
ISSUE NUMBER. TO THREE.
1-078-910-1112 THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN A NELSON ART. OKAY WE
NEED A MOTION FIRST AND WE GOT
THE MOTION FROM SENATOR CAN
LONGER. THAT IS NO PROBLEM- AND
SO WILL I TAKE THE VOTE NOW.
HAVE A ERA I HAVE A ROI TIME
LONGER. TIME LONGER I NIELSEN
NILSSON I. THE MOTION PASSES
THREE EYES. NO ZERO- AND- AND
THESE WERE ON THE STAFF AND
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THESE
PARTICULAR ITEMS SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR- YOUR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY THAT-
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING. SAY THAT
AGAIN. YEAH. WE OKAY. THAT'S
RIGHT. IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY
FOLKS SO I TOTALLY MISSED THAT
WE NOW HAVE TO FOCUS ON ISSUES
NUMBER ONE AND FIVE DO WE HAVE
A MOTION THAT SENATOR CAM AUGER
MAKES THE MOTION AND THE MOTION
IS TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON TODAY'S
AGENDA FOR THESE ITEMS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF AERO. HI HAVE
A ROI TIME LONGER I AM LONGER
ALLY NELSON RIGHT. THE FOOD NO
NO NO. THEY ALSO NOW SHOWED ME.
I TO KNOW IS ONE- DEMO PASSED.
THAT'S THE IT FOR TODAY THANK
YOU TO FOR PATIENCE A COPPER WE
HAVING CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HERE HEARING THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MORE.